>> SENATE COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT
WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US FOR
THIS MEETING.
THE SENATE WELCOMES THE PUBLIC
IN PERSON,
AND WE ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS
HERE IN THE STATE CAPITOL.
I ASK ALL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE
BE PRESENT IN ROOM 112
SO WE CAN ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM
AND BEGIN OUR MEETING.
WE HAD 24 BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA,
SIX OF WHICH ARE ON CONSENT.
THOSE ITEMS ARE.
ITEM THREE AB 353 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES.
ITEM EIGHT AB 2962 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PAPAN.
ITEM 13 UM AB 2430 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALVAREZ.
ITEM 14 AB 2455 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL.
ITEM 18 AB 2663 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON
AND ITEM 23 AB 3116 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA.
UM.
A FEW HOUSEKEEPING NOTES.
WE HAVE A SPECIAL ORDER FOR TWO
ITEMS ACA TEN AND AB 2813,
BOTH BY MAJORITY LEADER AGUILAR
CURRY.
WE WILL NEED ALL MEMBERS TO BE
PRESENT TO VOTE ON
THESE ITEMS AS SOON AS WE ARE
DONE WITH THEM,
SO I ENCOURAGE MEMBERS TO ARRIVE
QUICKLY.
SENATE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE
HAS A HARD STOP AT 6 P.M.
TODAY DUE TO SENATE FLOOR
SESSION.
I ENCOURAGE AUTHORS TO BE
WATCHING OUR
HEARING AND BE PROMPT WHEN YOUR
BILL
IS UP NEXT DUE TO THE HARD STOP
AT 6 P.M.,
DEPENDING ON WHAT IS LEFT OVER,
WE WILL EITHER COME BACK AFTER
SENATE
FLOOR SESSION AROUND 9 P.M.,
OR WE WILL ROLL OVER YOUR BILLS
TO
OUR NEXT HEARING ON JULY 3RD.
I ENCOURAGE ALL AUTHORS AND THE
PUBLIC
TO BE QUICK AND TO THE POINT,
SO WE CAN GET THROUGH OUR AGENDA
TODAY.
I DON'T YET.
>> HEAR THE START OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
OKAY, OKAY.
OKAY.
NOT DONE.
>> BY SIX.
WE HAVE TO COME BACK AT NINE.
HOW MANY BILLS WE GOT?
>> NO, YOU DON'T WANT TO.
ACCEPT IN MY ROOM.
OKAY, UM, WE DON'T YET HAVE
QUORUM,
BUT I APPRECIATE THE MEMBERS WHO
ARE HERE ON TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM, BUT WE
WILL BEGIN
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE SO THAT OUR,
UM, ASSEMBLY MAJORITY LEADER
CAN PROCEED.
MAJORITY LEADER AGUILAR CURRY.
WELCOME.
TRY TO GET YOU OUT OF HERE.
BEST.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT MY BILLS IN SPECIAL
ORDER TODAY.
AC ONE IS ON THE BALLOT THIS
NOVEMBER.
NOTHING ABOUT TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS WILL CHANGE THAT.
AC TEN SIMPLY AMENDS AC ONE TO
REMOVE
THE SPECIAL TAX PROVISIONS.
I FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SHOULD HAVE MULTIPLE
FINANCING TOOLS AVAILABLE TO
THEM,
INCLUDING SPECIAL TAXES.
BUT SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO BE
WILLING
TO ACCEPT INCREMENTAL
IMPROVEMENTS SO WE CAN
ACCOMPLISH AS MUCH AS WE CAN.
WITH YOUR SUPPORT OF AC TEN
TODAY.
OUR CONSTITUENTS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT
WILL HAVE BONDING
AVAILABILITY TO THEM AT A 55%
VOTE THRESHOLD,
GIVING THEM REASONABLE ACCESS
TO THIS TOOL FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS.
THE HISTORIC ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY
MEASURES REMAIN IN AC ONE,
SO LET US REMEMBER NO OTHER
STATE
OR LOCAL INITIATIVES REQUIRE
THE LEVEL OF ACCOUNTABILITY
AND TRANSPARENCY IN AC ONE.
FINALLY, AC TEN MEMORIALIZES
COMPONENTS
OF THE COMPROMISE THAT REMOVED
THE OPPOSITION FROM THE
CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS
SENATORS.
A VOTE FOR AC TEN IS A VOTE TO
REMOVE SPECIAL
TAXES FROM THE NOVEMBER BALLOT,
SO NOT SUPPORTING THIS MEASURE
TODAY
WILL MAKE CLEAR TO YOUR
CONSTITUENTS
THAT YOU WANT SPECIAL TAXES
ON THE BALLOT IN THE FALL.
I'M ASKING YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
COMPROMISE MEASURE.
IT'S SIMPLE AND IT'S
STRAIGHTFORWARD.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
TODAY IS DOUG SUBERS,
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS
FOR
THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS.
J.T.
HAGERMAN, EXCUSE ME, SENIOR
POLICY MANAGER FOR
NONPROFIT HOUSING OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
>> THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS DOUG SUBERS,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS,
PLEASED TO BE HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ACA TEN.
AS NOTED BY THE AUTHOR, ACA TEN
WOULD REMOVE
THE SPECIAL TAX PROVISIONS AND
ADD ADDITIONAL UM,
MECHANISMS TO AMEND ACA ONE TO,
UH, AFFIRM THE AGREEMENTS THAT
WERE
MADE WITH VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS,
UM, THAT WERE PART OF
DISCUSSIONS
OVER THE LAST YEAR.
AND WE DO APPRECIATE THE
LEADERSHIP OF
THE MAJORITY LEADER AND THE
COMMITTEE
AND ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS THAT
ENGAGED
IN THIS PROCESS THROUGHOUT,
UM, UH, THROUGHOUT THE LAST
SEVERAL MONTHS.
UM, AS WE DISCUSSED LAST YEAR,
UH,
FIRE AGENCIES ACROSS THE STATE
HAVE PUT
FORTH LOCAL BOND MEASURES OR
LOCAL TAX,
UH, SPECIAL TAX MEASURES THAT
HAVE SECURED MORE THAN 55% OF
THE VOTE BUT FAILED TO REACH
THE TWO THIRDS THRESHOLD.
WE THINK IT IS ENTIRELY
APPROPRIATE
FOR THE VOTERS TO CONSIDER, UM,
THE BONDED INDEBTEDNESS
THRESHOLD
OF 55% AS PUT FORTH
IN ACA ONE AS PROPOSED TO BE
AMENDED BY ACA TEN.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS, WE'D
RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A VERY QUICK
BREAK TO ESTABLISH QUORUM.
CAN WE DO THAT?
>> SENATORS.
DURAZZO.
PRESIDENT SUHARTO.
DOLLY O.
SUHARTO.
PRESIDENT.
DOLLY.
GLASER.
SKINNER.
WAHAB.
WIENER.
PRESIDENT.
YOU HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU CAN PROCEED THE NEXT.
NEXT SPEAKER.
>> THANK YOU.
UH, UH, GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS JT MACK WITH THE
NON-PROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA, OR MPH.
UH, MPH IS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF ACA TEN.
WE BELIEVE THAT IT IS AN
ESSENTIAL COMPONENT TO HELP
CALIFORNIA MEET ITS HOUSING
PRODUCTION GOALS.
THIS MEASURE HAS THE POTENTIAL
TO UNLOCK
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN LOCAL
REVENUE FOR HOUSING AND MUCH
NEEDED
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS.
STATE FACES HISTORIC.
HOMELESSNESS AND AFFORDABILITY
CRISES,
AND VOTERS ARE INCREASINGLY
FRUSTRATED WITH THE LACK OF
PROGRESS ON THESE ISSUES.
DESPITE STATE GOVERNMENTS BEST
EFFORTS
AT ADDRESSING OUR HOUSING
CRISIS,
CALIFORNIANS CONTINUE TO NAME
ECONOMIC CONDITIONS,
HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING AS
THE MOST IMPORTANT PROBLEMS
FACING THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
BY A WIDE MARGIN.
PASSING THIS BILL TODAY IS THE
FIRST STEP
TOWARDS ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES.
WE URGE YOUR I VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
UM, ANYONE WHO WISHES TO DO A
ME TWO IN SUPPORT,
PLEASE COME UP TO THE MIC IN
YOUR ORGANIZATION.
>> ANDREW DAWSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
>> GALEN DOBBINS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION
FOR RURAL HOUSING STRONG
SUPPORT.
>> CHRIS MYERS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
>> KEITH DUNN HERE FOR THE STATE
BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS, AND
MARTIN,
ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION AND ITS HEALTHY
HOUSING
FOUNDATION AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU, MARY ELLEN SHEA,
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
HOUSING FINANCE AGENCIES.
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
>> CATHERINE CHARLES ON BEHALF
OF HOUSING CALIFORNIA
AND THE HOUSING ACTION COALITION
IN SUPPORT CARLIN
SHELBY ON BEHALF OF ALL HOMES
IN THE CITIES OF OAKLAND,
BERKELEY AND EMERYVILLE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
>> AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
>> ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM
AND ENTERPRISE COMMUNITY
PARTNERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
>> HOLLY.
FOR MANY YEARS, THE LIGHT HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS,
ON BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA,
THE SAN DIEGO HOUSING
COMMISSION,
SPUR, UNITED WAY, GREATER LOS
ANGELES,
EDEN HOUSING AND CALIFORNIA
YIMBY ALL IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR,
AND MEMBERS OF BED.
FRANCO, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA
FIRE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION
AND THE FIRE DISTRICT
ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
UM, SEEING.
OKAY.
NO MORE IN SUPPORT.
YES.
NO.
UM.
IN OPPOSITION.
DO WE HAVE ANY ONE WHO WANTS
TO STEP
UP AND SPEAK IN OPPOSITION?
YOU'RE WELCOME TO SIT DOWN
OR STAY AT THE MICROPHONE.
VERY QUICK.
OKAY.
>> SCOTT KAUFMAN, HOWARD JARVIS,
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION WHILE WE
APPRECIATE
THE REMOVAL OF THE SPECIAL TAX
PROVISION,
AND WE STILL REMAIN OPPOSED,
BONDS ARE LARGELY PAID,
ARE ALMOST ALWAYS PAID BACK VIA
PROPERTY
RELATED FEES AND ASSESSMENTS.
SO IT'S NOT ENOUGH THAT A
MAJORITY
OR EVEN 55% APPROVE IT.
WE NEED A A BROAD CONSENSUS
THAT INCLUDES A MAJORITY OF
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE ACTUALLY
GOING
TO PAY IT, PROPERTY OWNERS.
AND WE BELIEVE THE TWO THIRDS
BEST DOES THAT.
SO WE ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
NEXT.
IN OPPOSITION.
>> AND JAMIE MINOR, THE
CALIFORNIA
STORMWATER QUALITY ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE A BIT OF A TWEENER OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION.
UM, YOU KNOW, HAVE NO ISSUE WITH
THE CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT,
JUST HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
DEFINITION
OF PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE AND
SPECIFICALLY
THE EXCLUSION OF STORMWATER
INFRASTRUCTURE.
JUST GIVEN A LOT OF THE
COMPLEXITIES
AROUND PROP 218.
THAT IS IMPORTANT TO OUR
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
>> MADAM CHAIR, AND MEMBERS
TOBIAS WILKEN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION?
OKAY.
SEEING NONE, WE'LL COME TO THE
DAIS.
MEMBERS.
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
SORT OF.
YES.
UM, YOU MADE A COMMENT THAT
IF WE DON'T VOTE FOR THIS,
WE'RE SOMEHOW SUPPORTING ACA
ONE INCLUDING.
SOMETHING YOU TOOK OUT, YOU
AMENDED TO DO THIS.
BECAUSE I DON'T SUPPORT THAT
EITHER.
UM.
NOT RIGHT.
I'M NOT A BIG FAN OF BEING TOLD
THAT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING,
OR THAT BEING CHARACTERIZED AS
THAT BEING WHAT WE'RE DOING.
UM, WE JUST HAD A.
SUPREME COURT THROW OUT THE
ABILITY
FOR PEOPLE TO WEIGH IN ON
THEIR ON THEIR TAX MEASURE THAT
THEY THEY PUT ON THE BALLOT.
AND GIVEN THAT I'M NOT, UM,
REALLY IN FAVOR OF
DOING ANYTHING TO WHAT THEY'VE
ALREADY DONE,
UH, WHICH IS PUT THIS INTO THESE
MEASURES
INTO PLACE A LONG TIME AGO.
AND, AND SINCE WE'RE NOT GOING
TO LET THEM VOTE TO KEEP OR,
OR MAKE IT MORE RESTRICTIVE,
I'M NOT GOING TO SUPPORT MAKING
IT LESS RESTRICTIVE, EITHER.
UH, SO THAT'S WHY I WON'T BE.
IT'S NOT BECAUSE I, YOU KNOW,
THE PROVISION THAT YOU TOOK OUT,
I DON'T THAT THAT MEANS.
ZERO TO ME AND WHAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING.
SO ANYWAY, I'M SORRY I CAN'T
SUPPORT THIS.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, IT IS.
IT IS THE ABILITY TO RAISE TAXES
AND MAKE
IT MAKE IT EASIER INSTEAD OF
HARDER.
AND AND I REALIZE IT'S BEEN VERY
DIFFICULT,
BUT MANY CITIES HAVE PASSED
THEIR
BONDS FOR SCHOOLS AND THINGS
LIKE THAT
THAT PEOPLE THINK THAT ARE
IMPORTANT.
UM, AND IN ORDER TO GET THAT.
BUT BUT THE OTHER PART OF THAT
IS HOW DO WE
GO ABOUT GETTING SOME OF THESE
THINGS DONE,
AND WHY DO WE KEEP MAKING IT
MORE AND MORE EXPENSIVE
FOR PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE
PUT IN PLACE?
UM, JUST, YOU KNOW, JUST BECAUSE
WE CAN GO BORROW
MONEY AND THEN USE THAT MONEY
TO DO IT
AND IT DOESN'T REALLY THE PUBLIC
DOESN'T FEEL IT AS MUCH,
DOESN'T MEAN WE'RE STILL NOT.
WE'RE SPENDING THEIR MONEY AND
WE'RE
WE'RE DRIVING COSTS TO DO THAT
WITH ALL OF THE OTHER REGULATORY
ISSUES AND,
AND THE LABOR ISSUES,
ALL THOSE THINGS THAT GET PUT
INTO THE,
THE BUILDING OF ALL THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WE NOW WANT TO TAKE
BONDS OUT FOR AND MAKE IT EASIER
TO TAKE BONDS OUT FOR.
UM, SO I WON'T BE SUPPORTING
THIS,
UM, AND, UH, UM, YOU KNOW,
AND I WOULD LIKE PEOPLE TO HAVE
A SAY,
UM, IN, IN BOTH WAYS.
UM, IF WE'RE ONLY GOING TO HAVE
A ONE WAY DOOR, UM,
I'M JUST MORE INTENT WITH
LEAVING IT THE WAY IT IS.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE?
NO.
SENATOR WIENER.
>> SO I REALLY JUST WANT TO
THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR I DON'T
EVEN KNOW HOW MANY YEARS SHE'S
BEEN WORKING ON THIS.
HOW MANY?
FIVE.
SIX?
SEVEN.
AND WE CAME IN TOGETHER IN 2016,
AND I THINK IT WAS SHORTLY AFTER
THAT, UM,
THAT SHE THAT YOU'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS
AND I'M SO APPRECIATIVE THAT
YOU'VE JUST
KEPT GOING AND NOT GIVING UP
WITH ALL OF
THE ROLLER COASTER THAT THIS
HAS BEEN.
BUT IT'S BEEN A ROLLER COASTER
BECAUSE
IT'S A BIG DEAL, RIGHT?
THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT POSITIVE
CHANGE,
UH, TO RECOGNIZE THAT IF WE
ACTUALLY
WANT LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO BE ABLE
TO SERVE THE NEEDS OF PEOPLE,
FIRE PROTECTION, POLICE, UM,
YOU KNOW,
HEALTH SERVICES, UM,
HAVING COUNTY HOSPITALS, THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO
FALL DOWN IN AN EARTHQUAKE, UH,
HAVING, UH,
REC CENTERS AND POOLS AND ALL OF
THE THINGS THAT THAT EVERYONE
WANTS LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO DO
THAT WE NEED TO STOP.
PREVENTING THEM FROM FROM DOING
IT.
AND WE KNOW THAT THE TWO THIRDS
ON THESE BONDS,
HOW MANY BONDS AND ESPECIALLY
BECAUSE THE LEGISLATURE
COMPLETELY
SCREWED UP WHEN WE ALLOWED
OUR FORMER COLLEAGUE TO PASS A
BILL TO PUT ALL SORTS
OF EXTRANEOUS LANGUAGE IN THE 75
WORD BALLOT LABEL,
WHICH HOPEFULLY WILL FIX ONE
DAY.
BUT WE'VE MADE IT PROGRESSIVELY
HARDER AND HARDER FOR CITIES
TO ACTUALLY FUNCTION AND TO
ENGAGE
IN MUNICIPAL FINANCE, UH,
SPECIAL DISTRICTS TO, UH,
AND THIS WILL HELP FIX THAT SO
PEOPLE CAN
HAVE THE LOCAL SERVICES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE.
SO THANK YOU FOR DOING IT.
UM, I'LL BE HONEST, AS I'VE
EXPRESSED TO YOU,
I DON'T LIKE THE COMPROMISE WITH
THE REALTORS.
I'LL SAY THAT IF THE REALTORS
ARE HERE,
I THINK THE REALTORS PROPOSAL.
I DON'T AGREE WITH IT.
I'VE SAID THIS BEFORE AS HOUSING
CHAIR BECAUSE THEY TRIED
TO GET THIS INTO OTHER BILLS,
AND SO I DON'T LIKE THAT.
HOWEVER, I'M A REALIST AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT
YOU'RE DOING WHAT YOU NEED TO
DO TO ACHIEVE
THE MOST GOOD FOR THE MOST
NUMBER OF PEOPLE,
AND SO I'M VERY APPRECIATIVE
OF THAT.
AND I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL.
OKAY.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR WIENER.
SENATOR DONNELLY, I.
>> JUST LIKE TO JUST TO MAKE A
COMMENT.
THAT'S AN OBSERVATION MAYBE
THAT, UM,
WE'VE SEEN A REALLY BIG TREND
IN THE FACT
THAT WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE ACTUALLY
OWNING PROPERTY AND HOMES,
AND WHICH IS WHERE THE TAX BASE
COMES
FROM IS FROM THE ASSESSMENT.
AND WE'VE SEEN, UM,
HEDGE FUNDS AND ALL KINDS OF
OTHER, UH,
INVESTORS THAT OWN THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF HOMES.
AND THAT'S BEEN AN ISSUE IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO WHEN YOU PUT SOMETHING ON THE
BALLOT AND,
AND MOST PEOPLE ARE, IT'S NOT
AFFECTING THEM.
IF YOU'RE A RENTER, THIS DOESN'T
AFFECT YOU.
IT WILL INDIRECTLY AFFECT YOU
BY THE COST OF RENT GOING UP.
SO THERE'S LESS PEOPLE THAT ARE
OWNERS
MEANS THAT YOU HAVE LESS IMPACT.
IT'S THE IMPACTS ON A SMALLER
GROUP.
SO I JUST WANT TO LET YOU KNOW
THAT THAT THIS WILL
AFFECT THAT THIS WILL AFFECT
THE THE MOST.
PEOPLE WILL VOTE FOR IT BECAUSE
IF YOU DON'T HAVE A PROPERTY,
YOU DON'T GET AN ASSESSMENT.
YOU GET IT INDIRECTLY, BUT YOU
DON'T KNOW IT.
SO THEY GO, OH YEAH, IT'S GREAT.
I'M GOING TO RAISE MY LOCAL TAX
BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T AFFECT ME BECAUSE I'M
RENTING.
BUT THE LANDOWNER GETS THE
ASSESSMENT.
AND SO THE LESS LANDOWNERS YOU
HAVE.
THE MORE PEOPLE CAN VOTE TO PUT
TAXES ON THEM.
BUT IT'S INDIRECT COST FOR
HOUSING TO GO UP.
SO I JUST WANT TO JUST MAKE
THAT POINT FOR THE RECORD.
GREAT.
UM, WE HAVE A MOTION, UM, ON
THE BILL.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO SAY ANY
CLOSING REMARKS?
OH, I.
HAVE SO MANY REMARKS.
BUT LET'S BE HONEST.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE THAT.
OKAY.
CAN WE MOVE WITH, UH, CALLING
THE ROLL CALL?
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATORS DURAZZO I, DURAZZO I.
CIERTO.
NO.
DOLLY.
DOLLY, NO.
GLASER.
GLASER I, SKINNER.
WAHAB WAHHAB I WIENER.
WIENER I 42.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN.
UM, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'LL MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
TWO, AB 2813.
WELL, THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN,
MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS,
AB 2813 IS A COMPANION MEASURE
TO ACA
ONE AND WILL ONLY BECOME
OPERATIVE IF ACA ONE
IS APPROVED BY THE VOTERS IN
NOVEMBER.
THIS BILL DOES NOTHING TO CHANGE
THE VOTE THRESHOLD FOR BONDS.
AB 2813 IT SIMPLY FURTHERS
THE STATUTORY ACCOUNTABILITY
AND TRANSPARENCY MEASURES IN
ACA ONE AND IT MEMORANDUM.
IT MEMORIALIZES THE COMPONENTS
OF A COMPROMISE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS TO REMOVE THEIR
OPPOSITION
TO AB 2813 AND ACA TEN,
AND THEY THEREFORE WILL NOT BE
OPPOSING ACA ONE IN NOVEMBER.
WHETHER OR NOT YOU VOTED FOR
ACA ONE.
THIS BUILDS UPON OUR EFFORTS TO
INCREASE OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY IN THE
INITIATIVE.
IF VOTERS APPROVE ACA ONE.
CERTAINLY ALL OF US WANT IT TO
BE AS ACCOUNTABLE
AND TRANSPARENT AS POSSIBLE.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
IS DOUG SUBERS,
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
FOR
THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS,
AND JT HARNICK, UH, SENIOR
POLICY MANAGER FOR
THE NONPROFIT HOUSING OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
DOUG SUBERS, AND ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE,
I WON'T REPEAT WHAT I SAID
PREVIOUSLY
OR WHAT THE MAJORITY LEADER
SAID.
I WILL JUST NOTE THAT THIS
MEASURE
DOES INCLUDE MORE DEFINITION ON
THE CITIZENS OVERSIGHT
COMMISSIONS THAT
ARE REQUIRED AS A RESULT OF UM.
ACA ONE IS PROPOSED TO BE
AMENDED
BY ACA TEN USEFUL LIFE
PROVISIONS
ON THE EXPENDITURE ON ALL
FACILITIES OR PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE AND EQUIPMENT
THAT WOULD BE PURCHASED FOR
THE USE FOR FIRE SUPPRESSION OR
EMERGENCY RESPONSE.
UH, SPECIFIC PROVISIONS
REGARDING
AUDITING REQUIREMENTS
THAT ARE REQUIRED AT THE STATE
LEVEL.
UM, IT WILL, UH, MEMORIALIZE
INDEBTEDNESS CAPS OF
THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AS THEY
HAVE THEM TODAY.
UM, AND IT PROVIDES AN IMPORTANT
MECHANISM
TO ALLOW FIRE DISTRICTS TO,
UM, PURSUE A MEASURE SHOULD
ACA ONE PASS AT THE BALLOT.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS, WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YES.
ONE MORE SPEAKER.
JT.
JT MACK WITH THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA,
AND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE,
OUR NONPROFIT MEMBERS WHO
DEVELOP AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ARE STRONG STEWARDS OF
PUBLIC MONEY
AND WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE THIS PROCESS
TRANSPARENT AND ACCOUNTABLE TO
THE PUBLIC.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GREAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
UH, ANYONE ELSE, UH, IN SUPPORT
OF AB 2813.
KEITH DUNN ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL,
ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
>> DENITA STROMGREN, A VOLUNTEER
WITH AARP CALIFORNIA.
ON BEHALF OF OUR 3.2
MILLION MEMBERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHRIS MYERS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
GRACIELA CASTILLO, CHRIS,
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSORTIUM AND ENTERPRISE
COMMUNITY
PARTNERS IN SUPPORT.
CATHERINE CHARLES AGAIN ON
BEHALF
OF THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION AND HOUSING CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT.
I'M HOLLY FROM DEJESUS WITH
LIGHTHOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS
ON BEHALF OF THE SAN DIEGO
HOUSING COMMISSION,
SPUR UNITED WAY, GREATER LOS
ANGELES,
EDEN HOUSING CALIFORNIA, YIMBY.
AND I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR THE LAST SET
OF AMENDMENTS THAT CALLED OUT
THE USE OF
THE FUNDS FOR ACQUISITION FOR
FOR SALE UNITS ON
BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
I'M ABED FRANK ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
FIRE DISTRICT.
SORRY, THE FIRE DISTRICT
ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MARY ELLEN SHEA, CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
HOUSING FINANCE AGENCIES AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MEMBERS.
COMMENTS.
QUESTIONS.
OH.
I'M SORRY, I'M SORRY.
BEFORE WE COME TO THE MEMBERS
OPPOSITION,
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
TO AB 2813?
UH, SCOTT COPLAND, HOWARD
JARVIS.
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION?
ANY MORE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS?
MEMBERS.
OKAY.
SENATOR GLAZER MOVES THE BILL.
CLOSING REMARKS.
SIMPLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE.
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
PLEASE DO THE ROLL CALL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATORS DURAZZO I DURAZZO I
CIERTO.
NO.
DOLLY.
GLASER.
GLASER I.
SKINNER.
SKINNER I WAHAB.
WAHAB I.
WIENER.
WIENER I.
FIVE.
TWO.
ONE.
CLOSE THE ROLL.
UM, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO
THE FIRST,
UM, THE FIRST BILL, A 1 OR 10.
YEAH.
WRONG.
SORRY.
THE WRONG ONE.
OKAY.
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO ACE.
UM, ITEM NUMBER ONE, ACA TEN.
UH, FURTHER FURTHER VOTES.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 422 WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYES.
SENATOR SKINNER.
SKINNER I 5 TO 2.
OKAY, CLOSE THE ROLL ON THESE
TWO BILLS.
>> I JUST WANTED THE ROLE TO
BE HELD.
SOMEONE IS WAITING HERE.
YES, RIGHT.
THERE'S NOBODY ELSE HERE.
PRESENTING THEIR BILLS.
OKAY.
UM.
WHICH ITEM?
WHICH ITEM IS THE 1990?
YOU'RE A LUCKY GUY TODAY.
OKAY, UM, ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
WILL
BE PRESENTING ITEM 19 AB 2682.
GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
AB 2682 WOULD AMEND THE SANTA
CLARA VALLEY
OPEN SPACE AUTHORITY'S ENABLING
ACT
TO IMPROVE ITS FUNCTIONS AND
ALIGN THEM
WITH SIMILAR JURISDICTIONS
FIRST.
THE BILL WOULD ALLOW THE
AUTHORITY TO PURCHASE
LANDS AND FEE TITLE FROM WILLING
SELLERS IN EAST OF THE
WESTERNMOST
RIDGELINE OF THE DIABLO RANGE,
IN THE SAME MANNER THAT IT
ALREADY ACQUIRES LANDS
THROUGHOUT THE REST OF ITS
JURISDICTION.
SECOND, THE BILL ALLOWS THE
AUTHORITY
TO AUTHORIZE A GENERAL
MANAGER TO BIND THE DISTRICT TO
CERTAIN CONTRACTS,
LIKE OTHER REGIONAL AND OPEN
SPACE
DISTRICTS ARE ABLE TO DO.
THIRD, THE BILL INCREASES THE
CONTRACTING
THRESHOLD FOR MATERIALS AND
EQUIPMENT,
AS THESE AMOUNTS WERE LAST SET
IN 2012.
THIS DOES NOT CHANGE THE
CONTRACTING
THRESHOLDS FOR CONSTRUCTION.
FOURTH, THE BILL WOULD ENABLE
THE AUTHORITY
TO FINANCE FACILITIES AND ISSUE
BONDS PURSUANT TO THE MELLO-ROOS
COMMUNITY
FACILITIES ACT OF 1982.
LASTLY, AB 2682 AMENDS THE
AUTHORITY'S
UNIFORMITY CLAUSE
TO ALLOW THEM TO CHARGE LOWER
TAX RATES TO SENIORS.
THIS IS THE SAME ABILITY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE
WITH THESE UPDATES TO THEIR
ENABLING ACT.
AB 2682 WILL PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY
AND GREATER
EFFICIENCIES TO THE AUTHORITY
AND HELP FACILITATE THEIR
MISSION TO
CONSERVE THE NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT,
SUPPORT SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE
AND CONNECT PEOPLE TO NATURE.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
IS MARK LANDGRAF,
ASSISTANT GENERAL MANAGER WITH
THE OPEN SPACE AUTHORITY.
>> MADAM CHAIR.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MARK LANDGRAF,
SANTA CLARA VALLEY OPEN SPACE
AUTHORITY.
WE'RE GRATEFUL TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA FOR AUTHORING
THIS LEGISLATION THAT UPDATES
OUR ENABLING ACT,
WHICH WAS ESTABLISHED BY
THE STATE LEGISLATURE IN 1993.
OUR INDEPENDENT SPECIAL DISTRICT
SERVES 1.4 MILLION CONSTITUENTS,
AND THIS SET OF UPDATES WOULD
ALLOW US TO
BETTER SERVE THOSE CONSTITUENTS
THROUGH.
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
INDICATED,
IMPROVED ABILITY TO PROTECT
WILDLIFE,
HABITAT AND CONNECTIVITY IN THE
DIABLO MOUNTAINS
IN SUPPORT OF STATE 30 BY 30
GOALS.
TO UPDATE OUR GENERAL MANAGER
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY
TO MAKE THOSE ALIGN WITH THOSE
OF OTHER
OPEN SPACE DISTRICTS AND THE
OTHER PROVISIONS
THAT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MENTIONED.
UH, WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR,
UH,
ALLOWING US TO MOVE THIS FORWARD
AT THIS TIME.
AND I URGE YOUR I VOTE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT, PLEASE
STEP UP.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
>> CHAIR AND MEMBERS MARCUS
DETWEILER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT.
HOLLY FOR MANY DAYS WAS
THE LIGHTHOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS
ON BEHALF OF VALLEY WATER AND
SUPPORT.
OKAY.
WE'RE ON OPPOSITION NOW.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
UH, AT THIS TIME, IS THERE
ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
AS A LEAD WITNESS?
THAT MEANS YOU GET A COUPLE OF
MINUTES.
GET TO SIT UP HERE.
IT'S REALLY FUN.
OKAY, IF NOT, I WILL ENTERTAIN
PEOPLE WHO WOULD JUST WANT
TO BE METOOS UP AT THE THING
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
THAT'S WHERE YOU ALL SCRAMBLE UP
AND YOU JUST SAY YOUR NAME,
WHERE YOUR ORGANIZATION REP AND
THAT YOU OPPOSE.
AND SINCE THEY'RE NOT DOING
THAT,
WE'RE GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO
THE DAIS FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
SENATOR GLAZER, THANK YOU.
I'M VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS WORK
THAT YOU ARE DOING.
IT'S FANTASTIC.
I JUST HAD ONE SIMPLE QUESTION,
WHICH IS THAT WHILE
THIS LEGISLATION WILL PROVIDE
AUTHORIZATION,
DOES IT STILL REQUIRE A VOTE
OF THE BOARD TO SPECIFICALLY
INCORPORATE THESE NEW CONDITIONS
AND SPENDING?
IS THAT STILL A BOARD DECISION?
SO, UH, YOUR MICROPHONE.
IS MY MIC ON?
THERE YOU GO A LITTLE CLOSER.
OKAY, SO THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION.
OUR BOARD HAS APPROVED THE
DIRECTION THAT WE
ARE CURRENTLY TAKING WITH THIS
LEGISLATION.
SO THAT APPROVAL HAS ALREADY
BEEN
AUTHORIZED BY OUR BOARD.
RIGHT.
BUT DO THEY.
TAKE AN ACTION THEN IF THIS BILL
PASSES,
DO THEY SAY, OKAY,
WE'RE AUTHORIZING A WE'RE
RAISING
THE LEVEL IN WHICH OUR EXECUTIVE
CAN.
IS THERE SOME A THERE ARE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
I KNOW IT ALMOST IMPLIES THAT,
THAT THEY'RE SUPPORTIVE,
BUT I'M JUST WONDERING IF
THERE'S A.
>> IF THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE PUBLIC
TO ENGAGE IN THIS DECISION.
THAT'S REALLY WHAT I'M TRYING
TO GET TO.
RIGHT.
SO THERE'S NO ADDITIONAL BOARD
AUTHORIZATION REQUIRED
TO PROVIDE TO TO PUT THIS INTO
STATUTE.
THAT SAID, THERE HAVE BEEN TWO,
TWO OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE PUBLIC
TO ENGAGE,
AS THE BOARD HAS HEARD THIS ITEM
MULTIPLE
TIMES OVER THE PAST SIX MONTHS.
OKAY, SO THE PUBLIC HAS HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY.
THEY MAY NOT IN THE FUTURE IF
THIS PASSES,
THEY COULD,
BUT THEY COULD OBVIOUSLY BRING
IT BACK AS AN AGENDA ITEM
IF SOMEONE WAS DISTRESSED ABOUT
THE NEW AUTHORIZATION.
THAT'S CORRECT.
AND WITH THAT, AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME,
I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
ANYBODY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS?
NO.
I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
DID YOU MAKE A MOTION?
THERE HAS BEEN A MOTION BY
SENATOR GLAZER.
>> SO YOU MAY.
CALL.
OH.
I'M SORRY, YOU WANT TO CLOSE?
RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOR AN I
VOTE.
YOU CAN GO AHEAD AND TAKE A
ROLL.
THANK YOU.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR.
SENATORS DURAZZO.
STELLATO.
DOLLY.
NO.
GLASER.
GLASER A SKINNER.
SKINNER I, WAHAB.
WIENER.
WIENER I.
3 TO 1.
SATO.
NO.
3 TO 2.
OKAY.
WE'LL KEEP THAT MEASURE OPEN FOR
PEOPLE TO ADD ON.
3 TO 2 RIGHT NOW.
ALL RIGHT.
NEXT UP, IT LOOKS LIKE.
ARE WE.
OH, YOU HAVE ANOTHER BILL?
THAT'S CORRECT.
GO AHEAD AND PRESENT.
THANK YOU.
UH, THANK YOU, MISTER CHAIR.
UH, AND I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS
BILL.
AND I'LL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TODAY.
AB 3122 IS A SIMPLE MEASURE THAT
MODIFIES
THE 15% RULE IN SB 35 TO ALLOW
HOUSING PROJECTS,
THE FLEXIBILITY TO REDUCE THE
SIZE OF A PROJECT,
TO BETTER RESPOND TO MARKET
NEEDS,
OR INCREASE THE UNIT COUNT
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF CHANGES IN
THE STATE DENSITY.
BONUS LAW.
UNDER CURRENT LAW, APPROVED SB
35 PROJECTS
MAY BE MODIFIED PURSUANT TO THE
OBJECTIVE
PLANNING STANDARDS THAT WERE
IN PLACE
AT THE TIME OF ORIGINAL
APPROVAL,
BUT ONLY IF THE SQUARE FOOTAGE
OF CONSTRUCTION
OR UNIT COUNT CHANGES BY LESS
THAN 15%.
POST PANDEMIC HAS REVEALED
CHANGING MARKET TRENDS,
SUCH AS LESS DEMAND FOR OFFICE
SPACE
OR RISING COST OF CONSTRUCTION,
LEADING DEVELOPERS TO REVISE
THE PROJECT
AND MAKE ADJUSTMENTS TO COMPLETE
THE PROJECT.
THESE CURRENT LIMITATIONS ARE
HAMPERING
THE ABILITY TO CHANGE
PROJECTS TO REFLECT THE CURRENT
MARKET REALITIES,
AND ULTIMATELY HAVING THE
PERVERSE
EFFECT OF NEEDING TO
INCLUDE MORE SQUARE FOOTAGE
THAN THE MARKET CAN BEAR.
AB 3122 MODIFIES THE 15% RULE
IN SB 35 TO MAKE THE CAP ONLY
APPLY TO INCREASES IN SQUARE
FOOTAGE IN EXCESS OF 15%,
AND DECREASES IN UNIT COUNT THAT
EXCEED 15%.
AB 3122 WILL CLARIFY THE
PROCESS,
WILL HELP FACILITATE
THE RIGHT SIZING OF HOUSING
PROJECTS,
MOVE FORWARD, AND ENCOURAGE MORE
HOUSING TO
BE DEVELOPED WITHOUT UNNECESSARY
DELAYS.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
THE ASSEMBLY AS WELL AS SENATE
HOUSING.
I'M HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT,
AS HOLLY FROM MANY
DEJESUS ON BEHALF OF OUR BILL
SPONSOR, SPUR.
CAN HAVE FOR MANY DAYS AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE STILL NOT ON.
LET'S SEE IF WE CAN GET THAT.
BRING IT CLOSER.
IS SHE ON?
THERE WE GO.
WELCOME.
CAN YOU HEAR ME?
>> YES.
UM.
HOLLY, FOR MANY A DAY HAS
SOOTHED THE LIGHTHOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS AGAIN ON BEHALF
OF SPUR.
THAT'S THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA PLANNING
AND RESEARCH ASSOCIATION.
SPUR HAS BEEN A PROUD CO-SPONSOR
OF MANY
OF THE MEASURES THAT ARE LISTED
IN YOUR ANALYSIS THAT HAVE
PASSED SINCE
THE ORIGINAL PASSAGE OF SB 35.
ALL OF THESE MEASURES, INCLUDING
AB 3122,
ARE AIMED AT KEEPING THIS POLICY
TO CONTINUE TO BE
WORKABLE AND ENSURE THAT
PROJECTS
THAT ARE ATTEMPTING
TO USE SB 35 CAN REMAIN
FEASIBLE.
AB 3122 WILL CREATE JUST MODEST
FLEXIBILITY
FOR DEVELOPERS TO REDESIGN
AND MODIFY THEIR PROJECTS TO
MEET
THE CURRENT REAL ESTATE DEMANDS,
AS MENTIONED BY THE AUTHOR,
BUT ALSO A REMINDER TO THE
COMMITTEE
THAT THESE PROJECTS STILL MUST
COMPLY
WITH UNDERLINING ZONING.
THAT IS THE ESSENCE AND THE
ORIGINAL OBJECTIVE.
A THE ORIGINAL PURPOSE OF SB 35
IS THAT THE PROJECTS
DO HAVE TO STILL COMPLY WITH
UNDERLYING ZONING.
WE URGE YOUR I VOTE VERY GOOD.
AND THIS IS YOUR ONLY WITNESS.
EXCELLENT.
OKAY.
AT THIS TIME WE'LL TAKE ME TOOS
IN FAVOR OF THIS.
THIS BILL, YOU COME ON UP, STATE
YOUR NAME,
THE ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT,
AND THAT YOU LIKE THIS BILL
A LOT.
I LIKE THIS BILL A LOT.
GRACIELA CASTILLO, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSORTIUM,
REALLY WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO,
UH, POLICY CONSULTANTS AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARO
FOR WORKING WITH US ON GETTING
A SMALL FIX IN.
REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
MICHAEL GUNNING, LIGHTHOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS
HERE ON BEHALF OF CAL YIMBY
CIVIC WELL,
FJELLESTAD AND SANDHILL
PROPERTIES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR CONSOLIDATING
THOSE SUPPORTERS.
ALL RIGHT.
AT THIS TIME, IS THERE ANYBODY
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AS
A LEAD WITNESS?
IF NOT, ARE THERE ANYBODY WHO
WISHES TO?
IS THERE ANYBODY WHO WISHES TO
COME UP,
SEE THE SINGULAR TO COME UP TO
THE MICROPHONE
THERE AND STATE YOUR OBJECTION
TO THE BILL?
IF THERE ISN'T, WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO
THE DAIS FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE THE
BILL BY SENATOR DULLI.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S A GREAT CLOSING.
GO AHEAD AND CALL ROLL.
THANK YOU.
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATORS.
DURAZO CIERTO CIERTO I DOLLY.
DOLLY I.
GLASER.
GLASER, I SKINNER.
SKINNER I WAHAB.
WIENER.
WIENER I 5 TO 0.
OKAY.
WE'RE GOING TO BE OKAY.
YEAH, THAT MEASURE WILL BE ON
CALL,
AND I THINK WE'RE GOING TO BE
STAYING
IN FILE ORDER AT THIS TIME.
SO.
MR..
OH YES.
MR.
VONTAZE, YOU ARE UP WITH ITEM
FOUR.
WHICH IS AB 1807.
>> THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS, FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 1807,
WHICH WILL MAKE UPDATES TO THE
EXISTING RIVERSIDE
COUNTY CITIZENS REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION.
GOVERNOR NEWSOM SIGNED MY BILL,
AB 1307, INTO LAW IN 2022.
THAT BILL CREATED THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION,
WHICH IS EMPOWERED TO REDRAW
DISTRICT DISTRICT BOUNDARIES
FOR THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS.
THE COMMISSION WOULD FIRST BE
CONSTITUTED
AFTER THE NEXT CENSUS IN 2030,
AND WOULD BE RECONSTITUTED AFTER
EVERY
DECENNIAL CENSUS THEREAFTER.
THE INTRODUCTION OF 1307 REALLY
KICKED OFF
THE CURRENT WAVE OF COUNTY
REDISTRICTING
COMMITTEE BILLS THAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY
SEEING IN RECENT YEARS.
THE COMMITTEE APPROVED
INDEPENDENT REDISTRICTING
COMMISSIONS FOR FRESNO, KERN,
ORANGE, AND SACRAMENTO COUNTIES,
AND THE GOVERNOR SIGNED THOSE
BILLS INTO LAW.
HOWEVER, AB 34 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VALENCIA
AND SB 314 BY SENATOR ASHBY
CONTAIN VERY USEFUL
INNOVATIONS THAT NONE OF THE
PREVIOUS COUNTY
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION BILLS
INCLUDED,
AND BOTH OF THOSE BILLS WERE
SIGNED
BY THE GOVERNOR LAST YEAR.
SO THE PURPOSE OF 1807 IS TO
IMPORT
MANY OF THOSE INNOVATIONS
TO THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY CITIZENS
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION.
THIS INCLUDES UPDATING THE
REDISTRICTING CRITERIA
TO REALLY REFLECT THE CHANGES
MADE
BY THE ENACTMENT OF THE FAIR
MAPS ACT OF 2023,
WHICH I WAS A PROUD AUTHOR OF.
AB 1807 WOULD ALSO IMPOSE
STRONGER PROHIBITIONS ON
THE ABILITY OF COMMISSIONERS TO
HAVE COMMUNICATIONS
ABOUT REDISTRICTING ISSUES
OUTSIDE OF
THE PUBLIC MEETING OF THE
COMMISSION.
THE BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE
THE COMMISSION TO TRANSLATE
BOTH ON ITS WEBSITE AND MANY
OF THE WRITTEN MATERIALS
IT DISTRIBUTES INTO LANGUAGES
SPOKEN BY AT LEAST 3% OF
THE TOTAL VOTING AGE RESIDENTS
OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
THE BILL WOULD ALSO IMPOSE MORE
RESTRICTIONS
ON THE ACTIVITIES OF
COMMISSIONERS.
FOR INSTANCE, THREE YEARS AFTER
BEING
APPOINTED TO THE COMMISSION,
COMMISSIONERS WOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO
ACCEPT EMPLOYMENT FROM A
CANDIDATE
FOR OFFICE OR AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL
OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
COMMISSIONERS WOULD ALSO BE
PROHIBITED FROM RECEIVING
NONCOMPETITIVE BID CONTRACTS
FROM RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
FINALLY, WHILE SERVING ON THE
COMMISSION,
COMMISSIONERS WILL BE BARRED
FROM ENDORSING, WORKING FOR,
OR MAKING FINANCIAL
CONTRIBUTIONS
TO THE CAMPAIGN OF
A CANDIDATE FOR ELECTED OFFICE
FOR RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
THESE UPDATES WILL MAKE THE
REDISTRICTING PROCESS
FOR THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY FAIR MORE ACCESSIBLE AND
MORE TRANSPARENT,
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
I VOTE.
OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DID YOU BRING ANYBODY AS ANY
WITNESS TODAY?
OH, OKAY.
YOU DID NOT.
EXCELLENT.
DO WE HAVE ANYBODY WHO WOULD
LIKE TO COME
AND BE A METOO IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL?
IF YOU WANT TO COME UP TO
THE MICROPHONE AND DO SO NOW.
IS THERE ANYBODY WHO WANTS TO
SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION AS A LEAD WITNESS?
IF NOT, ANYBODY WANTS TO COME UP
TO THE MICROPHONE?
IF NOT, WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO
THE DAIS.
ANYBODY HAVE QUESTIONS?
WE HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE THE
BILL.
I BELIEVE I HEARD SENATOR WIENER
FIRST.
DID YOU MOVE THE BILL, MR.
WIENER?
OKAY, WELL, I'M JUST TRYING TO
EVENLY DISTRIBUTE.
UH, WITH THAT, WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MR.
WIENER.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE,
SENATORS.
ALL RIGHT.
AND THIS IS A DUE PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
GO AHEAD AND CALL ROLL.
SENATOR DURAZZO.
CIERTO.
CIERTO?
NO.
DOLLY.
DOLLY, NO.
GLASER.
GLASER I.
SKINNER.
SKINNER I, WAHAB.
WIENER.
I'M 3 TO 2.
BILL WILL REMAIN ON CALL AND FOR
OTHERS TO ADD ON.
BRINGS US TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE,
AB 1801 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JACKSON.
WELCOME, MR.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
CHAIR.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
UM, AB 1801.
UM, WELL, FIRST I WILL WANT TO
SAY THAT I'LL
BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE CHAIR
AND STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US,
UH, AS WE CONTINUE TO STRENGTHEN
THIS BILL.
AB 1801 IS A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE
THAT PROVIDES CLARITY TO
EXISTING
LAW BY ALLOWING NONPROFITS THE
ABILITY TO USE THEIR
PROPERTY TO BUILD NEEDED OFFICE
SPACE AND PARKING IN
THE SAME LOCATION AS THEIR
SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING COMPLEXES.
UM AB 1801 WILL HELP OUR
NONPROFITS TO CONTINUE
IN THEIR WORK WHILE
CONSOLIDATING SO THAT
IF THEY HAVE IF THEY OWN
PROPERTY BUT THEY
ARE UNABLE TO HAVE THEIR
HEADQUARTERS,
THEN THEY HAVE TO USE EXISTING
RESOURCES
TO RENT OR LEASE OR OTHER
THINGS.
AND WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
SURE THAT PARTICULARLY, UM,
NONPROFITS OF ALL SIZES CAN BE
ABLE TO
USE THEIR DOLLARS MORE
EFFECTIVELY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I
VOTE.
GREAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION.
DO YOU HAVE ANYBODY WHO IS GOING
TO
BE TESTIFYING AS A LEAD WITNESS?
IS THERE ANYBODY OUT THERE WHO
WANTS
TO TESTIFY AS LEAD WITNESS?
I'LL GIVE YOU TWO MINUTES.
NO.
YOU WANT TO COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE AT THIS
TIME AND DO ME TWOS IN FAVOR
OF THE BILL?
JUST NAME ORGANIZATION YOU
REPRESENT
AND THAT YOU REALLY LIKE THE
BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
CATHERINE CHARLES, ON BEHALF
OF HOUSE
AND CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT.
AT THIS TIME, ANYBODY WHO WISHES
TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL IS A
LEAD WITNESS.
IF NOT ANYBODY WANTS TO COME
UP TO
THE MICROPHONE AND JUST SAY,
I OPPOSE.
THERE BEING NONE.
BACK TO THE DAIS.
ANY QUESTIONS OR MOTION?
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
GLAZER.
AND THIS IS.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO.
THEY'RE GOING TO FIND OUT IN
A MINUTE.
GO AHEAD AND CALL ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATORS.
DURAZZO.
SATO.
SATO I.
DOLLY.
DOLLY I.
GLASER.
GLASER, I.
SKINNER.
SKINNER I.
WAHAB.
WIENER.
WE.
WEINER.
I'M FIVE ZERO.
ALL RIGHT.
THAT HAS FIVE VOTES, AND WE'RE
GOING TO LEAVE
IT OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON
LATER ON.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON.
WELCOME.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER SIX AB 1819.
>> THANK YOU.
MOVING RIGHT ALONG, MR.
CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE CHAIR
FOR WORKING WITH ME ON THIS
BILL.
AND FIRSTLY, I AM ACCEPTING
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
AB 1819 ALLOWS FOR THE CREATION
OF SPECIAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICTS
IN AREAS CATEGORIZED AS HIGH
OR VERY
HIGH FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY ZONES.
AND HOW THIS ALL CAME ABOUT.
UM, HISTORICALLY, WE HAD TRIED
NUMEROUS
TIMES TO GET A BUDGET
ALLOCATIONS
TO HELP FUND HEAVY EQUIPMENT
AND FIREFIGHTING EQUIPMENT,
UM, IN BACK COUNTRY HIGH FIRE
RISK AREAS.
AND WE FOUND A STUDY SEVERAL
YEARS AGO
THAT SHOWS THAT IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY.
AND IT RELATES STATEWIDE AS
WELL.
ALMOST 25% OF WILDFIRES IN THE
BACK COUNTRY ARE
CAUSED BY VEHICLES PULLING OFF
THE ROADWAY.
SO THE CONCERN IS TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE
GETTING THOSE BACK COUNTRY
ROADS,
UH, CLEARED OF VEGETATION ALONG
THE SIDE.
AND THAT COULD CUT DOWN A
SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNT OF THE FIRES THAT WE ARE
EXPERIENCING BY DIRECTING
RESOURCES
TOWARDS THESE HIGH RISK AREAS.
AB 1819 ENSURES THAT THE MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
ARE BETTER PROTECTED AGAINST
FUTURE WILDFIRES.
THESE DISTRICTS WILL GENERATE
FUNDS SPECIFICALLY
FOR WILDFIRE MITIGATION EFFORTS,
SUCH AS HEAVY EQUIPMENT TO CLEAR
VEGETATION,
CREATING FIRE BREAKS AND
HARDENING INFRASTRUCTURE.
AS WE'VE SEEN IN RECENT YEARS,
THE FREQUENCY AND INTENSITY
OF WILDFIRES IN CALIFORNIA
HAS POSED SIGNIFICANT RISKS TO
LIVES,
PROPERTIES AND OUR ENVIRONMENT.
LAST YEAR, OVER 7000 FIRES
BURNED
CLOSE TO 325,000 ACRES.
THIS IS A CLEAR SIGNAL THAT OUR
CURRENT
EFFORTS MUST GO FURTHER.
IN A TIME WHERE OUR BUDGET IS
IN A DEFICIT,
CREATING A PROGRAM THAT DOES NOT
RAISE TAXES
OR IMPACT THE STATE BUDGET MAKES
SENSE.
PLEASE WELCOME FIRE CHIEF JOE
NAPIER FROM
VALLEY CENTER FIRE PROTECTION
DISTRICT
TO DISCUSS THE CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE OF
AB 1819 FOR WILDFIRE MITIGATION.
AND WE ALSO HAVE MARCUS DETWILER
WITH
THE SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION.
WELCOME TO THE WITNESSES.
AND IF YOU CAN KEEP IT FAIRLY
BRIEF,
THAT WOULD BE AWESOME.
WE HAVE A LONG AGENDA TODAY.
THANK YOU.
I'LL DO MY BEST, SIR.
UH, ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON.
AND TO THE CHAIR AND TO THE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE
AGAIN, JOE NAPIER.
I'M THE FIRE CHIEF OF THE VALLEY
CENTER FIRE PROTECTION DISTRICT,
WHICH IS AN 85 SQUARE MILE
SPECIAL
DISTRICT AT THE BASE
OF PALOMAR MOUNTAIN IN NORTH SAN
DIEGO COUNTY.
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT AB 1819,
WHICH IS WRITTEN AND DESIGNED
TO PROVIDE THE MUCH NEEDED AND
ENHANCED INSTRUMENT
TO FUND MITIGATION EFFORTS
AGAINST
THE DEVASTATING WILDFIRES
THAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
DURING MY 38 YEAR CAREER,
OVER 38 YEARS IN THE FIRE
SERVICE,
I'VE SEEN FIRSTHAND THE CHANGES
IN CLIMATE AND SPECIFICALLY
THE CHANGES IN FIRE BEHAVIOR
THAT
HAS RESULTED IN THE LOSS OF
LIFE,
HOMES AND BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT
OUR BEAUTIFUL STATE.
IT'S MY HOPE THAT THIS BILL GOES
THROUGH
THIS IMPORTANT PROCESS WITH
YOUR.
I VOTE TO GIVE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS,
COUNTIES AND CITIES WHO ARE IN
THE HIGH
OR VERY HIGH SEVERITY RISK
ZONES,
THE ABILITY TO FUND FIRE
HARDENED
FACILITIES TO IMPROVE
FIRE RESPONSE TIMES, TO KEEP
SMALL FIRES SMALL.
TO PURCHASE VITALLY NEEDED
EQUIPMENT TO PROACTIVELY
PERFORM VEGETATION MANAGEMENT.
IN AN EXAMPLE OF THAT IS
RECENTLY WE TOOK DOWN
A 20 ACRE DEAD VALENCIA GROVE
IN VALLEY CENTER,
AND THEY HAD TO IMPORT THE
EQUIPMENT FROM
TEXAS AND THEN RETURN IT BACK
TO TEXAS.
SO WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
EQUIPMENT TO DO THESE.
FIREBREAK AND VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT.
THE DIRECT RESULT OF CLEARING
VEGETATION
USING A COMBINATION
OF PRESCRIBED BURNING AND BRUSH
CLEARING.
USING THIS VITAL EQUIPMENT WILL
PROVIDE A MUCH
NEEDED FIREBREAKS TO MITIGATE
AND PREVENT
THE RAPID SPREAD OF WILDFIRE
FROM OUR WILDFIRE
BACK COUNTRY TO URBAN AREAS TO
SUBURBAN AREAS,
WITH THE REAL POTENTIAL OF FIRE
SPREAD ALL THE WAY INTO
METROPOLITAN AREAS AND THE GREAT
PACIFIC FIREBREAK.
I ALSO.
I ALSO HOPE THAT THE RESULTS OF
THESE EFFORTS
WILL RESULT IN STABILIZING THE
INCREASE
IN FIRE INSURANCE THAT OUR
RATEPAYERS ARE SEEING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA,
GIVING HOMEOWNERS AND BUSINESSES
FINANCIAL RELIEF
AND THE PEACE OF MIND KNOWING
THAT THEY
ARE LIVING IN WORKING IN A FIRE
SAFE
COMMUNITY THROUGH PLANNING,
FUNDING AND MITIGATION.
THANK YOU.
YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WE HAVE A SECOND LEAD
WITNESS.
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS, MARCUS DETWEILER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION.
UH, I'D LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT BILL
FORWARD AND HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT,
UH, PUBLIC AGENCIES,
INCLUDING MUNICIPAL AND DISTRICT
FIRE AGENCIES AND LOCALLY
OWNED PUBLIC UTILITIES ARE
IMPORTANT STAKEHOLDERS
AND PARTNERS IN THE STATE'S
FIGHT
AGAINST THE DEVASTATING
IMPACTS OF INCREASINGLY
HAZARDOUS WILDFIRES.
AS SUCH, IT IS ENTIRELY
APPROPRIATE
THAT WE ENSURE THAT THESE
AGENCIES
HAVE EVERY FINANCIAL TOOL
AVAILABLE
AT THEIR DISPOSAL,
INCLUDING ENHANCED
INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICTS.
THESE DISTRICTS, OR APHIDS,
ARE A FORM OF TAX INCREMENT
FINANCING THAT ALLOW THE
DISTRICT TO ISSUE
BONDS FOR WHICH THE PROCEEDS
ARE USED TO FUND SPECIFIED,
UH PUBLIC FACILITIES AND PUBLIC
PROJECTS.
UH.
CRUCIALLY, APHIDS ARE STRUCTURED
BASED ON THE VOLUNTARY
PARTICIPATION OF THE AFFECTED
TAXING JURISDICTIONS.
WHEREAS PREVIOUS ITERATIONS OF
TAX INCREMENT FINANCING, UH,
OBLIGATED TAXING JURISDICTIONS
TO FORFEIT PORTIONS
OF THEIR SHARES OF PROPERTY TAX
REVENUE.
UH, BY STRUCTURING IT IN THIS
WAY.
UH, THIS BILL AVOIDS DIVERTING
ANY LOCAL REVENUE
AND EMPOWERS AGENCIES TO UTILIZE
THIS FINANCING TOOL
AND PROVIDES THEM WITH THAT
ABILITY TO
FINANCE THOSE SPECIFIED
PURCHASES,
THOSE FACILITIES, THOSE
PROJECTS.
UM, THIS BILL SPECIFICALLY WOULD
PROVIDE THAT FOR DISTRICTS
LOCATED IN AT LEAST PARTIALLY IN
HIGH OR VERY HIGH,
UH, FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY ZONES,
THE ABILITY TO FINANCE
THE UNDERGROUNDING OF PUBLIC
UTILITIES,
THE HEAVY EQUIPMENT USED FOR
VEGETATION,
VEGETATION AND FIRE BREAKS,
AS WELL AS EQUIPMENT USED FOR
THE SUPPRESSION
AND FIGHTING OF FIRE, SUBJECT
TO LIMITATIONS.
FOR THESE REASONS, WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY
URGE YOUR YES VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE.
AND ONCE AGAIN, THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY.
AT THIS TIME, WE'LL GO TO THE
AUDIENCE
FOR ANY METOOS ANYBODY
THAT IS IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AND WOULD LIKE TO STATE.
SO PLEASE COME TO THE MIC.
I DON'T SEE ANYBODY SCRAMBLING
UP HERE.
DOES ANYBODY DARE?
I MEAN, DOES ANYBODY WANT TO
SPEAK AGAINST THIS BILL?
NO.
OKAY.
ANYBODY WANT TO COME TO THE MIC?
IT'D JUST BE A ME TWO AGAINST
IT.
NO.
OKAY, WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO
THE DAIS.
WE HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE
THE BILL FROM SENATOR DAWLEY.
UH, YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS, I URGE AND I VOTE
ON GETTING THE ABILITY
FOR SOME FUNDING FOR THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
THANK YOU.
AND I CAN SAY, AS A FIRE SERVICE
PROFESSIONAL,
PREVIOUS NOT QUITE AS MANY YEARS
AS THAT,
BUT THAT THIS IS DESPERATELY
NEEDED,
ESPECIALLY FOR THE SMALLER
DISTRICTS IN THOSE AREAS.
UH, AND HAVE A LOT OF BACK
COUNTRY
AND THEREFORE A LOT OF NEED FOR,
UH, FOR THE EQUIPMENT AND
SOMEHOW
BE ABLE TO ATTAIN IT.
SO THIS IS A DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE FLOOR.
AND SO YOU MAY CALL ROLL.
SENATORS DURAZZO CIERTO CIERTO
I DOLLY DOLLY I GLASER.
GLASER I SKINNER.
SKINNER I WAHAB.
WIENER.
WIENER I FIRE ZERO.
OKAY.
THAT MEASURE HAS GOT FIVE VOTES,
AND WE'RE GOING TO KEEP IT ON
CALL
FOR OTHERS TO COME IN AND ADD
ON.
THANK YOU.
MISS PEPIN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
PEPIN.
YOU'RE NEXT.
AB 1827.
>> SORRY, JOE.
YET.
WE'RE TRYING TO STAY IN FILE
ORDER.
SO SHE GOES RELATIVELY QUICKLY.
BOOM.
YOU'RE NEXT.
PLEASURE.
>> MY PLEASURE TO BUMP JP.
UH, WELL.
GOOD AFTERNOON, UM, MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB 1827,
WHICH IS ALL ABOUT KEEPING WATER
RATES FAIR.
AB 1827 WILL HELP PRESERVE WATER
PROVIDERS
ABILITY TO FAIRLY ALLOCATE
COSTS,
THEREBY PROTECTING LOW WATER
USERS FROM
THE STRESS OF HIGH WATER BILLS.
IN EVERY COMMUNITY, THERE ARE
WATER CONSUMERS WHO USE
MORE WATER THAN OTHERS AND THOSE
WHO USE LESS.
IT'S JUST A FACT OF LIFE.
WATER CUSTOMERS WHO USE MORE
WATER THAN OTHERS WITHIN
THE SAME CLASS INCREASE A WATER
SUPPLIER'S
OVERALL COST OF PROVIDING
SERVICE DUE TO
THE HIGHER COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
BUILDING,
OPERATING AND MAINTAINING
MAINTAINING A LARGER WATER
SYSTEM THAT CAN MEET THOSE
LARGER WATER DEMANDS.
PROP 218 ALLOWS WATER SUPPLIERS
TO RECOUP
THE LEGITIMATE COSTS
ATTRIBUTABLE
TO THAT HIGHER WATER USE FROM
THOSE
HIGHER WATER USING CUSTOMERS.
RECENT LAWSUITS, HOWEVER,
HAVE SOUGHT TO CALL THIS INTO
QUESTION.
TRIAL COURTS HAVE ATTEMPTED TO
IMPOSE NEW AND INCREASINGLY
GRANULAR REQUIREMENTS BEYOND
THOSE
REQUIRED BY PROP 218 ON
WHAT SUPPLIERS WHO SEEK TO
JUSTIFY
CHARGING HIGHER WATER USERS
FOR THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THEIR HIGHER WATER USE.
AB 1827 WILL BRING CLARITY TO
THIS ISSUE,
AS IT SIMPLY REAFFIRMS
THAT CALIFORNIA'S WATER
SUPPLIERS
CAN CONTINUE TO INCLUDE
THE INCREMENTALLY HIGHER COSTS
OF WATER SERVICE WITHIN
THE WATER RATES CHARGED TO
CUSTOMERS
WHO DRIVE UP THOSE COSTS.
AB 1827 DOES NOT PERMIT A WATER
SUPPLIER TO VIOLATE PROP 218.
IT SIMPLY PRESERVES PROP 218
PROPORTIONALITY
AND COST OF SERVICE PRINCIPLES,
ALLOWING WATER SUPPLIERS TO
CONTINUE
USING THE REASONABLE
AND WELL ACCEPTED METHODS THEY
HAVE USED FOR DECADES.
WITH ME TODAY, I HAVE MISS
CHRISTINE COMPTON WITH
THE IRVINE RANCH WATER DISTRICT
AND CODY PHILLIPS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COASTKEEPER
ALLIANCE TO
SPEAK FURTHER ON THE IMPORTANCE
OF AB 1827.
WELCOME TO OUR TWO PRESENTERS.
UM, IF YOU COULD KEEP IT TO FIVE
MINUTES BETWEEN THE TWO OF YOU,
SPLIT IT UP HOWEVER YOU'D LIKE.
THAT WOULD HELP US MOVE THE THE
MEETING ALONG.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I'M CHRISTINE COMPTON.
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF STRATEGIC
COMMUNICATIONS
AND ADVOCACY IN
THE DEPUTY GENERAL COUNSEL AT
IRVINE RANCH WATER DISTRICT.
WE ARE LIKE, UH, THE
ASSEMBLYWOMAN SAID,
THE CO-SPONSORS OF THIS BILL,
WE'RE A RETAIL WATER AGENCY, UH,
SERVING THE MIDDLE 20% OF ORANGE
COUNTY.
AND WATER SUPPLIERS DESIGN AND
MAINTAIN
A WATER SYSTEM TO ENSURE THEY'RE
MEETING THE MAXIMUM POSSIBLE
DEMAND OF
THEIR CUSTOMERS ON ANY GIVEN
DAY,
ANY GIVEN HOUR, USUALLY THE
HOTTEST DAY,
HOTTEST HOUR OF THE YEAR.
SO WHEN WE DESIGN AND OPERATE
THOSE SYSTEMS,
WE'RE TAKING INTO MAKING SURE
THAT EVERY CUSTOMER
HAS RELIABLE SERVICE WHEN THEY
TURN ON THEIR TAP.
BECAUSE OF THIS, WATER USERS
THAT
USE MORE WATER THAN OTHER
SIMILARLY SITUATED CUSTOMERS OR
HAVE A LARGER METER.
WE HAVE TO BUILD A LARGER SYSTEM
TO ENSURE WE CAN MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE SUPPLYING EVERYBODY
THAT RELIABLE WATER.
AB 1827 IS FUNDAMENTALLY ABOUT
WHO
SHOULD PAY FOR THOSE COSTS,
AND WHAT TOOLS A WATER SUPPLIER
CAN
USE FOR ALLOCATING THOSE COSTS.
CONSISTENT WITH PROP 18 AMONGST
CUSTOMERS.
AND WE WATER AGENCIES USE A
VARIETY
OF METHODS THROUGHOUT, YOU KNOW,
AND DO RATES A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY
FROM AGENCY TO AGENCY.
BUT UNIVERSALLY, WE ALL USE
METER SIZE AND PEAKING
FACTORS IN SOME WAY TO ALLOCATE
THOSE COSTS.
AND SO THIS BILL IS ABOUT
REAFFIRMING
THAT WE DON'T ANTICIPATE THAT
THIS
WILL RAISE WATER RATES OR CHANGE
THEM
IN ANY WAY ACROSS THE STATE,
AND IT WON'T ALLOW FOR TARGETING
OF
ANY CUSTOMER TYPE AGAINST
ANOTHER.
IT'S SIMPLY ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT THE TOOLS THAT HAVE
BEEN USED FOR DECADES WE CAN
CONTINUE TO USE.
I CERTAINLY HOPE THAT YOU'LL
SUPPORT IT
TODAY AND TURN IT OVER TO MY
RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT.
>> UH, YEAH.
CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS CODY PHILLIPS.
I'M A STAFF ATTORNEY WITH
CALIFORNIA
COASTKEEPER ALLIANCE.
WE REPRESENT WATERKEEPER
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE WHO ARE DEDICATED TO
SWIMMABLE,
FISHABLE AND DRINKABLE WATER
FOR ALL.
AND A BIG PORTION OF DRINKABLE
WATER
HAS TO BE AFFORDABLE WATER.
UM, JUST BRINGING IT BACK HERE.
PROP 218 MANDATES THAT WATER
RATES, QUOTE,
SHALL NOT EXCEED THE
PROPORTIONAL COST OF
THE SERVICE ATTRIBUTABLE TO THE
PARCEL.
AND THIS BILL JUST ATTEMPTS TO
CLARIFY WHAT IT MEANS
TO ATTRIBUTE THE COST OF SERVICE
TO A PARCEL,
AND TO BUILD ON WHY THIS IS
IMPORTANT
FOR PUBLIC UTILITIES.
WATER RATE DESIGN CAN TAKE MANY
SHAPES AND IS
AN IMPORTANT CONSERVATION AND
EQUITY TOOL.
UNIFORM RATES, FOR EXAMPLE,
ARE LIKE GAS PRICES YOU JUST PAY
PER GALLON.
UH, TIERED RATES, BY COMPARISON,
INCREASE THE PRICE PER
GALLON WHEN YOU ENTER SPECIFIC
TIERS OF WATER USE.
IN BOTH INSTANCES, YOU PAY MORE
FOR THE WATER YOU USE.
BUT TIERED RATES HAVE THE ADDED
BENEFIT OF SENDING A CLEAR
SIGNAL TO CUSTOMERS THAT ABOVE
A CERTAIN THRESHOLD,
WATER IS GOING TO GET MORE
EXPENSIVE.
RATE STRUCTURES, WHEN DESIGNED
CORRECTLY,
NOT ONLY INCENTIVIZE
CONSERVATION AND EFFICIENCY,
BUT THEY ALSO HELP TO ALLOCATE
THE INCREMENTAL
COSTS OF HIGHER WATER USE ON
THOSE CUSTOMERS
THAT DRIVE THE NEED FOR A SYSTEM
CAPABLE
OF MEETING THAT HIGHER WATER
USE.
IN OTHER WORDS.
THEY ASSIGNED TWO PARCELS THE
PROPORTIONAL COST OF
SERVICE ATTRIBUTABLE TO THAT
PARCEL UNDER PROP 22.
PROPORTIONALITY REQUIREMENTS.
THE PERFECT COMPLIANCE SCENARIO
WOULD BE TO
TRACK EVERY INDIVIDUAL WATER
MOLECULE,
AND EXACTLY WHEN THOSE MOLECULES
ARE USED TO PERFECTLY MAP
OUT THE EXACT COSTS EACH PARCEL
PLACES ON THE SYSTEM,
AND THAT IS AN IMPOSSIBLE
STANDARD.
ACCORDINGLY, CALIFORNIA COURTS
HAVE REPEATEDLY
SAID THAT PROP 18 DOES NOT
REQUIRE PERFECTION,
AND THERE'S AN UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE METHODS
THAT REASONABLY ASSESS THE COST
OF
SERVICE ATTRIBUTABLE TO A PARCEL
COMPLY
WITH THIS PROPORTIONALITY
REQUIREMENT.
BUT AS WE'VE SAID,
WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS THAT COURTS
HAVE
LEANED MORE INTO THE PERFECT
SCENARIO REQUIREMENTS,
WHERE RATE STRUCTURES HAVE TO
BE JUSTIFIED
BASED ON SPECIFIC TIME OF USE,
METERING AND MOLECULE BY
MOLECULE DATA.
ELSE THEY VIOLATE PROP 18.
AND THIS BILL JUST TRIES TO
CLARIFY THAT PROP 218
PROPORTIONALITY REQUIREMENT IS
NOT SO STRINGENT,
AND THAT WATER SUPPLIERS MAY
USE METHODS THAT REASONABLY,
NOT PERFECTLY ASSESS THE COST OF
SERVICE ATTRIBUTED TO A PARCEL.
SO WITH THAT, I URGE YOUR I VOTE
ON THIS BILL.
VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY.
AT THIS TIME, WE'LL TAKE METOOS
IN FAVOR OF THE MEASURE,
YOUR NAME, THE ORGANIZATION
REPRESENT.
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
LINED UP ALREADY.
>> PILAR QUINTANA HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE EAST
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT AND
SUPPORT.
AND I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED TO
CONVEY THE SUPPORT OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES.
THANK YOU.
>> CHAIR AND MEMBERS ASHLEY
WALKER
WITH NOSSAMAN ON BEHALF
OF OLIVENHAIN MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
AND JAMIE MINOR ON BEHALF OF
EASTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
AND SANTA MARGARITA WATER
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THANKS.
>> ETHAN NAGLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SANTA ROSA
AND THE TOWN OF HILLSBOROUGH
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MARCUS
DETWEILER,
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
AND THE CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
>> ERIC LAUER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
>> CHRISTY FOY WITH ARNOLD AND
ASSOCIATES
HERE ON BEHALF OF THREE
VALLEYS MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT, IN STRONG SUPPORT.
>> HI, DEBBIE.
MICHAEL, ON BEHALF OF EAST BAY
MUNICIPAL
UTILITY DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
>> M.J.
KUSHNER WITH COMMUNITY WATER
CENTER IN SUPPORT.
>> BETH LASSO FOR CUCAMONGA
VALLEY
WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
ROBERT FRANK ON BEHALF OF THE
CONTRA
COSTA WATER DISTRICT AND
SUPPORT.
>> THANK YOU.
DAWN KOPECKI, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
BALANCE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AT THIS TIME, WE WILL TAKE
ANYBODY WHO WISHES
TO BE A LEAD WITNESS ON
OPPOSITION TO THIS.
YOU CAN EITHER COME TO THE MIC
OR COME
UP AND SIT DOWN AT THE CHAIR.
I WILL BE VERY QUICK.
THANK YOU.
SCOTT KAUFMAN, HOWARD JARVIS,
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION WE DO
NOT BELIEVE THIS BILL IS
DECLARATORY
OF EXISTING LAW.
AND IN SOME WAYS WE THINK IT
DIRECTLY
CONFLICTS WITH PROPOSITION 218.
AND IT'S ALL RELATED TO A
CURRENT COURT CASE.
AND WE THINK THAT WE SHOULD JUST
SIMPLY LET THE COURTS DECIDE
THIS BECAUSE THEY WILL ANYWAYS
IN THIS BILL IS NOT NECESSARY.
THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE WHO WISHES TO ACT
AS A LEAD WITNESS?
A LOT OF ACTIVITY UP THERE.
ALL RIGHT.
I DON'T SEE ANY LEAD WITNESSES
COMING IN OPPOSITION.
SO ANYBODY WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS
THEIR
OPPOSITION IN JUST A METOO
FASHION.
NO.
OKAY.
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS
FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS, EMOTION.
OKAY.
ANYBODY?
I DO HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS
REALLY QUICK.
UM, WHENEVER YOU'RE DOING TIERED
RATE STRUCTURES,
UH, THERE IS A FORMULA THAT'S
USED TO DETERMINE,
UH, PER HOUSEHOLD BECAUSE SOME
HOUSES HAVE FOUR PEOPLE,
SOME HOUSES HAVE TWO PEOPLE.
AND AND IT ALSO CAN BE UM,
IT GETS MANIPULATED IF THERE ARE
DIFFERENT BILLING CYCLES
ACCORDING
TO THE WATER DISTRICT.
UH, AND THIS CAN ACTUALLY,
AS YOU GET INTO HIGHER TIERED
RATES,
UH, IF THAT IS,
IF YOU HAVE A 45 DAY PERIOD
ONE TIME
AND THEN NEXT MONTH IT'S A 28
DAY PERIOD,
UH, PEOPLE GET CHARGED LIKE
THEY'RE
USING A HIGHER TIERED RATE.
HOW ARE THEY PROPOSING TO
STRUCTURE
THESE RATES SO THAT THEY ARE
CONSISTENT AND THEY'RE TRUE
TO WHAT
THE PEOPLE ARE THAT ARE IN,
YOU KNOW, HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
IN A HOUSE BECAUSE USUALLY
IT WAS LIKE 55 GALLONS PER
PERSON PER DAY.
AND THEN THE FORMULA WENT FROM
THERE.
SO, SENATOR, THERE ARE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF TIERED RATES.
ONE WHICH YOU DESCRIBED AS
A BUDGET BASED RATE STRUCTURE.
AND IN FACT IRWD HAS A BUDGET
BASED RATE STRUCTURE.
UM, WE LIKE MOST FOLKS THAT HAVE
A BUDGET BASED RATE STRUCTURE,
AND THERE'S ONLY A SMALL HANDFUL
OF US
THAT HAVE THAT SORT OF TIERED
RATE.
WE ACTUALLY, FOR, YOU KNOW, IF
IT'S A 30 DAY PERIOD
FOR THE BILL VERSUS A 36, WE
PRORATE IT.
SO THEY'RE GETTING THE SAME
AMOUNT.
WE ALSO, UH, PROVIDE WE MAKE
CERTAIN ASSUMPTIONS
ABOUT THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN
A HOUSEHOLD.
SO FOR EXAMPLE, IN A SINGLE
FAMILY HOME WE ASSUME FOUR.
HOWEVER, I GREW UP IN A FAMILY
WITH EIGHT CHILDREN,
SO THERE WERE TEN OF US IN THE
HOUSEHOLD.
AND SO MY FAMILY WAS ABLE TO GET
A VARIANCE TO ACCOMMODATE.
SO YOU'RE GETTING THAT WATER
BUDGET
FOR THE TOTAL HOUSEHOLD
WITHOUT PENALIZING SOMEBODY THAT
GOES OVER IT.
SAME WITH THE LANDSCAPE AREA.
SO YOU'RE NOT PAYING FOR THAT
HIGHER USE
IN A BUDGET BASED RATE STRUCTURE
UNTIL
YOU GO OVER THE BUDGET TO GIVE
THAT
SORT ALL OF THOSE FACTORS
ACCOUNT.
RIGHT.
AND THANK YOU FOR CLARIFYING
THAT,
BECAUSE THAT'S EXACTLY HOW IT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE DONE.
BUT I HAVE SEEN IT DONE IN
INSTANCES,
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU HAVE WATER
METERING
COMPANIES THAT DO IT THE OTHER
WAY,
AND PEOPLE WIND UP PAYING WAY
MORE
FOR WATER THAN THEY SHOULD
BE PAYING ONE MONTH AND THEN
UNDERPAYING THE NEXT.
AND IT CAN BE AS MUCH AS $1,000
A YEAR.
UM, SO THAT'S MY MY CONCERN
ABOUT
THESE TIERED RATE STRUCTURES.
IF SOMEBODY CAN SHOW ME THAT
THERE EVERYBODY IS
DOING IT THE WAY IT'S SUPPOSED
TO BE DONE,
I WOULD I'M NOT I DON'T HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH IT,
BUT I'M YET TO SEE THAT.
SO SO I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED
ABOUT IT.
UH, THIS IS A DUE PASS TO THE
FLOOR.
SO AT THIS TIME, WE'LL GO AHEAD.
AND, UH, DID YOU WANT TO CLOSE?
OH, JUST RESPECTFULLY QUESTION
I VOTE.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND YEAH, THIS HAS BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR GLAZER.
SENATORS.
DURAZZO.
SATO.
NO.
DOLLY.
GLASER.
GLASER I.
SKINNER.
WAHAB.
WIENER.
WIENER I 2 TO 2.
OKAY.
THAT HAS.
GREAT.
I AM.
YOU MAY START WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS.
FIRST, LET ME BEGIN BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS,
WHICH ENSURE TRANSPARENCY BY
REQUIRING THAT ANY
COMPENSATION INCREASE OCCURS
DURING AN OPEN,
REGULAR MEETING AT THE AIR
DISTRICT.
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF
AND THE CHAIR AND ALL THE
MEMBERS FOR YOUR,
UH, ALL THE WORK BEING DONE ON
THIS BILL.
AND I AM PROUD TO PRESENT AB
2522,
WHICH INCREASES THE MAXIMUM
COMPENSATION FOR BOARD MEMBERS
FOR VARIOUS AIR DISTRICTS,
INCLUDING THE SOUTH COAST,
SACRAMENTO, SAN DIEGO,
BAY AREA, AND THE UNIFIED AIR
DISTRICTS.
MOREOVER, THE BILL AUTHORIZES
A YEARLY INCREASE IN
COMPENSATION
NOT TO EXCEED EITHER $0.05 5%,
OR INFLATION UP TO 10%.
AIR DISTRICT BOARD MEMBERS ARE
DEDICATED
PUBLIC SERVANTS ENTRUSTED WITH
IMPROVING AIR QUALITY AND
ESTABLISHING
EFFECTIVE CLEAN AIR PROGRAMS.
DESPITE THEIR IMPORTANCE TO OUR
ENVIRONMENT.
THE COMPENSATION LIMIT TO THE
BOARD
MEMBERS WAS LAST SET IN THE
1980S.
FOR EXAMPLE, COMPENSATION LIMITS
FOR SOUTH COAST
AQMD WAS LAST AMENDED IN 1987
OR 37 YEARS AGO.
AT THIS TIME, THE COMPENSATION
LIMIT WAS SET AT $100 PER DAY,
NOT EXCEEDING $1,000 PER MONTH.
OVER TIME, THIS FIGURE HAS
DIMINISHED
WITH INFLATION AND DOES
NOT REFLECT THE PUBLIC SERVICE
THESE BOARD MEMBERS PROVIDE.
THIS BILL WOULD INCREASE THESE
FIGURES
TO $200 A DAY, AT MOST $2,000
A MONTH,
AND PROVIDE THAT THE BOARD MAY
FURTHER INCREASE
COMPENSATION BY 5% OR INFLATION
UP TO 10%.
LAST YEAR.
SB 329 SIMILARLY INCREASED THE
COMPENSATION
LIMITS FOR CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS.
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
SOUTH COAST
AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT,
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA AIR
POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOCIATION,
WHICH REPRESENTS CALIFORNIA'S
35 LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS,
AND THERE IS NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB 25.
22 IS SENIOR PUBLIC AFFAIRS
MANAGER FOR THE SOUTH
COAST AQMD PHILIP CRABB AND
BRENDAN TUIGG,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA AIR
POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOCIATION.
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AND I VOTE.
ALL RIGHT.
WELCOME, BOTH OF YOU.
AND, UH, THE SAME THING IF YOU
WE GOT FIVE MINUTES,
IF YOU CAN SPLIT IT UP HOWEVER
YOU'D LIKE.
GO AHEAD.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS PHILIP CRABB.
I REPRESENT SOUTH COAST AQMD
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB 2522 AND SERVE AS THE
BILL'S SPONSOR.
WE APPRECIATE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR
AND COMMITTEE TO AMEND THE BILL
TO SPECIFY
THAT ANY INCREASE IN
COMPENSATION
MUST GO THROUGH A PUBLIC
PROCESS.
HOPEFULLY, THESE AMENDMENTS
ADDRESS SENATOR DOLLY'S
COMMENTS ON THE BILL AT THE LAST
COMMITTEE HEARING.
IN GENERAL, COMPENSATION LIMITS
FOR AIR DISTRICT BOARD
MEMBERS HAVE NOT INCREASED SINCE
THE 1980S,
LAST BEING SET AT $100 BASED ON
ESTIMATED INFLATION.
AN EQUIVALENT AMOUNT IN 2024
WOULD BE OVER $270 PER DAY.
THE BILL WOULD DOUBLE CURRENT
LIMITS
TO MODERNIZE COMPENSATION
TO BE MORE COMPARABLE TO LEVELS
SET NEARLY 40 YEARS AGO.
AIR DISTRICT BOARD MEMBERS
THROUGHOUT
THE STATE ARE DEDICATED IN THEIR
EFFORTS TO CLEAN THE AIR AND
PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
THEY ARE PUBLIC SERVANTS WHO
TRAVEL
LONG DISTANCES AND PERFORM
AN IMPORTANT PUBLIC SERVICE
WITH NOMINAL COMPENSATION.
THE OUTDATED PER DIEM LIMITS
PRESENT CHALLENGES
FOR AIR DISTRICT BOARD MEMBERS,
WHO HAVE OTHER ESSENTIAL DUTIES
TO PERFORM
AS LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS,
OR ARE PRIVATE CITIZENS WITH
EXISTING CAREERS
THAT PROVIDE THEIR PRIMARY
FINANCIAL SUPPORT.
AB 2522 ALSO CREATES AN
OPPORTUNITY
TO ENHANCE ENVIRONMENTAL
EQUITY IN ENVIRONMENTAL
GOVERNANCE.
IMPROVED FINANCIAL INCENTIVES
COULD ATTRACT
A MORE COMPREHENSIVE ARRAY OF
CANDIDATES,
INCLUDING THOSE FROM
UNDERREPRESENTED
AND VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES.
THE BILL ENHANCES LOCAL CONTROL
BY EMPOWERING
LOCAL AGENCIES TO APPROPRIATELY
UPDATE PER DIEM RATES GOING
FORWARD,
WITHOUT IMPACTING THE STATE
BUDGET.
THIS IS IN LINE WITH SB 329 DODD
SIGNED
INTO LAW IN 2023 THAT MORE
THAN TRIPLED COMPENSATION LIMITS
FOR CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT
FOR THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
NEXT SPEAKER.
>> MR.
CHAIR, MEMBERS BRENDAN TUG ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION.
THAT'S THE AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
OFFICERS FROM
ALL 35 LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS IN
SUPPORT.
MY COLLEAGUE, MR.
CRABB, HAS DONE A GOOD JOB.
I THINK MAKING THE CASE FOR
THIS.
WE THINK IT'S A REASONABLE
APPROACH,
A TRANSPARENT APPROACH TO
ADJUSTING
THESE COLD WAR ERA RATES.
AND WE URGE YOUR YOUR I VOTE.
COLD WAR ERA RATES.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY
AND FOR BEING AS KEEPING IT
BRIEF.
UM, AT THIS TIME, WE'LL TAKE
METOOS
IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
IF YOU COME ON UP TO THE MIC
STATE.
SO I DON'T SEE ANYBODY
SCRAMBLING UP HERE.
SO LET'S GO TO OPPOSITION.
IS THERE ANYBODY WHO WISHES
TO SPEAK
AS AN OPPOSITION LEAD OPPONENT?
OUR LEAD WITNESS?
NO.
OKAY.
ANYBODY WANT TO JUST SAY I DON'T
I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AT THE MICROPHONE.
NO, WE DON'T HAVE THAT.
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS.
QUESTIONS, MR.
GLAZER?
I KNOW THE INTENTIONS ARE GOOD
IN TERMS OF TRYING TO
GET A GOOD QUALITY BOARDS THAT
THAT SERVE AND THAT,
THAT THEIR WORK IS REALLY
IMPORTANT
AND VALUABLE TO US.
BUT I MUST ADMIT, I'M HAVING
TROUBLE WITH IT.
I'D LIKE TO ASK THIS.
THE THE THE SOUTH COAST AIR
QUALITY
REPRESENTATIVE A QUESTION YOU
HAVE REPS FROM THROUGHOUT
THE REGION ON YOUR BOARD, RIGHT?
SO I LOOK AT THE MEMBERSHIP, UM,
THEY ALL HAVE JOBS THAT THEY'RE
PAID FOR.
I MEAN, MANY OF THEM DO.
SO YOU HAVE A MEMBER FROM THE
BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS FROM LOS ANGELES.
HOW MUCH IS THAT PERSON PAID?
I DON'T KNOW, SORRY, SIR.
OKAY.
UH, I MEAN, A LOT OF MONEY.
THERE'S FIVE OF THEM.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE NUMBER IS.
SO.
AND WHEN WERE THEIR SALARIES
SET?
PROBABLY DON'T KNOW THAT TOO.
OKAY, I IMAGINE IT WASN'T SAID
IN THE COLD WAR.
PROBABLY NOT.
YOU HAVE MEMBERS FROM THE LOS
ANGELES
CITY COUNCIL ON THE ON THE
BOARD.
WHAT'S THEIR COMPENSATION?
SORRY.
SORRY, I DON'T KNOW THAT NUMBER.
I HAPPEN TO KNOW GENERALLY WHAT
IT IS.
I THINK IT'S THIS MATCHES A
SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE.
I THINK THAT'S OVER $200,000 A
YEAR AND IT ADJUSTS.
SO I'M STRUGGLING BECAUSE MANY
OF YOUR BOARD
MEMBERS ARE PAID ENORMOUS
AMOUNTS OF MONEY,
AND THEY'RE IN THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES
AS PUBLIC OFFICIALS.
THEN THEY GET TO BE APPOINTED
TO YOUR YOUR BOARD.
AND YET THEY MAY NOT HAVE ALL
THE TIME YOU'D LIKE THEM TO
HAVE,
BUT IT'S LIKE AN EXTRA BONUS IN
THEIR LIFE,
BECAUSE NOW WE'RE GOING TO PAY
THEM,
GOING TO GO FROM 12,000
TO 20 SOMETHING THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
SO IT'S NOT LIKE THESE ARE
IMPOVERISHED
INDIVIDUALS THAT
HAVE NO JOB AND THEREFORE YOU
GOT TO COMPENSATE THEM.
SO THIS IS THE TROUBLE THAT
I'M HAVING WITH THIS BILL.
BEST OF INTENTIONS.
THESE ARE GREAT PUBLIC SERVANTS
THAT
ARE SERVING IN THESE BOARDS.
BUT THAT'S THE STRUGGLE I'M
HAVING.
AND IF YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT YOUR
BOARD MEMBERS ARE PAID,
I THINK THAT'S A BLIND SPOT
BECAUSE
THIS ISN'T ALL THAT THEY'RE
MAKING,
AND THAT'S MY STRUGGLE.
SO THE AUTHOR CAN ADDRESS IT IF
SHE WISHES.
I KNOW HER INTENTIONS ARE THE
BEST HERE,
BUT THAT'S THE THAT'S THE
TROUBLE I'M
HAVING WITH THIS BROAD BASED
INCREASE
THAT IS BEING PROPOSED BEFORE
US.
THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE HAVE A QUESTION?
DID YOU WANT TO ANSWER OR YOU
WANT TO
ANSWER IN YOUR CLOSING OR GO
AHEAD?
OH, JUST TO RESPOND JUST
BRIEFLY.
UM, SO NO ACTUALLY POINT'S WELL
TAKEN.
UM, WE DO HAVE A DIVERSE ARRAY
OF BOARD
MEMBERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
SO THAT INCLUDES ALSO FOLKS THAT
WORK FOR NONPROFITS, UM,
LOCAL CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS WHO
ARE JUST
PAID MORE OF A PER DIEM LEVEL.
THERE'S A THERE'S A COMBINATION
IN TERMS OF WHO SERVES.
UM, ALSO, THAT'S ONE OF THE
ASPECTS
OF THE BILL IS PROVIDING FOR
THE FOLKS THAT MIGHT GET
APPOINTED TO
THE BOARD IN DIFFERENT
SITUATIONS.
PROVIDING A LITTLE BIT MORE
COMPENSATION
MIGHT MAKE IT MORE ACCESSIBLE
IN TERMS
OF AN OPPORTUNITY THAT THEY
MIGHT PRESENT
TO PUT THEMSELVES FORWARD,
TO BE REPRESENTED ON THE BOARD
OR TO BE APPOINTED.
IT'S A FAIR COMMENT, BUT THIS
THIS MEASURE DOESN'T
HAVE ANY OF THOSE DIFFERENTIALS
IN IT.
SO IF YOU WERE SAYING THAT
IF YOU HAVE AN EXISTING JOB THAT
PAYS YOU THAT THIS DOESN'T
COVER YOUR PER DIEM UNLESS
YOU'RE GOING TO SUBTRACT IT FROM
THE MONEY YOU'RE MAKING
FROM THIS IS LIKE A DOUBLE
DIPPING OPPORTUNITY.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO ELIMINATE
THE DOUBLE DIPPING OPPORTUNITY,
THEN THAT MAKES THE THE BILL
MORE APPEALING, RIGHT?
AND HONESTLY, I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT, YOU KNOW,
THE GOAL OF THE BILL TWO IS JUST
TO EQUALIZE.
37 YEARS AGO FOR OUR DISTRICT,
IT WAS SET AT $100.
WE'RE JUST LOOKING TO GET IT
EVEN,
NOT EVEN TO THE EQUIVALENT OF
INFLATION.
SO RIGHT NOW IT'S PROGRESSIVELY
GOTTEN TO A SMALLER AMOUNT.
THIS INCREASE DOESN'T EVEN GO TO
WHAT THE ORIGINAL INTENT WAS.
37 I GOT IT, BUT THAT'S JUST
A FRAMING
THAT MAKES THE BILL SEEM
APPEALING.
AND YOU'RE IGNORING ALL THE
UNDERLYING
FACTORS INVOLVED,
INCLUDING THE FACT THAT THESE
PEOPLE
ARE MAKING A LOT OF MONEY,
NOT ALL OF THEM, AND THAT IT'S
GOING
TO ALLOW THEM TO DOUBLE DIP.
IT'S GOING TO GIVE THEM EVEN
MORE.
IT'S LIKE A BONUS BUY,
AND THEY'RE GOING TO USE THE
TIME
DURING THE DAY WHEN YOUR
MEETINGS
ARE IF THEY'RE NOT,
MAYBE THEY'RE AT NIGHT AND AND
THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE WORKING THEIR
DAY JOB.
UM, AND SO THERE'S NO
DIFFERENTIAL IN HERE.
AND THEN THE LAST THING AND
AGAIN,
THE AUTHOR MAY WISH TO SPEAK TO
THIS IS THAT IT'S NOT AS IF YOU
HAVE A WHO SETS OUR SALARIES.
DO WE GET TO SET OUR SALARIES?
SENATOR DOLLY, CAN WE JUST SET
OUR SALARIES?
I'D LIKE TO DO A LITTLE
ADJUSTMENT.
NO, NO, WE DON'T GET TO DO THAT.
WHY IS THAT?
WE HAVE A CONFLICT OF INTEREST
IN SETTING OUR SALARIES.
SO THE FACT THAT YOU'RE
DELEGATING THIS
BACK TO THE LOCAL AIR DISTRICT
BOARD,
FOR THOSE SAME POLITICIANS TO
SET THEIR
OWN RATE IS ALSO A STRUGGLE,
BECAUSE IT'S NOT LIKE YOU'RE
SAYING IN THE BILL,
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THIS,
UH, CITIZENS UH, UH,
COMPENSATION COMMISSION TO
HELP SET THE RATES FOR US.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE A LITTLE
MORE INDEPENDENT THAN US.
THIS IS THE STRUGGLES I'M HAVING
WITH THE BILL.
AND I KNOW THE INTENTIONS ARE
GOOD,
AND I KNOW THAT THESE ARE GOOD
PEOPLE DOING THEIR BEST WORK.
BUT THIS IS THE BILL DOES NOT
HAVE
ANY OF THESE DISTINCTIONS
IN IT TO MAKE IT SEEM LIKE A
REASONABLE BILL.
SO WITH WITH ALL RESPECT.
WELL, I SAW THIS BILL EARLIER
AND I DID YOU ADDRESS SOME OF
THE CONCERNS I HAD AND I GUESS
THERE WAS AN AMENDMENT.
I HAVEN'T SEEN THAT AMENDMENT,
BUT I DID WANT TO ASK A QUESTION
OF WHERE DOES
THE AIR DISTRICT GET THEIR MONEY
TO MAKE
TO DO THE COMPENSATION TO START
WITH?
WELL, I CAN SPEAK FOR SOUTH
COAST.
IT'S A COMBINATION OF THINGS.
THERE'LL BE POTENTIALLY FEES.
SOMETIMES THERE'S FEDERAL
FUNDING THAT
WE NEED TO SEEK OUT STATE
FUNDING.
THERE'S A COMBINATION OF
DIFFERENT,
UH, WE HAVE PERMIT TYPES OF
THINGS.
SO SOME OF IT IS TRYING TO JUST
GENERATE,
BUT IT'S COMING FROM MANY
DIFFERENT SOURCES.
AND DOES IT ALSO COME FROM
FINES?
IT CAN COME FROM PENALTIES.
OKAY.
AND THEN THEN THE SECOND.
SO I'M ALONG THE SAME LINES AS
SENATOR GLAZER IS.
BUT BUT BUT AT LARGE MEMBERS
THAT AREN'T ELECTED TO IN
A BOARD OR A COUNCIL OR
SOMETHING
THAT GET APPOINTED.
I DO FEEL FOR THAT.
I FEEL FOR THEM BECAUSE THEY'RE
THE ONES THAT REALLY ARE
THE PUBLIC THAT ISN'T ALREADY
ELECTED TO A BOARD,
AND THOSE ARE THE ONES I THINK
WE SHOULD,
UH, FOCUS IN ON,
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT ALREADY
PAID BY
SOME AGENCY TO SIT ON THAT
BOARD.
SO THAT'S WHERE.
AND I HAVE THOSE ALL THROUGHOUT
MY DISTRICT.
THE AT LARGE PERSON THAT YOU
WANT THERE THAT IS DOESN'T
HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE AT SOME
OTHER AGENCY.
THEY NEED COMPENSATED BECAUSE
THEY'RE TRULY TAKING
TIME AWAY FROM THEIR BUSINESS
AND THEIR TIME OR,
OR THEIR FAMILY TO GO SIT ON
THIS BOARD THAT WE NEED.
SO THAT'S WHERE I THINK THIS
BILL SHOULD
FOCUS ON IS THOSE WHO AREN'T.
AND THE ABILITY TO SET YOUR OWN
SALARY
TO I THINK IS VERY DISTURBING.
SO IT MAKES IT TOUGH.
I WANT I WANT TO SUPPORT THE
PERSON THAT
YOU WANT TO ATTRACT TO THE
BOARD,
BUT NOT THE OTHER ONES AS AS
SENATOR GLAZER STATED.
OKAY.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS?
WE HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE THE
BILL.
UH, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
AND THANK YOU TO THE SENATORS
FOR THE ROBUST CONVERSATION,
I TOTALLY UNDERSTAND.
I THINK LOS ANGELES, UH,
BOARD OF SUPERVISOR SALARIES,
AS WELL AS THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES
SALARIES ARE VERY UNIQUE IN
THAT THEY ARE PROBABLY SOME OF
THE HIGHEST IN THE COUNTRY.
UH, THE THE SENTIMENT IN THE
LEGISLATURE
IN CALIFORNIA IS THAT YOU YOU
GO FROM
THE LEGISLATURE AND YOUR GOAL
IS TO BECOME
A CITY COUNCIL MEMBER IN LOS
ANGELES,
OR A COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISOR
VERSUS THE OTHER WAY AROUND.
SO I UNDERSTAND THE CRITICISM.
UH, THIS IS NOT WHAT THIS BILL
DOES.
IT'S NOT ABOUT REFORMING,
REFORMATTING WHO IS ON THESE
QUALITY AIR BOARDS.
THIS IS ABOUT COMPENSATION
LEVELS TO ACTUALLY SUPPORT
MOSTLY THE AT LARGE MEMBERS
ACROSS THE STATE
THAT IF THEY DO SERVE ON A CITY
COUNCIL,
IT'S MORE THAN LIKELY A PER DIEM
PART TIME JOB.
UH, WHILE THEY HAVE OTHER
RESPONSIBILITIES
IN THEIR DAY TO DAY LIFE.
UH, AND SO THE GOAL HERE IS TO
ENSURE
THAT WE ARE KEEPING UP TO DATE
WITH,
UH, INCREASES AND THAT
ULTIMATELY,
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE SERVING IN
OUR GOOD PUBLIC
SERVANTS HAVE COMPENSATION THAT
BENEFITS THEM.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS A COMMISSION
THAT OVERSEES OUR
INCREASES IN SALARY AS WELL AS
OUR PER DIEM.
THERE IS A GOVERNING BOARD THAT
DOES THAT.
THE GOVERNING BOARD FOR A FOR
THE AQMD IS THE LEGISLATURE.
SO UNLESS THE LEGISLATURE IS
IS ACTING EVERY YEAR TO DO
A POLICY ANNUALLY THAT'S GOING
TO INCREASE COMPENSATION,
THERE IS NO COMPENSATION.
SO THIS IS A BILL WITH 37 YEARS
IN THE MAKING.
AND SO THE CONVERSATIONS AND
THE CONCERNS
THAT WE HEARD IN PREVIOUS
COMMITTEES THAT
THIS SHOULD THESE INCREASES
SHOULD NOT BE
DONE IN A CLOSED SESSION NOW
ADDRESSED.
IT'S NOW BEING DONE AND HAS
ALWAYS THE INTENTION THAT
IT WOULD BE DONE IN PUBLIC WITH
A VERY PUBLIC VOTE.
SO THERE IS ABSOLUTE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
AS TO WHAT THAT INCREASE
IS GOING TO LOOK LIKE AND THE
MEMBERS
THAT ARE GOING TO VOTE FOR IT.
UNDERSTANDABLY, THAT LOS ANGELES
AND OTHER PLACES,
PERHAPS EVEN SAN FRANCISCO, ARE
QUITE UNIQUE.
UM, BUT THIS IS THIS IS THE
SITUATION
AND THE CURRENT STRUCTURE OF
AQMD.
AND SO OUR GOAL AT THE END OF
THE DAY IS JUST
TO BRING PARITY AND PAY PAY
PARITY WHEN
IT COMES TO THE COMPENSATION
THAT'S CURRENTLY,
UM, UH, BEING ADJUSTED FOR
INFLATION.
SO RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AND I VOTE AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
UM, WITH THAT, UH, THIS IS A
DUE PASS
RECOMMENDATION TO THE FLOOR,
AS AMENDED TO THE FLOOR.
SO GO AHEAD AND CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS DURAZZO.
CIERTO.
CIERTO?
NO.
DOLLY.
DOLLY, NO.
GLASER.
NO.
SKINNER.
WAHAB.
WIENER.
WIENER I123.
OKAY.
THAT VOTE IS 1 TO 3 RIGHT NOW.
WE'LL REMAIN OPEN FOR OTHERS
TO ADD ON AS THEY COME IN.
THANK YOU.
AND AT THIS TIME WE'RE GOING
TO GO TAKE A.
YEAH WE'RE GOING TO YOU'RE GOING
TO PASS COME BACK LATER OKAY.
VERY GOOD.
MISS PELLERIN.
COME ON UP.
I'M NOT TAKING OVER.
MM.
UH, YES.
WHY DON'T WE GO AHEAD AND TAKE
YOUR ITEM NUMBER 11?
THAT'S AB 2387.
>> VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
CHAIR AND SENATORS.
MOBILE HOME PARKS PROVIDE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF HOUSING UNITS IN CALIFORNIA,
OFTEN AT MORE AFFORDABLE PRICES
THAN OTHER OPTIONS.
BECAUSE MANUFACTURED HOMES.
OH, THERE WE GO.
MANUFACTURED HOMES ARE LESS
EXPENSIVE AND FASTER
TO CONSTRUCT THAN TRADITIONAL
SITE BUILT HOUSES.
THEY CAN BE A KEY COMPONENT OF
ADDRESSING THE HOUSING CRISIS.
HOWEVER, IN SOME AREAS, LOCAL
PERMITTING
PROCESSES AND EXCESSIVE
FEES CHARGED FOR ADDING LOTS IN
EXISTING MOBILE HOME PARKS CAN
REACH THE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS PER LOT BEING ADDED,
MAKING THE ADDITION OF LOTS IN
MOBILE
HOME PARKS COST PROHIBITIVE.
AB 2387 ALLOWS CALIFORNIA'S
EXISTING
MOBILE HOME PARKS TO APPLY TO
LOCAL
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO INCREASE
THEIR
NUMBER OF LOTS BY UP TO 10%,
AND INCENTIVIZES INCREASES IN
MOBILE
HOME SPACES BY EXEMPTING
ADDED SPACES FROM ADDITIONAL
BUSINESS
TAXES AND LOCAL FEES.
SAFEGUARDS IN THE BILL ENSURE
THAT ADDITIONAL
SPACES DO NOT SUBSTANTIALLY
IMPACT THE PROVISION OF UTILITY
SERVICES WITHIN THE PARK,
AND CLARIFY THAT ADDED UNITS
WILL NOT REMOVE
UNITS FOR LOCAL RENT CONTROL
MEASURES.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
TODAY IS JEFF NEAL,
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURED
HOUSING INSTITUTE.
WELCOME, SIR, AND THANK YOU FOR
TESTIFYING TODAY.
IF THERE'S ONLY ONE OF YOU, YOU
HAVE FIVE MINUTES,
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO USE IT
ALL IF YOU DON'T WANT TO.
THERE IS ONLY.
>> ONE OF ME, AND I WILL NOT BE
USING ALL FIVE MINUTES.
THANK YOU.
UH, THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
AND THANKS TO THE AUTHOR FOR,
UH,
FOR PURSUING THIS POLICY CHANGE.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR EXCELLENT ANALYSIS.
THERE IS A HOUSING CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE KNOW THAT THIS BILL IS
UNLIKELY
TO SOLVE IT ON ITS OWN,
BUT IT IS PART OF AN ALL OF THE
ABOVE STRATEGY FOR,
UH, FOR FOR FIGHTING THE HOUSING
CRISIS.
UM, IT WILL ADD AT LEAST
HUNDREDS,
ALMOST CERTAINLY THOUSANDS OF
NEW HOMES IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE NATURALLY
AFFORDABLE.
AS AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WAS
SAYING,
THEY IT DOES THIS WHILE
PROTECTING EXISTING HOME OWNERS
AND THEIR QUALITY OF LIFE.
UM, UH, ENSURING THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY
OF THE OF THE PARKS AND, AND UH,
ALL DOES NOT AFFECT ANY EXISTING
POLICIES OR LAWS AROUND
RENT CONTROL IN MANUFACTURED
HOUSING COMMUNITIES.
UH, SO WE APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PELLAR
AND AUTHORING THIS BILL AND ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AT THIS TIME, WE'LL TAKE THE
METOOS COMING UP,
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
YOU REPRESENT,
YOU SUPPORT THE BILL.
AND I'M GOING TO READ PASSING
THE CHAIR OVER.
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
MEMBERS CHRIS VAISAKI
REPRESENTING WMMA.
AND WE WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR INTRODUCING THIS BILL.
IT'S A IMPORTANT PART OF
THE ENTIRE HOUSING SOLUTION.
UM, IT WILL HELP US CREATE MORE
INVENTORY,
WHICH IS A GREAT GOAL FOR THE
LEGISLATURE.
AND WE WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR HER WORK ON THIS.
THANK YOU.
GREAT.
ANY OTHER?
ME TOO.
IN SUPPORT.
IT'S REALLY A CHAOTIC DAY HERE
IN THE CAPITAL.
LET ME JUST SAY, WHAT AM I DOING
HERE?
OKAY.
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO OPPOSITION.
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS REALLY GOOD BILL?
OH, I DIDN'T SAY THAT.
RIGHT.
ANYBODY HERE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL?
YES.
ALL RIGHT, I SEEING NONE.
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
HELLO, COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I HOPE EVERYBODY'S HAVING A NICE
DAY TODAY.
DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS?
THANK YOU, STAFF, FOR ALL YOUR
GOOD WORK.
UH, QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
UH.
WELL, IT SEEMS LIKE A VERY
REASONABLE BILL TO ME.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
IT'S BEEN GETTING THROUGH
COMMITTEES
VERY SUCCESSFULLY.
2387 ALL RIGHT.
I THINK I HEAR SOMETHING OVER
THERE,
BUT I'M GOING TO LET YOU CLOSE
FIRST.
WELL, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE.
ALL RIGHT.
I'M GOING TO RECOGNIZE THIS
INCREDIBLE MOTION
FROM SENATOR DALI TO MOVE THIS
BILL.
THIS IS A DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
BUT I DO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR
OUR CHAIR THAT HAS JUST
RETURNED,
WHETHER SHE HAS ANYTHING TO SAY
BEFORE
WE TAKE CARE OF THIS BILL.
OKAY.
SOUNDS LIKE SOUNDS LIKE THAT'S
A THANK YOU FOR STEPPING IN.
OKAY, SO WE'LL PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON THIS REALLY GOOD
BILL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATORS.
DURAZZO.
ACIERTO.
DOLLY.
DOLLY I.
GLASER.
GLASER I.
SKINNER.
WAHAB.
WIENER.
3 TO 0.
>> THAT POLANCO.
ITEM NUMBER TRIAL 1123 SEVEN.
THE.
YES.
ANOTHER.
PELLERIN.
THE PREVIOUS BILL.
YEAH, BUT WHICH NUMBER IS IT?
2387.
AB 2387 WILL BE HELD ON CALL.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
AND NOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLERIN
ON AB 335, ITEM 12.
YES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, I THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR DURAZZO
AND SENATORS,
I'LL START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS,
WHICH EXCLUDE FROM THE BILL
SITES THAT
ARE DEDICATED TO INDUSTRIAL USE.
AB 3335 EXPANDS AN EXISTING
STREAMLINED APPROVAL
PROCESS FOR AGRICULTURAL
EMPLOYEE
HOUSING IN THE TWO COUNTIES IN
MY DISTRICT,
SANTA CLARA AND SANTA CRUZ.
IN 2019, SPEAKER REAVIS AUTHORED
THE FARM WORKER HOUSING ACT,
WHICH CREATED A STREAMLINED
MINISTERIAL
APPROVAL PROCESS
FOR QUALIFYING AGRICULTURAL
EMPLOYEE HOUSING PROJECTS.
THE PROJECTS PROPOSED PURSUANT
TO THAT BILL
ARE REQUIRED TO MEET NUMEROUS
CRITERIA,
INCLUDING THAT THEY MUST BE
LOCATED ON LANDS DESIGNATED
FOR AGRICULTURE AND THE GENERAL
PLAN,
AND THAT PROJECTS MUST INCLUDE
NO MORE THAN 36 UNITS.
UNFORTUNATELY, THESE LIMITATIONS
MEAN THAT THERE ARE FEW PROJECTS
THAT COULD POTENTIALLY QUALIFY
FOR
STREAMLINING IN MY DISTRICT.
IN PARTICULAR, MOST SITES IN MY
DISTRICT THAT
COULD POTENTIALLY QUALIFY ARE
OUTSIDE OF
CITIES AND OTHER URBANIZED AREAS
AND LACK
THE NEEDED WATER AND SEWER
INFRASTRUCTURE.
SO WE ARE HERE WITH AB 3035 TO
MAKES TWO CHANGES
TO BROADEN THE SITES WHERE
AGRICULTURAL
EMPLOYEE HOUSING CAN BE
STREAMLINED IN
SANTA CLARA AND SANTA CRUZ
COUNTIES.
FIRST, IT EXPANDS THE SITE
QUALIFICATION TO
INCLUDE AREAS NEAR AGRICULTURAL
LAND THAT
ARE MORE LIKELY TO HAVE WATER
AND SEWER SERVICE
THAT CAN SUPPORT MULTI-UNIT
HOUSING.
SECOND, IT INCREASES THE NUMBER
OF UNITS THAT CAN BE INCLUDED
IN A QUALIFYING DEVELOPMENT TO
REFLECT THE ECONOMIES
OF SCALE TYPICALLY REQUIRED TO
DEVELOP HOUSING AND EXPENSIVE
HOUSING MARKETS LIKE THOSE IN
MY DISTRICT.
WHILE AB 3035 IS A DISTRICT
BILL,
WE HOPE THAT THIS PILOT PROJECT
CAN HELP INFORM FUTURE
OPPORTUNITIES TO STREAMLINE THIS
MUCH NEEDED
HOUSING FOR FARM WORKERS
STATEWIDE.
AND WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT
TODAY IS DAVID CAMPOS,
THE DEPUTY COUNTY EXECUTIVE FOR
THE COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
UH, ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLERIN.
MADAM CHAIR, HONOURABLE MEMBERS,
UH, DAVID CAMPOS,
DEPUTY COUNTY EXECUTIVE FOR
THE COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA.
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY,
I'M HERE TO SIMPLY ASK YOU TO
GIVE
US THIS TOOL SO THAT WE CAN DO
BETTER BY OUR FARM WORKERS.
THE FACT IS THAT WE AS A COUNTY,
WE AS A STATE,
MUST DO BETTER FOR THE PEOPLE
THAT PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE,
AND WHEN YOU HAVE BEFORE YOU
IS A PRETTY MODEST BILL THAT
ESSENTIALLY BUILDS ON THE WORK
THAT SPEAKER RIVAS
HAS ALREADY DONE TO EXPEDITE THE
BUILDING OF THIS
HOUSING IN AREAS THAT ARE ZONED
FOR AGRICULTURE.
BUT AS WE AS WAS NOTED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLERIN,
THAT HOUSING HAS NOT BEEN BUILT
SIMPLY BECAUSE
THOSE AREAS LACK THE
INFRASTRUCTURE,
THE WATER, THE SEWER SYSTEM TO
ACTUALLY
MAKE HOUSING AFFORDABLE.
WHAT THIS DOES IS SIMPLY EXPANDS
THE GEOGRAPHIC
AREA TO AREAS NEAR THE
AGRICULTURAL ZONES.
SO THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY BUILD
HOUSING
NOT ONLY THAT'S AFFORDABLE,
BUT ON THE SCALE THAT IS NEEDED.
IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY ALONE,
WE NEED AT LEAST 700 UNITS
TO HOUSE THE PEOPLE THAT PUT
FOOD ON THE TABLE.
THE COUNTY HAS MADE AN
INVESTMENT.
WE HAVE A MASTER PLAN.
WE HAVE IDENTIFIED FUNDING,
BUT WE NEED THIS EXPEDITED
PROCESS SO THAT WE CAN FINALLY
BUILD THIS HOUSING.
THIS IS A MODEST EFFORT THAT
WILL ALLOW
SANTA CLARA AND SANTA CRUZ TO
BEGIN
THIS PROCESS AND HOPEFULLY SHOW
THE REST OF THE STATE HOW THIS
IS DONE.
UH, SUPERVISOR SYLVIA ARENAS
HAS BEEN
LEADING THIS EFFORT IN SANTA
CLARA.
SHE COULDN'T BE HERE TODAY.
BUT ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY,
WE ARE GRATEFUL TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PELLER
AND HER STAFF AND HOPE THAT
YOU CAN
JOIN HER AND GIVE US THIS
ABILITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
MUCH.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRINGING
UP THIS ISSUE AND WORKING ON
THIS.
UM, ANY MORE ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT?
NO.
SB 335.
SEEING NONE.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION?
OKAY SEEING NONE.
WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE DAIS?
THANK YOU.
SENATOR GLAZER MOVES THE BILL.
SEEING NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS,
PLEASE.
ROLL CALL.
OH, CLOSING.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATORS DURAZZO I DURAZZO I
CIERTO CIERTO I DOLLY.
DOLLY I.
GLASER.
GLASER I SKINNER.
WAHAB.
WEINER 4 TO 0.
APPRECIATE IT.
HOLD ON.
CALL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
50.
NOW.
WHICH ONE IS?
IT'S OKAY TO TAKE UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
DO YOU WANT TO GO?
NO, THIS IS THIS IS.
SHE LEFT?
IT'S NUMBER NINE.
OKAY.
WE'RE GOING TO ITEM NUMBER NINE.
UH, AB 1950 ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WENDY CARRILLO.
THANK YOU FOR PUTTING IT OVER
FOR A SECOND.
YOU GOT BACK?
OH, YEAH.
BEFORE YOU GET STARTED, I JUST
WANT TO THANK
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR HOLDING
OFF,
UH, GIVING ME TIME TO GET HERE.
THANK YOU.
>> NO PROBLEM.
NO.
HELLO?
>> OKAY.
WELL SHOULD I?
SHOULD I START?
OKAY.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
AND SENATORS, I'D LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE.
FIRST, LET ME JUST THANK THE
CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR YOUR HARD WORK ON
THIS BILL.
ALONGSIDE WITH MY STAFF, I'D
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN PROPOSED.
AND I HAVE, AND I AM COMMITTED
TO TAKING THOSE
AMENDMENTS IN SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE,
WHICH IS WHERE THIS BILL
HOPEFULLY IS HEADED NEXT.
UH, THE SENATOR AND I ARE
WORKING
ON JUST A SMALL PIECE OF
OF THE POLICY RELATED TO THE
CONSTRUCTION
OF THE MEMORIAL,
WHICH WE ARE HOPING TO COME TO
A RESOLUTION
AS TO WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE.
AND TODAY, I AM PROUD TO PRESENT
AB 1950,
THE CHAVEZ RAVINE ACCOUNTABILITY
ACT.
THIS BILL ACKNOWLEDGES THE
HISTORICAL
DISPLACEMENT OF THE PALO VERDE,
LA LOMA, AND BISHOP COMMUNITIES
KNOWN TODAY AS CHAVEZ RAVINE.
THIS POLICY IS SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
AND OUR INSURANCE COMMISSIONER,
RICARDO LARA IN 1950.
AB 1950 IS A CRITICAL STEP
FORWARD AND AIMS TO
CORRECT AN INJUSTICE THAT
DISPLACED FAMILIES
AND HAS LINGERED IN THE SHADOWS
OF LOS ANGELES
EAST SIDE HISTORY FOR FAR TOO
LONG.
AMID THE 1950S, THE VIBRANT
COMMUNITIES OF PALO VERDE,
LA LOMA AND BISHOP HOME TO
MOSTLY MEXICAN
AMERICAN FAMILIES AS WELL AS
ITALIAN,
AMERICAN AND CHINESE AMERICAN
FAMILIES,
SAW AN UPHEAVAL AS FAMILIES
WERE UPROOTED AND DISPLACED IN
THE NAME OF PROGRESS.
FAMILIES WERE PROMISED A RETURN
TO BETTER HOUSING,
BUT INSTEAD WERE LEFT DESTITUTE.
DURING THIS TIME,
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
UNDERVALUED
THE PROPERTIES AND OFFERED
VERY MINIMAL COMPENSATION,
AND ALSO CALLED THESE
COMMUNITIES SLUMS.
AND THEY WERE ACTUALLY VERY
VIBRANT COMMUNITIES WITH
THEIR OWN PARKS AND SCHOOLS AND
SUPERMARKETS.
ULTIMATELY, THE CITY ENDED
UP USING EMINENT DOMAIN TO
REMOVE THE REMAINING FAMILIES OF
THESE COMMUNITIES.
FOR GENERATIONS, CHAVEZ RAVINE
STOOD AS
A AS A BEACON OF HOPE AND
RESILIENCE,
EMBODYING THE DREAMS AND
ASPIRATIONS OF FAMILIES
WHO BUILT THEIR LIFE IN ITS
EMBRACE.
WITH THIS LEGISLATION, WE ARE
ADDRESSING THE PAST,
GIVING VOICE TO THIS INJUSTICE,
ACKNOWLEDGING THE PAIN OF THESE
FAMILIES
AND OFFERING POTENTIAL
COMPENSATION MEASURES,
AND ENSURING THAT WE HONOR AND
REMEMBER
THE LEGACY OF THESE FAMILIES
AND THE COMMUNITIES OF PALO
VERDE,
LA LOMA, AND BISHOP.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD, I URGE YOU
TO LEND YOUR
SUPPORT TO ESTABLISH THE HEALING
FOR
THE DESCENDANTS OF WHOM WERE
DISPLACED
IN RELATIONS TO THESE
COMMUNITIES.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND IS PART OF A LARGER
CONVERSATION RELATED TO
GENERATIONAL
WEALTH AND HOME OWNERSHIP.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I VOTE.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR DARAZO
AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE JOSEPHINE
FIGUEROA,
DEPUTY COMMISSIONER AND
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF
INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA.
FIRST, I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARRILLO
FOR AUTHORING THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE.
I ALSO WISH TO THANK CHAIR,
DURAZO AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR
WORK IN ADVANCING AB 1950.
THROUGHOUT HIS CAREER IN PUBLIC
SERVICE,
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA HAS BEEN STEADFAST
IN HIS COMMITMENT TO SERVING
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
FROM ADVOCATING FOR UNIVERSAL
HEALTH
CARE TO CHAMPIONING
ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE IN THE FIGHT AGAINST
CLIMATE CHANGE,
COMMISSIONER LATTA'S MISSION
HAS ALWAYS
BEEN TO CONFRONT HISTORICAL
INJUSTICES
AND FOSTER A MORE EQUITABLE
SOCIETY
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
HIS COMMITMENT CONTINUES AS
THE PROUD SPONSOR OF AB 1950.
AS AMENDED.
WE WHAT WE SEEK TO ADDRESS
WITH AB 1950 IS KNOWLEDGE,
UNDERSTANDING AND HEALING THE
NEIGHBORHOODS OF
THE NEIGHBORHOODS OF PALO VERDE,
LA LOMA,
AND BISHOP IN LOS ANGELES SERVED
AS
A HAVEN FOR HISTORICALLY
MARGINALIZED
POPULATIONS SEEKING HOUSING
SECURITY
AMIDST SYSTEMATIC
DISCRIMINATION.
LONG STANDING RESIDENTS OF THESE
COMMUNITIES WERE
NEVER FAIRLY COMPENSATED FOR
THEIR PROPERTY.
BOTH LANDOWNERS AND TENANTS,
MANY OF WHOM
HAD LIVED THERE FOR GENERATIONS,
WERE COERCED INTO LEAVING THEIR
HOMES.
ALTHOUGH MANY RESISTED,
ALL WERE EVENTUALLY DISPLACED.
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO BEGIN
TO ADDRESS THIS, AND WE SHOULD.
THIS LEGISLATION PRESENTS A
CRUCIAL
FIRST STEP IN PROVIDING
LONG OVERDUE COMPENSATION TO
THESE RESIDENTS.
IT ALSO OFFERS A PATH TO
RECONCILIATION AND HEALING
FOR ALL THOSE IMPACTED BY
ADJUSTING PAST WRONGS.
AB 1950 PAVES THE WAY FOR A MORE
JUST AND EQUITABLE LOS ANGELES.
IT WILL HELP EDUCATE ANGELENOS
ABOUT THE TRUE HISTORY
OF WHAT IS NOW KNOWN AS CHAVEZ
RAVINE.
PROMOTING TRANSPARENCY AND
UNDERSTANDING.
AB 1950 MARKS A SIGNIFICANT
MILESTONE IN THE JOURNEY
TOWARDS ACHIEVING JUSTICE FOR
THESE FAMILIES.
WE AIM TO RECTIFY THESE ERASURE
OF THEIR HOMES,
THEIR IDENTITY FROM THE LAND
AND TO WRITE
A NEW CHAPTER IN LOS ANGELES
HISTORY,
ONE THAT ACKNOWLEDGES THE PAST
INJUSTICES
AND HONORS THEIR ENDURING
LEGACY.
ON BEHALF OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA,
I ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN SUPPORT OF
AB 1950?
SEEING?
NONE.
UH, ANYONE IN OPPOSITION?
ANYONE WANT TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION?
NOPE.
SEEING NONE.
UM, COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
DAIS.
YES, SENATOR.
DOLLY.
SO THANK YOU, ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD.
I NEED TO GET EDUCATED A LITTLE
BIT.
SO FIRST OFF, UM.
I'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE STAFF
HERE AND TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT I'M NOT FROM THE AREA,
SO I DON'T KNOW THE HISTORY,
BUT I AM VERY DEDICATED TO
PRIVATE PROPERTY RIGHTS
AND WE HAVE THE ABILITY FOR
EMINENT DOMAIN.
AND EMINENT DOMAIN SHOULD BE
USED FOR PUBLIC,
FOR THE GOOD OF THE PUBLIC.
AND WHEN YOU WHEN THE PUBLIC
DECIDES TO TAKE YOUR LAND,
THEY NEED TO COMPENSATE YOU
FAIRLY FOR IT.
SO I WANT TO JUST MAYBE I'LL
TELL
YOU WHAT I THINK I KNOW,
AND THEN MAYBE YOU CAN CORRECT
ME IF I'M NOT RIGHT.
SO THE PROPERTY WAS TAKEN FOR
HOUSING OR SOME
OTHER PROJECT BESIDES THE
STADIUM ORIGINALLY,
AND, UH, THEN THAT FELL THROUGH.
AND THEN LATER ON, SOMEBODY CAME
IN AND SAID,
HEY, WE'LL BUILD A STADIUM
THERE.
AND THEY BUILT THE STADIUM
THE STADIUM IS OWNED BY SOME
PRIVATE PEOPLE.
IT'S NOT THE GOVERNMENT THAT
OWNS
IT OR THE GOOD OF THE PUBLIC.
SO IN MY OPINION, THAT'S WRONG.
YOU SHOULDN'T TAKE LAND FROM
SOMEBODY, UH,
UNLESS IT'S FOR THE GOOD OF THE
PUBLIC.
AND BUT WE DID HAVE, IN SOME
CASES,
UNDER REDEVELOPMENT,
THERE WAS AN ABILITY TO BE ABLE
TO TAKE
BLIGHTED AREAS AND REDEVELOP
THOSE.
AND THEY HAD THE POWER FOR
EMINENT DOMAIN.
THERE WAS A CASE THAT WENT
THROUGH THE SUPREME
COURT THAT ALLOWED THAT TO
HAPPEN.
SO MAYBE YOU COULD EDUCATE ME
ON.
WERE THEY FAIRLY COMPENSATED
AT THE TIME?
NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER TWO,
WHAT HAPPENED AT THE JUNCTURE OF
WHEN THEY DECIDED TO ALLOW THEM
TO BUILD A STADIUM THERE?
AND DID THEY GIVE THE FIRST
RIGHT
OF REFUSAL BACK TO THOSE
FAMILIES THAT HAD BEEN DISPLACED
OUT OF THEIR PROPERTIES?
THANK YOU, SENATOR, AND
APPRECIATE YOUR
YOUR FRAME AND THE HISTORICAL
ASPECT.
SO BETWEEN BETWEEN THAT ERA IN
THE 1950S,
THE LOS ANGELES HOUSING
AUTHORITY
DEEMED THESE COMMUNITIES TO
BE, UH,
NOT DESIRABLE AREAS TO LIVE.
AND SO THEY WERE DEEMED AS SLUMS
BY INDIVIDUALS IN POWER.
THE COMMUNITY ITSELF DID NOT
SEE THEMSELVES THAT WAY,
BUT THERE WAS A VERY PRO-HOUSING
AGENDA THAT
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES HAD AT
THAT TIME.
AND IN FACT, THE ELYSIAN VALLEY,
UH,
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT THAT HAD
ALREADY
BEEN SLATED WITH TRUMAN,
TRUMAN ERA FEDERAL FUNDING WAS
MOVING FORWARD.
THEN AN ELECTION HAPPENED, AND
THE MAYOR THAT
WAS VERY PRO HOUSING LOST HIS
ELECTION.
AND THE MAYOR THAT CAME AFTER
WAS VERY ANTI HOUSING.
AND IN FACT, IT ALMOST SEEMS AS
IF HISTORY REPEATS ITSELF,
BECAUSE AT THE TIME IT WAS
LABELED
AS A SOCIALIST HOUSING AGENDA.
AND SO IN A COMMUNIST RED SCARE
ERA,
AT THE SAME TIME,
THIS IS ALL HAPPENING ALL AT
ONCE.
UH, A NEW ELECTION ALLOWED FOR
AN ANTI-HOUSING MAYOR TO COME
IN.
AND SO THE PROMISES MADE TO THE
COMMUNITIES,
THE LOWERED VALUED OFFERED FOR
THOSE HOMES IN AN EFFORT
TO BUILD HOUSING WAS NEVER
ACTUALLY FULFILLED.
THE FAMILIES WERE NOT GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE THE FIRST RIGHT OF REFUSAL
TO COME BACK.
AND SO THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
EVENTUALLY BECAME
THE PROPERTY OWNER OF ALL THAT
AREA.
AND AND IN THAT FOLLOWING
ELECTION, UH,
THE FIRST THE YOUNGEST CITY
COUNCILWOMAN,
SHE WAS 22 YEARS OLD AT THE
TIME,
CAMPAIGNED ON A PROMISE TO BRING
MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL TO LOS ANGELES.
AND IN ALL THAT CONVERSATION,
THE PEOPLE THAT WERE HURT THE
MOST
WERE THE PEOPLE OF THESE THREE
COMMUNITIES
WHO WERE DISPLACED,
WHO WERE GIVEN LESS MONEY FOR
THEIR PROPERTY,
WHO WERE PROMISED HOUSING AND
WERE PROMISED
THE OPPORTUNITY TO RETURN,
AND NEVER HAD THAT PROMISE
FULFILLED,
THAT HOUSING WAS NEVER
DEVELOPED.
AND THEN ULTIMATELY, FOR THE
REMAINING
FAMILIES THAT HAD REFUSED TO
LEAVE,
EMINENT DOMAIN WAS USED TO KICK
THEM OUT,
AND THE HOUSING NEVER HAPPENED.
AND SO IT'S A WE'RE TRYING TO
TO CREATE JUSTICE
FOR SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED
IN LOS
ANGELES AND ULTIMATELY REALLY
TELL THE STORY
OF THESE FAMILIES AND HOW THESE
LOSS,
THIS LOSS OF LAND REALLY
HAPPENED IN THE PROMISE
FOR HOUSING THAT NEVER ACTUALLY
TOOK PLACE.
SO WHAT DOES THIS BILL.
AND THIS IS A BILL THAT DOES
WHAT
TO UNDERSTAND OR TO DO A REPORT
OR SOMETHING BACK TO WHO IT'S
BEEN AMENDED I KNOW TO.
CAN YOU CAN YOU SHARE WITH WHAT
I KNOW THAT.
SO THE TOUGH PART FOR SOMEBODY
LIKE ME WHO
IS GETTING EDUCATED ON THE
HISTORY,
NUMBER ONE, WE CAN'T CHANGE
HISTORY.
AND THEN WHO'S LIABLE IN THE
FUTURE
BECAUSE SOME OF THE PEOPLE THAT
WERE THERE THAT MADE THE WRONG
DECISIONS
AREN'T HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
BUT WHO'S GOING TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AT THE END?
AND WHO HAS TO PAY IF THERE'S
IF THERE'S COMPENSATION FOR UM.
SURE YOU KNOW WRONG.
THE EDUCATION PIECE IS CRITICAL
TO THIS BILL,
AND UNDERSTANDING AND ENSURING
THAT THIS
PIECE OF OF VERY LOS ANGELES
FOCUS,
UH, HISTORY, IS TOLD NOT ONLY
TO L.A.
BUT REALLY THROUGHOUT THE STATE,
ESPECIALLY AS LAND USE AND LAND
USE MANAGEMENT
AND HOUSING AND THE WAY IN WHICH
LOS ANGELES BUILDS ITS FREEWAYS.
THIS IS ONLY ONE EXAMPLE OF MANY
COMMUNITIES THAT,
UM, WERE LOST AMID THE USE OF
EMINENT DOMAIN.
ANOTHER PROMINENT COMMUNITY
IS A SUGAR HILL COMMUNITY
OF THE WEST ADAMS AREA IN LOS
ANGELES,
A VERY AFFLUENT AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY WHOSE HOMES
WERE TORN DOWN BY THE USE OF
EMINENT DOMAIN,
AND THE, UH, FREEWAY, THE TEN
FREEWAY BEING BUILT.
WE'VE SEEN THAT BILL LIKE FIVE
TIMES.
WELL, IT'S IT'S ONE OF MANY.
BUT WHAT CAME OUT,
WHAT CAME OUT OF THAT
CONVERSATION
AND CONVERSATIONS THAT WERE
STRONGLY
LED BY THE BLACK CAUCUS ON
CONVERSATIONS
OF REPARATIONS,
WAS THE IMPORTANCE OF STUDIES.
AND SO THIS BILL MIRRORS IN
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN.
IT MIRRORS SOME OF THAT WORK
THAT THAT HAS
ALREADY BEEN DONE TO CREATE
STUDIES.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY, THE TASK
FORCE ASSOCIATED WITH
THE THREE COMMUNITIES OF CHAVEZ
RAVINE, UM,
WOULD BE INFLUENCED AND BY
ACTUAL COMMUNITY
MEMBERS WORKING IN COLLABORATION
WITH THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES TO
DETERMINE WHAT HAPPENS NEXT.
IT IS NOT UP TO THE LEGISLATURE
TO DETERMINE THAT.
SO WE ARE FORMING A COMMUNITY
LED TASK FORCE WITH
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES TO BRING
AWARENESS,
TO THINK ABOUT NEXT STEPS,
AND ULTIMATELY ALSO CREATE A
MEMORIAL IN THIS SITE.
THE FAMILIES STILL GATHER.
IN FACT, THIS 4TH OF JULY
WEEKEND,
THE FAMILIES WILL BE HONORING
50 YEARS OF THEM
COMING TOGETHER AFTER THE LAST
DISPLACEMENT.
THEY'RE STILL DESCENDANTS.
THERE ARE STILL FAMILIES.
IF YOU LOOK AT A RECENT STORY IN
THE LA TIMES, UH,
FOLKS TALK ABOUT LIKE WHERE
THIRD
BASE IS OF THAT OF THE STADIUM,
IT'S WHERE THEIR HOME USED TO
BE.
AND THIS ISN'T ABOUT MAJOR
LEAGUE
BASEBALL OR WHO PLAYS THERE.
THIS IS ABOUT THE ACTIONS THAT
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
TOOK AGAINST THE FAMILIES OF
THESE COMMUNITIES,
TRYING TO CREATE A RIGHT FOR
MANY
WRONGS AND AT THE VERY MINIMUM,
START A HEALING CONVERSATION
AND NOT
IGNORING WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
PAST.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR CIERTO.
OKAY, SO MY DAD WAS NEVER A
DODGER FAN.
YOU KNOW WHY?
BECAUSE OF THIS.
HE DID HAVE FRIENDS THAT LIVED
IN THAT AREA.
UM, BUT THEN THOSE FRIENDS THAT
THEY RELOCATED ELSEWHERE.
THIS IS SQUARELY IN THE MIDDLE
OF LA CITY.
AND THE LA CITY COUNCIL AND THE
LA CITY'S MAYOR.
AND ALL OF THOSE FOLKS HAVE THE
CAPACITY
TO DEAL WITH THIS ISSUE IN A
FAIR WAY,
A WAY THAT THEY THINK IS FAIR.
AND THEY SHOULD IF THEY WANT
TO GO BACK 70
YEARS AND AND TRY TO UNTANGLE
SOMETHING,
THEN I SAY, MORE POWER TO YOU.
UM, IF THEY WANT TO SPEND THEIR
TAXPAYER
DOLLARS DOING THAT, MORE POWER
TO THEM.
UM, THE STADIUM ALSO BROUGHT IN,
UM, A LOT OF WEALTH IN THE AREA.
LOS FELIZ AREA, UH, IS IS HOME
TO A LOT OF WEALTHY,
UH, WEALTHIER HOMES,
NOT THE WEALTHIEST,
BECAUSE ALL THOSE WENT UP INTO,
UH,
BRENTWOOD AND AND THE OTHER
HILLS
A LITTLE BIT, UH, MORE WEST,
UH, BUT, UM, YOU KNOW,
BACK IN THE EARLY 60S AND 70S
WITH,
WITH THE CHAVEZ RAVINE THERE,
UM, YOU KNOW,
IT PRETTY MUCH THE WHOLE AREA
WAS FLOURISHING,
THE BUSINESSES WERE FLOURISHING,
AND ALL OF THAT WAS AND I DON'T
KNOW WHETHER,
YOU KNOW,
THEY ALLOWED THESE PEOPLE OR
THESE PEOPLE
STAYED IN THE AREA OR THEY
DIDN'T.
BUT WHEN THEY GET RELOCATED,
SOME OF THEM MIGHT
HAVE RELOCATED DOWN BY DOWN BY
THE BEACH AREAS.
AND THEN ARE WE GOING TO STUDY
TO SEE WHAT THEIR
ECONOMIC CONDITION WAS LATER
ON IN LIFE?
BECAUSE SOMETIMES THAT LED TO
THEM BEING IN
AN AREA THAT BECAME EVEN MORE
PROSPEROUS.
SO, YOU KNOW, THERE'S SO MANY
OF THESE ISSUES.
THROUGHOUT.
CALIFORNIA AND EVERYWHERE.
AND IF WE'RE GOING TO SPEND
ALL OF
OUR TIME AND EFFORTS AND MONEY
TRYING TO UNWIND THOSE AND FIND
OUT
WHO WAS WRONGED AND WHO WAS,
YOU KNOW, WHO CAME OUT BETTER OR
WHO CAME OUT WORSE.
UM, WE'RE GOING TO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE GOING
TO BE DOING FOR THE REST OF OUR
LIVES.
UH, SO, UM, YOU KNOW, HARD FOR
ME TO SUPPORT
BILLS LIKE THIS JUST BECAUSE
OF THAT.
YOU CAN'T UNWIND 70 YEARS OF
HISTORY BECAUSE
YOU HAVE TO TAKE THE GOOD AND
THE BAD,
FIGURE OUT ALL OF WHAT HAPPENED.
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY, THIS
IS L.A.
CITIES TO DEAL WITH.
THEY LIKE THIS STUFF,
THEY NEED TO DEAL WITH THIS
STUFF.
THIS IS NOT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS
AND MY TAXPAYERS OUT,
IN, OUT IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY TO
BE PAYING FOR.
UH, SO I WON'T BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL BECAUSE OF THAT.
UH, MY DAD IS HE WENT TO HIS
GRAVE
NOT BEING A DODGER FAN,
THOUGH, IF THAT MAKES ANYBODY
FEEL BETTER.
UH.
THANK YOU, SENATOR.
SENATOR DOLLAR, YOU HAD A FOLLOW
UP QUESTION.
YEAH.
SO I, I SUPPORTED THE BROWN'S
BEACH RESOLUTION OR BILL
THAT CAME THROUGH THAT SENATOR
BRADFORD BROUGHT FORTH,
QUITE FRANKLY, BECAUSE THE CITY
MADE A MOVE FIRST AND SAID,
HEY, THIS IS SOMETHING WE NEED
TO DO.
THEN HE BROUGHT THE LEGISLATION
AND I THINK IT WAS RIGHTEOUS.
AND AT THE SAME TIME THAT THE
CITY
STILL OWNED THE PROPERTY.
SO YOU CAN ACTUALLY DO SOMETHING
RIGHT HERE IN THIS CASE.
UM, WHY ISN'T THE CITY COUNCIL
DOING
SOMETHING ABOUT WHY ARE WE.
AND I THINK SENATOR BRINGS UP A
REALLY GREAT POINT.
SO CAN YOU MAYBE ADDRESS THAT
ISSUE AS WELL?
BECAUSE I'M WITH HIM, I LOOK,
I'M TRYING TO LEARN THE HISTORY.
I LOVE PRIVATE PROPERTY RIGHTS.
I HATE EMINENT DOMAIN.
UNLESS IT'S ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY.
UM, BUT I ALSO DON'T WANT TO BE
ON THE HOOK TO PAY
FOR SOMETHING THAT I HAD NOTHING
TO DO WITH.
>> MHM.
WELL, IF I MAY, NO ONE'S ON
THE HOOK FOR PAYING FOR
ANYTHING.
YOUR COUNTY, RIVERSIDE COUNTY,
ANY OTHER COUNTY IS NOT ON THE
HOOK
FOR ANYTHING FIRST AND FOREMOST.
IN FACT, THE BILL DOES NOT
MANDATE ANY COMPENSATION,
NOT EVEN FROM THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES.
IT ESTABLISHES A TASK FORCE
THAT'S GOING TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO BRING
PEOPLE TOGETHER,
HOW TO TALK ABOUT THIS HISTORY
THAT HAPPENED IN LOS ANGELES
AND MAKE MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS AS
WHAT HAPPENS MOVING FORWARD.
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES WILL BE
INVOLVED IN THAT CONVERSATION.
I WOULD LOVE FOR THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES,
WHO HAS HAD DECADES TO DO
SOMETHING
ABOUT THIS ISSUE,
TO HAVE ACTED, AND SADLY, IT
DIDN'T.
I REPRESENT THIS COMMUNITY.
I GREW UP IN, THIS COMMUNITY.
I LOVE THIS COMMUNITY,
AND I ALSO LOVE OUR BASEBALL
TEAM.
BUT I ALSO BELIEVE IN HOLDING MY
CITY ACCOUNTABLE.
AND SO THESE ARE TOUGH
CONVERSATIONS.
THEY ARE NOT EASY.
BUT EVERY DAY WE MOVE THE NEEDLE
TOWARDS JUSTICE.
EVERY DAY, A NEW STORY COMES UP
FROM SOMEONE WHO
GREW UP IN THAT COMMUNITY WHO
WAS DISPLACED,
WHO WHO IS A DESCENDANT OF MR..
SENATOR SATO, YOUR FAMILY
INCLUDED.
I KNOW YOU HAVE FAMILY IN MY
DISTRICT,
IN THE COMMUNITY OF EAGLE ROCK
AND ALL THE COMMUNITIES AROUND
IT.
AND SO IT'S IT'S VERY
INTERESTING TO LOOK AT THIS,
THIS PIECE OF PROPERTY AND SEE,
YOU KNOW, HOW MUCH IT'S
FLOURISHED
AND THRIVED THROUGHOUT THE
DECADES,
WHILE ALSO UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE WERE PEOPLE
THAT WHOSE WHO WERE GIVEN LESS
THAN WHAT
WOULD BE WHAT ANY OF US WOULD
HAVE SEEN AS AS
APPROPRIATE NUMBERS FOR THOSE
PROPERTIES.
AND WHEN YOU HAVE AND WHEN YOU
LOOK
AT GOVERNMENTS OF THE 1950S,
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES OF THE
1950S IS
NOT THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
TODAY.
PEOPLE IN POWER OF THE 1950S
DID NOT
LOOK LIKE THE REPRESENTATIVES
THAT REPRESENT THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES TODAY.
AND SO WHILE YOU KNOW, I WISH
THAT THE CITY
WOULD HAVE ACTED SOONER, IT
DIDN'T.
BUT WE ARE IN COLLABORATION AND
IN CONVERSATION
AS TO HOW WE MOVE A POLICY
FORWARD THAT
ULTIMATELY SETS THE GOAL OF OF
CREATING SOME
KIND OF JUSTICE FOR THE
DESCENDANTS.
IT IS NEVER TOO LATE TO LOOK
AT HISTORY.
IT IS NEVER TOO LATE TO SAY THAT
SOMETHING WAS DONE WAS WRONG.
IT IS NEVER TOO LATE TO SPEND
TIME TO
CORRECT THAT AND TO THINK ABOUT.
THESE ARE NOT FAMILIES THAT NO
LONGER EXIST.
THEY ARE STILL LIVING IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
THEY LIVE IN MY DISTRICT.
THEY GATHER EVERY YEAR AND HAVE
BEEN
GATHERING FOR THE PAST 50 YEARS
TO
COMMEMORATE WHAT HAPPENED TO
THEM
AND WHAT HAPPENED TO THEIR
FAMILIES.
AND THEY GATHER EVERY 4TH OF
JULY.
AND I THINK THAT'S SIGNIFICANT.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD HONOR
AND THAT WE SHOULD MOVE FORWARD,
AND THAT WE SHOULD ULTIMATELY
ALLOW
FOR THE CONVERSATION TO HAPPEN.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY, FOR A
MEMORIAL TO BE
BUILT THAT COMMEMORATES THAT
HISTORY.
ANY FURTHER FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS,
SENATOR?
OKAY.
UM, I NORMALLY I WOULD SAY I'LL
TAKE THAT AS YOUR CLOSE,
BUT SINCE WE DON'T HAVE AN
AUTHOR HERE,
THERE'S SOMETHING I WANTED TO
SAY TOO,
SO I'LL TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY.
UM, FIRST, I BELIEVE THAT THE
ANALYSIS,
A GREAT ANALYSIS TO THE STAFF,
UH,
ADDRESSES THE THE QUESTION THAT
SENATOR
DAWLEY RAISED ABOUT EMINENT
DOMAIN.
IT WENT ALL THE WAY UP TO THE
SUPREME COURT,
ACCORDING TO THE ANALYSIS,
AND RESOLVED THAT QUESTION.
SO IT WAS SETTLED LAW IN TERMS
OF
HOW THAT WAS HANDLED AND AND IN
A WAY THAT ADVANCED JUSTICE
DEPENDING
ON YOUR POINT OF VIEW.
BUT IT WAS RESOLVED.
UM, SECONDLY, UH, YOU MY GENERAL
VIEW IS,
IS THAT WHILE I DON'T PROFESS
TO HAVE GREAT
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
HERE,
I THINK THAT ANY PLACE WHERE
WE BELIEVE
THERE'S BEEN INJUSTICE IN OUR
HISTORY,
IT'S INCUMBENT UPON US TO OWN
UP TO IT,
ACKNOWLEDGE IT, AND TO GET THE
FACTS.
AND I THINK THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO WITH THE BILL
THAT'S
BEFORE US IS THAT IT DOESN'T
DEFINE A RESULT,
BUT IT DEFINES A PROCESS.
AND I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT THAT,
UH,
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES COULD
HAVE DONE THIS ON THEIR OWN.
AND SO PART OF WHY I'M HESITANT
ON
THE LOCAL CONTROL GUY TO, UH,
UH,
BUT THE THE QUESTION I ALWAYS
SAY IS,
HAVE THEY BEEN GIVEN THE CHANCE?
SO LET'S SEE HOW MANY DECADES
NOW.
OKAY.
SO IT OVERCOMES MY LOCAL CONTROL
ISSUE.
THIS IS LOCAL GOVERNMENT, BUT
THEY'VE
BEEN GIVEN THE CHANCE.
THIS IS A NUDGE.
UM, AND I THINK IT'S A IT'S AN
APPROPRIATE
NUDGE FROM MY POINT OF VIEW.
OF COURSE, THE THING THAT REALLY
GOT ME IN THE ANALYSIS,
IT SAYS MEMBERS OF THE TASK
FORCE ARE NOT ENTITLED
TO COMPENSATION FOR THOSE WHO
ARE HERE.
EARLIER.
YOU WOULD LAUGH AT THAT, BUT IT
WAS A SILLY POINT.
BUT ANYWAY, I'M SUPPORTIVE OF
YOUR BILL.
I WISH YOU WELL.
UH, DO YOU WANT TO CLOSE?
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I VOTE
AND APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION.
GREAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD.
OKAY.
AS A COURTESY.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION THIS WOULD
BE DO PASS TO JUDICIARY OKAY.
TERRIFIC.
AMENDMENTS WERE AGREED TO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THANK YOU.
MOTION IS TO PASS THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
SENATOR.
DURAZO.
CIERTO.
DOLLY.
DOLLY, I.
GLASER.
GLASER I.
SKINNER.
WAHAB.
WIENER.
2 TO 0.
I'LL BE ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON WITH OUR AGENDA.
WE HAVE ANOTHER AUTHOR HERE.
UH, ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON.
HELLO.
IT'S BEEN SO LONG SINCE I'VE
SEEN YOU.
UM, THIS IS FILE ITEM 17 AB
2632.
LITTLE DID YOU KNOW YOU WOULD
SEE ME SO MUCH TODAY.
OH, MY GOSH.
BUT WE'RE THE FUN CHAIR.
WE'RE THE FUN CHAIR, SO DON'T
WORRY.
UH, OKAY.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> WELL, GOOD AFTERNOON, UH,
INTERIM, MR.
CHAIR AND, SENATOR, UM,
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY NOTING
THAT
I AM ACCEPTING THE THREE OUT
OF THE FOUR COMMITTEE AMENDS
AND HAVE COMMITTED TO THE CHAIR
TO CONTINUE WORKING ON
THE REMAINING ISSUES AS IT
RELATES
TO ILLEGAL DUMPING.
I ALSO WANT TO EXPRESS MY
SINCERE THANKS,
UH, TO THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF
FOR THE EXTENSIVE CONVERSATIONS
AND WORKING
WITH ME IN MY OFFICE ON THIS
BILL.
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT AB 2632,
WHICH STRENGTHENS STRENGTHENS
THE SECOND HAND GOODS MARKET
THAT
MANY OF US ARE FAMILIAR WITH,
HAVING SHOPPED IN THRIFT STORES,
AND WILL FURTHER DEVELOP THE
CIRCULAR ECONOMY
FOR USED CLOTHING AND HOME GOODS
IN
ORDER TO REDUCE LANDFILL WASTE.
NOT ONLY WILL THIS BILL HELP
CALIFORNIA REACH
ITS WASTE REDUCTION AND
RECYCLING GOALS,
BUT WILL ALSO ENSURE LOWER
INCOME SHOPPERS
MEET THEIR BASIC NEEDS BY
CREATING
LOCAL PARITY FOR THRIFT STORES
WITH OTHER,
MORE TRADITIONAL RETAIL STORES.
IN 2020, CAL RECYCLE ISSUED A
REPORT
THAT CALIFORNIA PRODUCED 77.4
MILLION TONS OF TRASH AND
RECYCLED ONLY 42% OF IT.
CALIFORNIA HAS A RECYCLING GOAL
OF 75% OF ALL MATERIAL,
AND WE ARE FALLING FAR SHORT OF
OUR 75% RECYCLING
GOAL AND FACE CLEAR EVIDENCE
THAT
AN ECONOMY DRIVEN BY RESOURCE
EXTRACTION
AND SINGLE USE DISPOSABLE
PRODUCTS CONTINUE TO ENDANGER
OUR
PEOPLE AND IMPAIR OUR PLANET.
THIS BILL WILL HELP PROVIDE
CALIFORNIANS
WITH A BETTER ALTERNATIVE TO
THROWING
THEIR CLOTHING AWAY BY PROVIDING
EASIER
ACCESS TO SECONDHAND CLOTHING
STORES.
NOW, CURRENTLY, THERE IS AN
EQUITABLE
PATCHWORK APPROACH THAT OFTEN
TENDS TO FAVOR TRADITIONAL
RETAIL
STORES OVER THRIFT STORES,
SEEMINGLY DUE TO MISCONCEPTIONS
AND ANTIQUATED BELIEFS ABOUT
THRIFT
STORES AND THE SHOPPERS WHO
FREQUENT
THEM WITH LOCAL JURISDICTION,
SOMETIMES USING ZONING AND
ORDINANCES TO EXCLUDE
THRIFT STORES FROM THEIR
SHOPPING DISTRICTS.
AS SOMEONE WHO HAS PERSONALLY
SPENT A LOT OF TIME
IN THRIFT STORES AND GOTTEN MANY
GREAT DEALS,
I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT THE PEOPLE
WHO
SHOP AT THRIFT STORES ARE NO
WORSE
AND NO BETTER THAN PEOPLE WHO
SHOP
AT STORES THAT SELL NEW CLOTHES.
PEOPLE MAY SHOP AT A THRIFT
STORE BECAUSE THEY
DON'T WANT TO PARTICIPATE IN
FAST FASHION,
BECAUSE THEY ARE SEARCHING FOR
A VINTAGE LOOK,
OR BECAUSE THEY WANT THE VALUE
THAT
BUYING USED CLOTHES AFFORDS.
AND I'M SPENDING A LOT OF TIME
TALKING ABOUT CLOTHING,
BUT AS YOU KNOW FROM THRIFT
STORES,
YOU CAN BUY ANYTHING APPLIANCES,
UM, TOYS DOESN'T MATTER.
IN FACT, THE SUCCESS OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL
AND ECONOMIC BENEFITS
OF THE SECONDHAND GOODS MARKET
IS PLAINLY EVIDENT,
AS MANY TRADITIONAL BIG NAME
RETAIL CHAINS THAT
HISTORICALLY HAVE ONLY SOLD NEW
GOODS ARE
BEGINNING TO RESELL THEIR OWN
BRANDS IN SECOND
HAND MARKET AND IN THE SECOND
HAND MARKET,
FURTHER BLURRING THE LINE
BETWEEN
THRIFT STORES AND TRADITIONAL
RESTORES RETAIL STORES AND
UNDERSCORING,
UNDERSCORING THE IMPORTANCE OF
CREATING
PARITY IN HOW WE TREAT THESE
MARKETS.
I'VE BEEN RECENTLY MADE AWARE
OF CONCERNS
FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AS
THE BILL REACHED THE SECOND
HOUSE AFTER
PASSING UNANIMOUSLY IN THE
SENATE,
AND I WILL COMMIT TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THEM TO ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS SHOULD THE BILL
MOVE FORWARD.
TODAY WITH ME TODAY IS CASSY
GILSON
OF ACXIOM ADVISORS TO SPEAK
MORE ON
THE IMPORTANCE OF AB 2632 AND
TO HELP ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYWOMAN, APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTATION.
LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR WITNESSES
REMARKS.
>> THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, CASSIE GILSON
WITH
AXIOM ADVISORS ON BEHALF OF
SAVERS.
VALUE VILLAGE SAVERS OPERATES
THRIFT STORES
IN COMMUNITIES AROUND
CALIFORNIA,
EMPLOYS 1000 OR MORE PEOPLE AND
BENEFITS
MANY MORE WHO SHOP THERE.
FIRST, I DO WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIR
AND MY COLLEAGUES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT
FOR WORKING WITH US.
WE APPROACHED THEM BEFORE WE
EVEN INTRODUCED THE BILL.
UM, I AM A STUDENT OF THIS
COMMITTEE,
SO I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
ORDERING
PRINCIPLE HERE IS THAT,
UM, WE SHOULD THE DEFAULT SHOULD
BE
THE SANCTITY OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
CONTROL.
AND ONLY WHEN THERE'S A
COMPELLING STATE INTEREST
DO WE WANT TO PROVIDE GREATER
DIRECTION.
AND THEN THAT DIRECTION SHOULD
BE VERY CAREFULLY
SCOPED TO BE AS NARROW AS
POSSIBLE.
AND I THINK THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
WE'VE DONE HERE.
THE ONLY THING THIS BILL DOES
IS SAY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
CANNOT BAN THRIFT STORES OR
RETAIL STORES.
IT RESERVES FOR THEM THE RIGHT
TO IMPOSE
WHATEVER OPERATING CONDITIONS
THEY WANT,
WHETHER IT BE TRAFFIC
CONDITIONS, YOU KNOW,
OPERATION OF TRASH COMPACTORS,
THE COLOR YOU CAN PAINT YOUR
STORES
WHEN THEY CAN BE OPERATED,
ALL OF THOSE THINGS,
AS LONG AS THOSE RULES ALSO
APPLY TO REGULAR RETAIL.
SO THE IDEA HERE WAS REALLY
TO ALLOW
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FULL CONTROL
TO
ENSURE THE SAFETY AND AND
POSITIVE
EXPERIENCE OF FOLKS USING THESE
STORES AND GET RID OF WHAT I
THINK
IS REALLY A LEGACY ISSUE AND
AN OUTDATED VIEW OF WHO SHOPS
AND WHO DONATES TO THESE
FACILITIES.
SO I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
AND HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN.
ANY QUESTIONS?
TERRIFIC.
WE'RE GOING TO OPEN IT UP TO
OTHER METOOS
IN FAVOR OF THIS LEGISLATION.
COME ON UP TO THE MICROPHONE.
MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
RAND MARTIN, ON BEHALF OF
THE AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION,
WHICH OPERATES TEN THRIFT STORES
ACROSS THE STATE
TO HELP SUBSIDIZE CARE TO TO
PEOPLE
WITH HIV IN CALIFORNIA
AND VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
ANYBODY ELSE HERE IN SUPPORT?
OKAY.
WE'LL GO TO OPPOSITION.
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION WANT
TO COME
FORWARD TO PROVIDE PRIMARY
TESTIMONY?
COME ON UP.
I THINK THE RULE HAS BEEN TWO
PEOPLE UP TO FIVE MINUTES.
IS THAT THE BETWEEN BETWEEN BOTH
OF YOU?
HOPEFULLY YOU WORKED IT OUT.
>> WELL, I ASSURE YOU IT WILL
NOT BE FIVE MINUTES.
OKAY.
UH, TRACY RYAN WITH THE RURAL
COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA.
UNFORTUNATELY, WE STILL DO HAVE
AN OPPOSING,
LESS AMENDED POSITION ON THE
BILL.
UM, I DO WANT TO SAY A GENUINE
THANKS
TO THE MEMBER IN PARTICULAR,
FOR HAVING A GOOD CONVERSATION
WITH
US AND HER STAFF AND THE
SPONSORS,
WORKING WITH US FOR THE LAST
FIVE MONTHS
TO TRY TO WORK OUT THIS BILL.
UM, THE AMENDMENTS IN THE
ANALYSIS DOES TAKE
A GIANT STEP IN HELPING ADDRESS
OUR ISSUES.
WE CONTINUE TO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS,
ESPECIALLY WITH BIGGER, UM,
THRIFT STORES AND THE IMPACTS
OF THOSE
IN THE DONATION FACILITIES.
AND SO WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITMENT OF, UH,
OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO HELP
WORK ON THAT OVER THE SUMMER.
AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN FIND A
COMPROMISE
THAT WORKS FOR EVERYBODY.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR MEMBERS
BRADY GIRTON ON
BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES,
ECHOING THE CONCERNS THAT OUR
CRC HAD.
AND AGAIN, THANKS TO THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AND THE SPONSORS ON THIS,
WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH THEM.
LOOK FORWARD TO THOSE CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS,
AND LOOK TO FIND THOSE COMMON
GROUND OVER THE RECESS,
AND APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THAT
EVERYONE'S DONE ON THIS,
AND LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THOSE
CONVERSATIONS IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD.
ALL RIGHT.
ANYBODY ELSE WHO IS IN
OPPOSITION
FOR A ME TO COME ON UP?
>> MARC NEWBURGER, CALIFORNIA
STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR OF
THE SPONSOR
AND THE COMMITTEE FOR THE WORK
ON THIS BILL,
AND ASSOCIATE ALL MY COMMENTS
WITH
THOSE MADE BY RCA AND CAL
CITIES.
THE RECORD WILL REFLECT, WILL
REFLECT.
OKAY.
ANYBODY ELSE?
SEEING NONE, WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS.
MEMBERS.
THAT'S.
ALL RIGHT.
I WILL JUST SAY, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER,
YOU'VE COME FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
YOUR SENSITIVITY, I KNOW, IS
THERE.
YOUR WITNESS IDENTIFIED MY
PHILOSOPHICAL THINKING.
EXACTLY.
UM, AND I THINK UNDER THOSE
TERMS,
I THINK THE BILL IS A REASONABLE
STEP FORWARD.
I HAVE HEARD BACK FROM MY
COMMUNITY
THAT HAVE RAISED SOME CONCERNS.
I THINK YOU REALLY DO ADDRESS
THEM WITH YOUR
BILL AND THE AMENDMENTS THAT YOU
HAVE TAKEN.
I KNOW THE ONE THAT YOU ARE NOT
ACCEPTING AT
THE MOMENT REGARDING DONATIONS
FROM INDIVIDUALS
AT LARGER LOCATIONS IS STILL
A MATTER OF
DISCUSSION WITH THE CHAIR AND
OTHERS,
AND I KNOW THAT YOU WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THAT GOING FORWARD AND HAPPY TO
SUPPORT IT.
AND I UNDERSTAND THE CHAIR
SUPPORTS IT.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, THE REAL CHAIR
ALL RIGHT.
ANYTHING ELSE FURTHER FROM
COLLEAGUES?
SAY AGAIN SIR.
UH, YOU WOULD BE THE ARTIFICIAL
VICE CHAIR
WITH WITH SEASONING AND VICE
CHAIR.
UH, NO.
DIES.
OKAY.
UH, ASSEMBLYWOMAN, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE?
YES.
THANK YOU.
UM, THIS BILL WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA REACH
ITS WASTE REDUCTION AND
RECYCLING
GOALS AND WILL HELP SHOPPERS
MEET
THEIR BASIC NEEDS BY PROHIBITING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FROM ENACTING
OR
ENFORCING BANS OR LIMITATIONS ON
THRIFT STORES THAT ARE NOT
PLACED ON RETAIL,
OTHER RETAIL STORES.
THAT IS THE INTENT AND HAPPY
THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO ACCOMPLISH THAT WITH THE
AMENDMENT SO FAR.
WITH THAT, I THANK YOU ALL AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE.
OKAY.
THIS IS A, UH, SHE ACCEPTED
THREE
OF THE FOUR AMENDMENTS.
AS WE INDICATED, IT'S DO PASS,
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
UH MOTION FORMERLY MADE BY, AH,
THE GOOD SENATOR FROM BEAVER,
SENATOR DOLLY.
UM, SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATORS.
DURAZZO.
SATO.
I.
DOLLY.
DOLLY I.
GLASER.
GLASER I.
SKINNER.
WAHAB.
WIENER.
3 TO 0.
OKAY.
CONGRATULATIONS ON THAT.
THAT'S ALMOST A GRAND SLAM HERE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY.
OKAY, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON.
WE'RE MAKING A LOT OF PROGRESS
HERE.
UH, FILE ITEM 15, ASSEMBLY BILL
2457 BY
OUR GOOD ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
MCCARTY.
YES, SIR.
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE.
BEEN EAGERLY AWAITING YOUR
PRESENTATION TODAY.
AND THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
YES.
THANK YOU.
>> UH, COMMITTEE, UM, I PRESENT
TO YOU A DISTRICT BILL.
UH, THIS IS RELATED TO OUR
UTILITY DISTRICT.
SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE FAMILIAR
WITH.
SENATOR, THIS IS THE SACRAMENTO
MUNICIPAL UTILITY DISTRICT.
SMUD, OUR PUBLIC POWER DISTRICT.
THIS BILL SIMPLY EXTENDS A
SUNSET ON A STATUTE
BILL THAT I CREATED FIVE YEARS
AGO,
ALLOWING SMUD TO ENTER INTO
FINANCIAL PARTNERSHIPS.
UM, THE THE PRIOR BILL LIMITS
THESE
FINANCIAL PARTNERSHIPS WITH UM,
ENERGY AND CLIMATE TYPE PROJECTS
HERE AT A TOTAL OF SIX.
UH THIS BILL WOULD CERTAINLY
ALLOW THAT TO CONTINUE.
THESE ARE NON STOCK OPTIONS.
SO THIS ALLOWS OUR PUBLIC POWER
ENTITY TO
KEEP TO KEEP OUR ENERGY AND
OUR POWER
ON LIKE HOT DAYS LIKE TODAY UH
PUSHING ON
OUR EFFORTS TO FOCUS ON CLEAN
ENERGY,
UH, WORK ON SOLAR AND STORAGE
AND STARTUP COMPANIES
THROUGHOUT THE SACRAMENTO SMUD
AREA.
AND WITH ME TODAY IS A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM SMUD.
AND AGAIN, DISTRICT BILL EXTENDS
THE SUNSET
OF PRIOR LAW THAT'S BEEN
SUCCESSFUL.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
AND YOU HAVE A DISTINGUISHED
WITNESS HERE ON
YOUR BEHALF THAT YOU WANT TO
INTRODUCE.
>> SCOTT MARTIN CHIEF FINANCIAL
OFFICER SMUD TERRIFIC.
DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING YOU WANT
TO ADD
TO THIS OR JUST THERE FOR
TECHNICAL.
HAVE A BRIEF STATEMENT I'D LIKE.
TO OKAY.
VERY GOOD SIR.
AS THE SIXTH LARGEST COMMUNITY
OWNED
ELECTRIC UTILITY IN THE NATION.
WE SERVE ABOUT 1.5 MILLION
RESIDENTS
IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY
AND A SMALL ADJOINING PORTIONS
OF PLACER AND YOLO COUNTY.
AS A PUBLIC UTILITY, EVERY
DOLLAR IN
REVENUE THAT WE GENERATE IS
INVESTED
IN THE COMMUNITY AND USED TO
OFFSET
ANY FUTURE RATE INCREASES.
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE ON AB 2457,
A BILL THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO
CONTINUE THE AUTHORITY
TO HOLD NON-STOCK SECURITY IN
A CORPORATION.
THIS AUTHORITY IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE
IT ALLOWS US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REALIZE A RETURN ON THE PRODUCTS
AND SERVICES THAT WE HELP
DEVELOP,
WHICH WILL HELP KEEP OUR RATES
AFFORDABLE FOR OUR CUSTOMERS.
IMPORTANTLY, SMUD DOES NOT PAY
ANYTHING IN THESE DEALS BEYOND
WHAT WE WOULD NORMALLY PAY TO
PROCURE
THE PRODUCT OR SERVICE.
THERE IS NO FINANCIAL RISK FOR
SMUD CUSTOMERS.
WE OFTEN PARTNER WITH COMPANIES
TO DEVELOP INNOVATIVE PRODUCTS
AND SERVICES THAT ENABLE US TO
ACHIEVE
THE STATE'S CLEAN ENERGY GOALS,
MAINTAIN AFFORDABILITY AND
RELIABILITY
FOR OUR CUSTOMERS,
FOR SOME OF THESE PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES,
SMUD PROVIDES ACCESS TO OUR
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY.
WE DEVOTE OUR STAFF TIME AND
PROVIDE CRITICAL
FIELD TESTING TO ENSURE THEIR
EFFECTIVENESS.
THE COMPANIES THAT WE PARTNER
WITH MAY
THEN CAPITALIZE ON OUR
CONTRIBUTIONS
BY MARKETING THOSE PRODUCTS
AND SERVICES TO OTHER UTILITIES.
WE EXERCISED OUR AUTHORITY UNDER
AB
689 TO ENTER INTO A PARTNERSHIP
WITH A COMPANY THAT IS
DEVELOPING LONG DURATION
ENERGY STORAGE THAT WILL BE
ESSENTIAL
FOR US TO HELP MEET
OUR CARBON REDUCTION GOALS
AND THE GOALS OF THE STATE.
UM, TO MEET OUR CARBON REDUCTION
GOALS,
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
DEVELOP THESE
INNOVATIVE PARTNERSHIPS
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
WE CONTINUE WITH THIS AUTHORITY.
THIS AUTHORITY SIMPLY ALLOWS OUR
CUSTOMERS TO REAP THE POTENTIAL
FINANCIAL UPSIDE OF THE
PARTNERSHIPS
SHOULD THE COMPANY SUCCEED.
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU.
TERRIFIC.
WE'LL GIVE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
OTHER ME
TO SUPPORT TO COME TO THE
MICROPHONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS MARCUS DETWEILER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
ERIC DOLPHY, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
>> THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
ABED FRANKEL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, MCKINLEY
THOMPSON MORLEY,
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
>> CHRIS LEE ON BEHALF OF THE
SACRAMENTO AREA
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS IN
SUPPORT.
TERRIFIC.
OKAY.
WE'RE GOING TO FINISH THE PUBLIC
SIDE
OF THE SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO OPPOSITION.
ANYBODY HERE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL?
ANYBODY HERE IN OPPOSITION?
SEEING NONE, WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
MEMBERS.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS?
SEEING NONE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THIS LOOKS LIKE A GOOD BILL.
I UNDERSTAND THE CHAIR MOST
IMPORTANTLY LIKES IT.
I LIKE IT TOO.
ANYTHING YOU WANT TO SAY IN
CLOSING?
HA!
IS THAT A RESPECTFUL, I VOTE
KIND OF THING FOR GOOD?
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR A MOTION FROM
A COLLEAGUE.
ANYBODY WANT TO DO THAT NOW?
OR WE CAN WAIT TILL OUR FULL
COMMITTEE IS HERE.
WE'LL WAIT.
NO WORRIES.
ALL RIGHT.
IT'S A COURTESY MOTION.
I WON'T SAY BY WHO, BUT BY A
MEMBER OF THE SENATE.
THIS IS DO PASS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR.
WITH ENTHUSIASM.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS.
DURAZZO.
SARTO.
CIERTO.
I, DOLLY.
DOLLY I.
GLASER, I GLASER, I.
SKINNER.
WAHAB.
WEINER.
3 TO 0.
ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GOING TO PUT THAT ON CALL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
DO YOU HAVE ANY SET COUNTY
ANY MORE IN YOUR DISTRICT?
THANK YOU.
DO YOU HAVE SMUD.
UH.
AND YOU PAY SMART.
HEY, IT'S BETTER THAN PGA.
JUST SAYING.
HEY, THAT'S SUCH A.
THAT'S A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR I SAW
SENATOR DASCHLE IS JUMPING UP
AND DOWN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM THREE, AB 453,
FILE ITEM EIGHT, AB 2962,
FILE ITEM 13 AB 2430, FILE ITEM
14,
AB 2455 AND FILE ITEM 18 AB
2663.
AND FINALLY AB FILE ITEM 23
AB 3116.
THAT MOTION IS DUE PASS TO
WHEREVER
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO GO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS ADOPT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SENATORS.
DURAZZO.
SATO.
AYE.
DOLLY.
DOLLY I.
GLASER.
GLASER I.
SKINNER.
WAHAB.
WIENER.
3 TO 0.
WE'RE GOING TO PUT THAT ON CALL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
SO WE'RE LOOKING FOR AUTHORS.
UH, WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A SHORT
RECESS
WHILE WE WAIT FOR AUTHORS.
OKAY.
WE HAVE AN AUTHOR IN THE IN THE
IN THE HOUSE.
THIS IS, UH, THIS IS FILE ITEM
16,
ASSEMBLY BILL 2488 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING.
SIR.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
>> THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
SO, UH, 24, 88 IS A BILL THAT
WILL ALLOW SAN FRANCISCO
TO CREATE A DOWNTOWN
REVITALIZATION
DISTRICT TO HELP FINANCE THE
CONVERSION
OF EMPTY OFFICE BUILDINGS INTO
HOUSING.
UH, THE I WANT TO START OFF BY
ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
DUE TO THE LEGISLATIVE
DEADLINES,
WE WERE NOT ABLE TO INCORPORATE
ALL OF THE AMENDMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE IN TIME FOR
SENATE
HOUSING TO HEAR THE BILL NEXT
WEEK.
I'VE AGREED TO TAKE THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS
AND REDUCE THE SQUARE FOOTAGE,
EXEMPT FROM AFFORDABILITY
REQUIREMENTS,
FROM 3,000,000FT² TO ONE POINT
5,000,000FT²
IN SENATE HOUSING.
I'M ALSO COMMITTING TO NOT TAKE
UP THE BILL UPON THE UP
ON THE FLOOR UNTIL THE LABOR
LANGUAGE IS SORTED OUT,
IN CONSULTATION WITH ALL THE
COMMITTEES
THAT HAVE JURISDICTION ON THIS
BILL.
UM, THIS BILL IS SIMPLE.
IT'S A SAN FRANCISCO BILL.
WE ARE TRYING TO CREATE A
DOWNTOWN
REVITALIZATION DISTRICT.
THIS DISTRICT WOULD BE CREATED
BY OUR
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND OUR
MAYOR.
UH, WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IS ONCE
THE VALUES IN THAT AREA WERE
SET,
THE ADDITIONAL TAX INCREMENTS
WITH THE ADDITIONAL
PROPERTY TAXES THAT CAME AS THAT
ISSUE,
AS THAT COMMUNITY GOT BETTER,
UH,
WOULD BE SET ASIDE INTO THIS
DISTRICT WILL
BE USED TO INCENTIVIZE THE
CONVERSION
OF OFFICE BUILDINGS INTO
HOUSING.
WE BELIEVE THAT MANY OF THE
NEWER OFFICE
BUILDINGS REALLY WOULDN'T
CONVERT.
IT WOULD REALLY BE A WAY TO
INCENTIVIZE
SOME OF THE OLDER OFFICE
BUILDINGS,
BECAUSE THE NEW OFFICE
LIKE IF YOU SEE THE TRANSAMERICA
BUILDING OR BANK
OF AMERICA BUILDING WITH THE
LARGE FLOOR PLATES,
THE PLUMBING, THE ELECTRICITY
JUST WOULDN'T
WORK TO CONVERT INTO HOUSING
THE MANY OF THE OLDER ONES THAT
ARE ALREADY SECTIONED OFF,
THEY HAVE MORE PLUMBING, MORE
ELECTRICITY.
IT'S A LITTLE BIT EASIER TO
GET, UM,
INFRASTRUCTURE INTO THOSE
BUILDINGS.
WE THINK THOSE WOULD BE
POTENTIAL TARGETS.
SO IF YOU THINK ABOUT LIKE A
CLASS B,
CLASS C KIND OF BUILDING, THAT
IS IT.
UM, WE ALSO, UH, THIS IS NOT
JUST ABOUT BUILDING HOUSING.
THIS IS REALLY ABOUT TRYING TO
GET MORE
PEOPLE INTO DOWNTOWN SAN
FRANCISCO.
RIGHT NOW, OUR BUSINESSES ARE
SUFFERING,
RESTAURANTS HAVE CLOSED,
SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE CLOSED
BECAUSE
THE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE THAT
WERE GOING INTO DOWNTOWN SAN
FRANCISCO
EVERY DAY FOR WORK ARE NOT
THERE.
AND SO ALL THOSE LUNCHES, ALL
THOSE COFFEES,
ALL THOSE, YOU KNOW,
WHETHER IT'S DRY CLEANERS OR
PHARMACIES,
THOSE BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN PUT
OUT OF BUSINESS.
SO WE'RE TRYING TO GET MORE
PEOPLE THERE SO
WE CAN REVITALIZE THAT
PARTICULAR AREA.
AND AGAIN, THIS IS JUST FOR SAN
FRANCISCO ONLY.
I DO HAVE LUIS MORANTE FROM
BAY AREA
COUNCIL TO TESTIFY AS MY
WITNESS.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
YOU MAY BEGIN.
>> THANK YOU.
MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS LUIS MORANTE.
I REPRESENT THE BAY AREA COUNCIL
ON HOUSING ISSUES
AND PROUD TO BE HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF 2488.
THE BAY AREA COUNCIL REPRESENTS
SOME OF THE MOST, UH,
SOME OF THE LARGEST EMPLOYERS
IN SAN FRANCISCO.
I'M SORRY.
I WAS PROUD TO WORK WITH A LARGE
GROUP OF THEM
IN COMING UP WITH THIS CREATIVE
IDEA.
UM, WE'RE REALLY EXCITED TO HAVE
WORKED WITH THE CITY ON THIS.
WE'RE EXCITED THAT THEY'RE
EXCITED ABOUT THIS TOOL,
AND IT RESPONDS TO A REALLY
PRESSING PROBLEM THAT A MAJOR
EMPLOYERS
ARE FACING IN THE BAY AREA.
DOWNTOWN SAN FRANCISCO HAS ABOUT
100,000,000FT²
OF OFFICE SPACE.
ABOUT 40,000,000FT² RIGHT NOW
IS VACANT
IN DOWNTOWN SAN FRANCISCO.
THAT MEANS THERE JUST ISN'T THE
FOOT TRAFFIC
TO SUSTAIN THOSE SMALL
BUSINESSES,
THOSE DRY CLEANERS, THOSE
RESTAURANTS.
THAT'S A HUGE ISSUE, BOTH FOR
THE STATE,
FOR THE REGION,
AND FOR THE CITY'S PUBLIC
PERCEPTION
AND FOR OUR COMPETITIVENESS AS
A REGION.
THE GOAL HERE IS DOWNTOWN
REVITALIZATION.
THE STRATEGY IS HOUSING.
THIS IS THIS IS A HOUSING BILL.
IT'S ABOUT INVESTING IN HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION.
BUT THE GOAL HERE IS REALLY TO
REACTIVATE
DOWNTOWN SAN FRANCISCO.
SO TO SO THAT IT'S THE REGIONAL
CENTER
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA FOR
EMPLOYERS,
FOR PEOPLE WHO WANT TO LIVE
THERE FOR,
FOR, FOR, FOR FOR PEOPLE WHO
REMEMBER
WHAT SAN FRANCISCO USED TO BE
LIKE.
WE'RE TRYING TO SHOOT FOR, FOR,
FOR FOR THAT GOAL.
UM, JUST WANTED TO THANK AGAIN
THE CITY AND THEIR
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US ON THE
AMENDMENTS HERE,
FOR YOUR STAFF, FOR WORKING US
ON WITH US ON THE AMENDMENTS.
UH, OUR MEMBERS ARE REALLY
EXCITED
ABOUT THIS BILL AND,
AND ARE READY TO GET TO WORK
ONCE THE CITY OPTS INTO IT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD.
ALL RIGHT.
ANYBODY ELSE WHO WANTS TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT?
COME ON UP TO THE MICROPHONE
FOR ME TO.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS.
KAREN LANG, ON BEHALF OF MAYOR
LONDON BREED,
THE MAYOR OF SAN FRANCISCO, VERY
GRATEFUL FOR MR.
TING'S LEADERSHIP AND MOVING THE
BILL FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR
WORKING THROUGH IT AND KEEPING
US GOING.
SHE NEEDS EVERY TOOL.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND ASK
FOR AN I VOTE.
THANK YOU.
CATHERINE CHARLES ON BEHALF OF
THE HOUSING
ACTION COALITION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
>> HOLLY, FOR MEETING WITH THE
WHITE HOUSE PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF SPUR AND
SUPPORT.
TERRIFIC.
SEE NO ONE ELSE HERE IN SUPPORT.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE IN
OPPOSITION.
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION?
PLEASE COME ON UP.
THE TABLE OR THE MICROPHONE.
YOUR CHOICE.
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
JEREMY SMITH, ON BEHALF OF THE.
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL.
UM, YOU KNOW, AS WE'VE BEEN OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS IN THIS COMMITTEE AND
OTHER COMMITTEES,
WE'RE HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
WORKERS WHO ARE
GOING TO BE PERFORMING THESE
CONVERSIONS.
UH, WE ARE SENSITIVE, UH,
TO WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE CITY
OF SAN FRANCISCO.
UH, WE APPRECIATE, UH,
ENGAGING WITH THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER,
I BELIEVE, BACK IN MARCH ON
THIS BILL.
AND CONVERSATIONS HAVE
CONTINUED,
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO THOSE
MOVING FORWARD.
UM, AND, YOU KNOW,
ARE HAPPY THAT THEY ARE
CONTINUING
AND THINK THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO BE FRUITFUL ULTIMATELY.
SO WE'RE HERE AS A TWEENER.
I DON'T WANT TO SAY WE'RE
OPPOSED,
BUT WE'RE CERTAINLY
WATCHING THIS AND HAVE SOME
CONCERNS.
AND THOSE ARE AROUND THE LABOR
PROVISIONS THAT
HOPEFULLY WILL GO INTO THIS BILL
EVENTUALLY.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO THOSE, UH,
THOSE CONCLUDING THOSE
DISCUSSIONS,
INCLUDING IN A POSITIVE MANNER.
THANK YOU.
TERRIFIC.
ANYBODY ELSE HERE IN OPPOSITION
OR ANY TWEENERS.
ALL RIGHT.
SEEING NONE, WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR CONVERSATION,
DEBATE, DISCUSSION QUESTIONS.
ANY QUESTIONS?
OKAY.
UH, SENATOR TING, LET ME JUST
SAY THANK YOU TO YOUR STAFF.
I HAD A LOT OF QUESTIONS.
THEY WERE GREAT IN ANSWERING
THEM.
UH, IT MAKES ME VERY COMFORTABLE
IN SUPPORTING THEIR BILL TODAY.
I UNDERSTAND THE CHAIR'S
SUPPORTING
IT WITH THOSE AMENDMENTS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
UH, JUST.
I FORGOT TO THANK THE CHAIR.
FORGOT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF.
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK
THAT THEY'VE PUT IN
WORKING WITH US TO GET THIS BILL
TO THIS PLACE.
UH, WE STILL HAVE MORE WORK TO
GO, BUT RESPECT FOR.
I VOTE ON AB 2488.
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
TERRIFIC.
DO WE SEE IF WE HAVE A MOTION
OR WAIT FOR A FULL COMMITTEE?
I'M NOT GOING TO SUPPORT THE
BILL, BUT OKAY.
A COURTESY MOTION'S BEEN
EXTENDED
BY A COLLEAGUE HERE ON THE DAIS.
UH, IT'S JUST AN EFFICIENT.
IT'S AN EFFICIENCY POINT, I
SUPPOSE.
UNLESS YOU'D LIKE THE
CHAIRMANSHIP
GAVEL BACK AND WE CAN DO.
OKAY, SO THIS IS A DO PASS TO
HOUSING.
THE AMENDMENTS WILL BE
OFFICIALLY TAKEN IN HOUSING,
AS THE AUTHOR HAS SO INDICATED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS.
DURAZO.
CIERTO.
DALI.
GLASER.
GLASER I.
SKINNER.
WAHAB.
WEINER.
ONE.
TWO.
ZERO.
GOT A STRONG START.
UH, WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE THE
ROLL
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU.
SIR.
ALL RIGHT.
LOOKING FOR AUTHORS HERE?
LOOKING FOR AUTHORS.
WE'RE WAITING ON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JOE PATTERSON.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VALENCIA.
TWO AUTHORS WERE LOOKING FOR YOU
GUYS TO COME
ON DOWN SO WE CAN COMPLETE OUR
BUSINESS.
WE'LL TAKE A SHORT RECESS.
YOU BET.
OKAY, WE'RE GOING TO OPEN THE
ROLL ON
TWO ITEMS TO ALLOW MEMBERS TO
ADD ON.
FIRST ONE IS FILE ITEM 611 AB
2387.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 0 WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYES.
SENATOR.
SATO.
SATO I SKINNER.
BOB WEINER 4 TO 0.
BACK ON CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 16 AB 2488.
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING.
CHERNEVO IS 1 TO 0.
NO CURRENT VOTE FOR THE CHAIR.
SENATORS.
DURAZZO.
SATO.
NO.
DOLLY.
SKINNER.
BOB WIENER 101.
THAT'S A CLIFFHANGER.
WE'RE GOING TO PUT THAT BACK
ON CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
WE'LL TAKE ANOTHER SHORT RECESS.
LOOKING FOR AUTHORS.
LOOKING FOR AUTHORS HERE.
JO PATTERSON AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VALENCIA.
AND, UH, LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS
BACK.
BACK IN SESSION.
WE HAVE MEMBERS THAT ARE HERE
AND READY TO GO.
WE HAVE AN AUTHOR IN THE HOUSE.
UM, WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH
YOUR BILL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THIS IS FILED ITEM 22 AB 2946
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VALENCIA.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
>> WONDERFUL.
UH, THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
I WANT TO START THE SENATORS.
I'D LIKE TO START BY THANKING
THE COMMITTEE
TEAM FOR DILIGENTLY WORKING ON
AB 2946.
I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TODAY TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CONCERNS VOICED BY
THE COUNTY OF ORANGE.
AB 2946 WILL ESTABLISH
GUIDELINES
AND CRITERIA FOR APPROPRIATING
DISTRICT DISCRETIONARY FUNDS IN
ORANGE COUNTY.
THE AMENDMENTS CLARIFY THAT THE
COUNTY OF
ORANGE AND ITS SUPERVISORS ARE
PROHIBITED
FROM TAKING SPECIFIED ACTIONS
WITHIN
90 DAYS PRECEDING AN ELECTION.
THE PROHIBITION DOES NOT APPLY
TO ANY PROJECTS THAT
RECEIVED FUNDS PRIOR TO THE 90
DAY PERIOD,
AND HAVE BEEN COMPLETED WITHIN
A 90 DAY PERIOD.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO EMPHASIZE
THAT
THIS BILL WILL NOT PRECLUDE
THE COUNTY FROM ALLOCATING FUNDS
TO ENTITIES LIKE NONPROFITS.
THE GOAL OF THIS BILL IS TO
PREVENT
THE MISUSE OF DISCRETIONARY
FUNDS.
DURING THE COVID 19 PANDEMIC,
A NONPROFIT IN ORANGE COUNTY
RECEIVED MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN DISCRETIONARY FUNDS
FOR THE PURPOSES
OF DELIVERING MEALS TO SENIORS.
THE NONPROFIT WAS UNABLE TO
PROVIDE
DOCUMENTATION TO THE COUNTY THAT
DEMONSTRATED THAT THE MONEY WAS
USED IN AN APPROPRIATE MANNER.
FURTHERMORE, IT WAS REVEALED
THAT
THE NONPROFIT WAS ALLEGEDLY
LED BY ORANGE COUNTY SUPERVISOR
FAMILY MEMBER.
THIS EXAMPLE HIGHLIGHTS
THE NEED FOR MORE OVERSIGHT OF
THE COUNTY'S APPROPRIATIONS OF
DISCRETIONARY FUNDS.
WITH ME TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS
IS OUR LEDGE AIDE, KATIE
GUTHRIE.
TERRIFIC.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
SO FOR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS, WE
HAVE YOUR AIDE HERE.
ANYBODY HERE IN SUPPORT THAT
WANT TO COME UP
TO THE MICROPHONE TO ADD ON IN
SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT.
SEEING NONE ANYBODY HERE IN
OPPOSITION THAT WANTS
TO COME TO THE MICROPHONE OR THE
DESK UP FRONT.
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
>> THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
AMY JENKINS, ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS,
IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL,
I'D FIRST LIKE TO ADDRESS THE
CONFLICT
OF INTEREST CONTROVERSIES
HIGHLIGHTED ON PAGE ONE OF THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
WHILE I AM NOT HERE TO CONDONE
OR DEFEND
THE ACTIONS OF ANY PARTICULAR
SUPERVISOR,
IT IS CRUCIAL TO UNDERSTAND
THAT AB 2946, IF ENACTED,
WOULD NOT PREVENT SUCH
OCCURRENCES
FROM HAPPENING AGAIN.
THERE IS, HOWEVER, ANOTHER BILL
THAT WILL BE PRESENTED
NEXT THAT DOES ADDRESS THAT
PROBLEM.
WHEN THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS MANAGED
THE ALLOCATION OF FEDERAL COVID
19 FUNDING,
IT ESTABLISHED A TRANSPARENT
AUTHORIZATION
PROCESS WHERE THEY APPROVED THE
ALLOCATION
OF DISCRETIONARY FUNDS BASED
ON BOARD
APPROVED FUNDING CATEGORIES.
BOARD ACTIONS, ALONG WITH THE
PRIORITIES
AND PROJECTS AWARDED
FUNDS ARE PUBLICLY POSTED ON THE
COUNTY'S WEBSITE.
UNDER TRANSPARENCY REPORTS,
DISTRICT DISCRETIONARY
PRIORITIES PROJECT PROGRAM.
THE ACCESSIBLE WEBSITE LISTS ALL
PROJECT AWARDS,
THE DATES OF BOARD ACTIONS,
CORRESPONDING AGENDA STAFF
REPORTS,
AND A BREAKDOWN OF EACH
SUPERVISOR'S DISCRETIONARY
PRIORITIES BY DISTRICT.
THE PROCESS EXEMPLIFIED THE
HIGHEST
STANDARDS OF TRANSPARENCY
AND ENSURED CRITICAL FUNDING FOR
ESSENTIAL NONPROFIT PROGRAMS,
INCLUDING SUPPORTING VETERANS
WHO
ARE HOMELESSNESS, YOUTH
PROGRAMS,
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE,
FOOD ASSISTANCE,
AUTISM SUPPORT, ETC..
POLICIES THAT GUARANTEE
TRANSPARENCY
AND DISCLOSURE OF
PUBLIC FUND EXPENDITURES SHOULD
ALWAYS BE UPHELD.
HOWEVER, AB 2946 DOES NOT
ADDRESS
THE UNDERLYING PROBLEM.
INSTEAD, IT ENSHRINES A PROCESS
FOR AWARDING DISCRETIONARY
FUNDS SPECIFICALLY TO ONE
COUNTY,
WHICH IS BOTH UNNECESSARY AND
INEQUITABLE.
MOREOVER, WHILE WE ACKNOWLEDGE
AND APPRECIATE THE CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS TAKEN TODAY REGARDING
THE 90 DAY BLACKOUT PERIOD,
THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD'S
ABILITY TO AWARD
DISCRETIONARY FUNDS FOR
ESSENTIAL
DISTRICT PROJECTS IS SHOULD BE
PROVIDED
TO EVERYBODY WITHOUT THE 90 DAY.
OTHERWISE, IT EFFECTIVELY
DISENFRANCHISES
CERTAIN VOTERS IN THE DISTRICT.
SO FOR THESE REASONS, THE ORANGE
COUNTY BOARD RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSES THIS BILL AND URGES YOUR
YOUR NO VOTE.
EXCUSE ME.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MR.
JENKINS.
ANYBODY ELSE HERE IN OPPOSITION
WANT TO
COME TO THE MICROPHONE TO
INDICATE SO?
ALL RIGHT.
SEEING NONE, WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
ANY SENATOR HAS A QUESTION OR
A COMMENT.
SO AT RISK OF, UM, SENATOR
DOLLY.
THANK YOU.
SO DO THEY NOT HAVE TO COME BACK
TO THE BOARD?
SO I WOULD SIT ON BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS FOR 16 YEARS,
AND WE HAD A EACH SUPERVISOR WAS
ALLOCATED A $5,000
IS VERY SMALL AMOUNT OBVIOUSLY
IN THE COUNTY I'M FROM
TO BUT WE HAD TO WE HAD TO RUN
IT THROUGH THE BOARD,
MAKE A MOTION, HAD TO MAKE SURE
IT WAS NOT
A GIFT OF PUBLIC FUNDS, ALL
THOSE THINGS.
AND CAN YOU MAYBE GIVE ME
A LITTLE BACKGROUND ON WHAT?
WHAT THEY'RE DOING, HOW THEY'RE
DOING IT.
THEY'RE NOT DOING IT.
MAYBE SO THE ALLOCATION AMOUNT
IS VOTED ON BY THE BOARD.
HOWEVER, THEN THE SUPERVISOR
HAS THE ABILITY TO ALLOCATE
THE RESOURCES FROM THAT DIRECT
ACCOUNT,
WHICH I THINK IS THE ISSUE.
OKAY.
SO BUT AT RIGHT, THAT'S THE SAME
THING WE DID.
WE GOT A BLOCK AMOUNT.
THAT WAS ALL YOU COULD GET.
BUT THEN IF YOU TOOK $1,000
OF IT AND YOU GAVE IT TO THE
VETERANS, WHATEVER,
UM, YOU HAD TO COME BACK AND
GET A MOTION
AND THEN THEN THE MONEY, THE.
NO, THIS THEY DON'T HAVE TO
DO THAT.
SO THIS AND IN ADDITION TO THAT,
IT'S NOT THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS.
IT'S MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
RIGHT.
OH YEAH.
THAT'S INTERESTING.
SO.
THIS BILL WILL FORCE THEM TO
HAVE TO COME BACK AND MAKE
A MOTION TO DAYLIGHT WHERE THE
MONEY GOES SIMPLY.
WHAT I'M ASKING FOR EXACTLY IS
A MAJORITY
OF THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS TO
ALLOCATE THOSE RESOURCES TO
WHATEVER
NONPROFIT THEY THEY SO CHOOSE,
AS OPPOSED TO HAVING SOLE
PROPRIETY
OVER WHAT THOSE DOLLARS SHOULD
DO.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S HOW
DEMOCRACY WORKS.
ALL RIGHT.
ANYTHING FURTHER, SENATOR DOLLY?
YOU'RE GOOD.
OKAY, SENATOR.
OKAY.
WELL, SO WE'VE COMPLETED THE
DISCUSSION
AMONG OUR COLLEAGUES.
I WOULD SAY THAT THIS IS A VERY
REASONABLE BILL TO ME.
I THINK THE CHAIR, MORE
IMPORTANTLY, SUPPORTS IT.
AND, UH, I WOULD WELCOME YOUR
CLOTHES IF YOU HAVE ONE.
I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A YES VOTE.
OKAY.
UH, ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
IS THERE A MOTION OR WILL WAIT
FOR.
ALL RIGHT.
WE HAVE A COURTESY MOTION.
UH, DO PASS.
NOT A COURTESY.
UH, A FIRMLY HELD MOTION BY
SENATOR DOLLY DO PASS,
AS AMENDED TO THE FLOOR.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS DURAZZO.
CIERTO.
NO.
DOLLY.
DOLLY I GLASER.
GLASER.
I SKINNER.
WAHAB.
WIENER 2 TO 1.
ALL RIGHT.
THAT WILL BE ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
I UNDERSTAND, ASSEMBLYMAN,
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO PRESENT
ANOTHER BILL.
UH, ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA.
IF I'VE DONE THAT CORRECTLY,
THIS IS FILE ITEM 24.
FOR ALL THOSE FOLLOWING AT HOME.
THIS IS FILED ITEM 24,
ASSEMBLY BILL 3130 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA PRESENTED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VALENCIA.
SIR, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN.
YES.
PRESENTING AB 3130.
ON BEHALF OF MY GOOD FRIEND
AND FELLOW ORANGE COUNTY
COLLEAGUE,
UH SHARON QUIRK-SILVA,
UH AB 3130 PROMOTES TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY
BY REQUIRING THAT THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS
DISCLOSES A KNOWN FAMILY
RELATIONSHIP
BEFORE ALLOCATING
PUBLIC FUNDS TO NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS
BY PREVENTING OFFICIALS FROM
PRIORITIZING
FINANCIAL GAIN OVER THE PUBLIC
GOOD.
CONFLICT OF INTEREST LAWS WILL
HELP ENSURE FAIRNESS
AND ACCOUNTABILITY ACROSS ALL
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT.
AB 3130 IS A GOOD GOVERNMENT
BILL THAT VALUES TRUST,
INTEGRITY AND FAIRNESS IN THE
ALLOCATION
OF PUBLIC FUNDS WHILE PRACTICING
ETHICAL CONDUCT AMONG MEMBERS
OF BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
UH, HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS IF THERE ARE ANY.
>> YOU'RE DONE.
I'M DONE.
ANYONE HERE?
ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL?
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
SEEING NONE COME BACK TO OUR
MEMBERS.
ANY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> YOU WILL DO IT WHEN SHE'S
HERE.
YOU ALLOWED HER TO TAKE THE
CHAIR BACK.
THANK YOU.
UH, SENATOR SOLDADO.
UM, WE'LL NOW DO ROLL CALL.
OH YOU DID.
CLOSING.
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA,
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A YES
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR.
SENATORS DURAZZO I.
DURAZZO I.
SATO.
SATO I.
DOLLY.
DOLLY I.
GLASER.
GLASER, I.
SKINNER.
WAHAB.
WIENER FOR TWO ZERO.
THANK YOU.
THE SONG CALLED.
OH, THE BILL REMAINS ON CALL.
KNOW WHO'S NEXT.
>> UH, NOT THE COMMITTEE ONES.
NO.
I REMEMBER PATTERSON, UH,
PRESENTING ITEM 21 AB 2729.
GREAT.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
>> SENATORS, THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT THIS MEASURE.
FIRST OF ALL, I REALLY WANT TO
SINCERELY THANK YOU, CHAIR,
AND FOR DISCUSSING THIS MEASURE
WITH
ME AND ALSO THE COMMITTEE STAFF.
I THINK WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
BACK
AND FORTH ON THIS OVER SEVERAL
WEEKS,
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
SINCERE
EFFORT TO GET THIS RIGHT.
UM, AS YOU KNOW, THIS BILL
EFFECTIVELY DELAYS
THE PAYMENT OF IMPACT FEES FROM
BUILDING PERMITS,
THE CERTIFICATE OF OCCUPANCY.
IN ABSOLUTELY NO WAY DOES IT
STOP
THE PAYMENT OF FEES FROM
OCCURRING.
THE FEES WILL GET PAID.
WHY IS THIS NECESSARY?
BECAUSE AT MANY TIMES,
THESE IMPACT FEES AND CONNECTION
FEES
CAN BE MILLIONS AND MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS ON A PROJECT.
THE CARRYING COSTS ALONE IS COST
PROHIBITIVE.
AS A FORMER MAYOR MYSELF, I SEE
A HOUSING PROJECT
IN MY OWN NEIGHBORHOOD BEING
HELD UP BECAUSE
OF THE SIZE OF SPECIAL DISTRICT
FEES AND THE COSTS
OF CARRYING IT ON A HIGH DENSITY
PROJECT.
ONE FEE ALONE IS OVER $3
MILLION,
BUT I HAVE SEEN TOO MANY TIMES
WHERE THE FEES ARE COLLECTED
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE AND
THE MONEY JUST SITS FOR YEARS,
AND MAYBE EVEN A GENERATION.
FOR EXAMPLE, ON MAJOR HIGHWAY
PROJECTS.
WE'RE TRYING TO BUILD HOUSING IN
THIS STATE AND AS YOU KNOW,
WE ARE IN A DIFFICULT BUDGET
ENVIRONMENT
THAT WILL LIKELY RESULT
IN REDUCED HELP FROM THE STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
THIS BILL IS SIMPLY A TIMING
BILL THAT ENSURES
MONEY GETS THERE AND HELPS WITH
CASH
FLOW TO GET THE PROJECTS OFF
THE GROUND,
INCLUDING IN MY OWN
NEIGHBORHOOD.
IN THE ASSEMBLY, WE TOOK MANY
AMENDMENTS TO ENSURE THAT
IF THERE IS ANY OBLIGATION OR
COST BY A LOCAL GOVERNMENT,
THAT IT CAN BE COLLECTED UPFRONT
AND IN ADVANCE.
THIS INCLUDES PAYMENT OF BONDS,
PROCESSING AND ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS,
AND TO PAY THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT IS
LIKELY TO OCCUR WITHIN TWO
YEARS.
WE'RE ALSO COMMITTED TO ENSURING
SCHOOLS ARE NOT IMPACTED WITH
POTENTIAL FUTURE BOND FUNDING,
AND THE NEED FOR MATCHES.
IMPACT FEES MIGHT VERY WELL BE
THE BRIDGE TO HELP A SCHOOL GET
BUILT,
AND EVERYONE SUPPORTS THIS IDEA.
YOUR COMMITTEE HAS BEEN SO
GRACIOUS
TO OFFER AMENDMENTS
TO ME TO LIMIT THESE DEFERRALS
TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING,
OR SB 35 OR AB 2011 PROJECTS,
I.E.
DENSITY BONUS LAW.
WHILE I WAS ENCOURAGED TO
PRESENT
THE BILL AS IS TODAY,
IT'S BECAUSE SB 35 AND AB 211,
2011, WHICH ARE GREAT BILLS,
ARE NOT TOOLS THAT WILL BE USED
IN MY DISTRICT OR
MANY RURAL COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
SO AS A RESULT OF OUR BACK AND
FORTH,
WE HAVE ABOUT FIVE SETS OF
AMENDMENTS
THAT WE ARE INTERESTED AND
ALWAYS HAPPY
TO MOVE ON ON ANY DISCUSSION,
PERHAPS TAKING THOSE AMENDMENTS
SIMILAR
TO SENATOR WIENER BILL IN TERMS
OF
WHEN THE FEES ARE ACTUALLY PAID
AND WHAT'S EXEMPT AND THINGS
LIKE THAT.
BUT SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE
WERE THINKING ABOUT,
FOR EXAMPLE,
IS THAT WE CAN ONLY APPLY THIS
TO CITIES THAT ARE NOT MEETING
THEIR ANNUAL PERFORMANCE
PROGRESS
REPORTS EVERY YEAR.
AND SO THAT WOULD ACTUALLY
INCENTIVIZE CITIES
TO MEET THEIR HOUSING
OBLIGATIONS.
AND IF THEY DON'T THEN THIS TOOL
WOULD APPLY THEN.
SO WE ARE OPEN TO DISCUSSIONS.
FINALLY, THERE MAY BE CONCERNS
ON WHAT
TYPES OF FEES GET PAID AND WHEN.
AND AGAIN, WE ARE MORE THAN
HAPPY
TO DO AMENDMENTS IN THIS,
CONSISTENT WITH SENATOR WIENER'S
BILLS THAT PASSED OUT.
AND ALSO I HEARD TODAY IN IN
HOUSING
COMMITTEE IN THE ASSEMBLY.
WE ARE, WE ARE HAPPY TO TAKE
DARN NEAR ANY AMENDMENT SO
LONG AS WE CAN HAVE THIS APPLY
TO MARKET RATE HOUSING,
BECAUSE I'M TRYING TO MAKE THIS
IMPACTFUL ON MY DISTRICT
AND OTHER DISTRICTS THAT AREN'T
PART OF THE URBAN CORE.
THIS IS A GOVERNMENT FUNDING
FREE WAY TO HELP
SPUR DEVELOPMENT FEES WILL GET
PAID.
IT DOES NOTHING TO CHANGE ZONING
OR LOCAL CONTROL OF A PROJECT.
WITH THAT, I'M MORE THAN HAPPY
TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS I HAVE WITH ME.
HOLLY FOR MINNIE DEJESUS WITH
SPUR.
MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS, ON BEHALF
OF SPUR,
THAT'S THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA
PLANNING RESEARCH ASSOCIATION.
WE'RE HERE TO URGE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL.
SPUR IS PROUDLY BEEN A SPONSOR,
A CO-SPONSOR AND SUPPORTER
OF NUMEROUS BILLS THAT HAVE
PASSED SINCE
2017 THAT AIM AT ADDRESSING THE
HOUSING CRISIS
THROUGH STREAMLINING LOCAL
PROJECT APPROVALS,
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW AND
INCREASING AFFORDABILITY
STANDARDS OF STATE HOUSING LAWS,
AS WELL AS CREATING MORE
TRANSPARENCY
FOR IMPACT FEES YEAR AFTER YEAR.
UNFORTUNATELY, MANY BILLS HAVE
PASSED IN THAT REGARD,
BUT WE ARE ALL WELL AWARE THAT
THE STATE HAS BEEN UNDER
PRODUCING NEW HOUSING UNITS FOR
NEARLY 20 YEARS,
AND ALL THESE NEW TOOLS WE HAVE
PASSED HAVE BARELY
MADE A DENT IN GETTING ANY MORE
PERMITS APPROVED,
LET ALONE GETTING PROJECTS
ACTUALLY BUILT.
AND INSTEAD, THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY HAS NOW, IN 2014,
2024, WE'VE SURVIVED A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC.
BUT NOW NEW CHALLENGES ARE
FACING
THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
AT LARGE AND ESPECIALLY
RESIDENTIAL CONSTRUCTION.
THE CRISIS HAS NOW BEEN
EXACERBATED
BY AN ECONOMIC CRISIS,
AS THE AUTHOR MENTIONED,
AND THE ANALYSIS STATED THAT
SKYROCKETING INTEREST RATES,
COST OF CONSTRUCTION, EVERYTHING
CONTINUES TO GO UP,
AND NOW DEVELOPERS HAVE TO FIND
NEW WAYS TO TRY TO SAVE MONEY.
AS THE AUTHOR MENTIONED IN THE
AREAS,
THE RURAL AREAS THAT ARE
DISADVANTAGED BY AND NOT BEING
ABLE TO USE SB 35 AND AB 2011,
THESE MARKET RATE DEALS ALSO
THAT TRY TO USE THOSE
PROJECTS AND THOSE TOOLS IN
OTHER AREAS,
THEY ACTUALLY APPLY FOR
SUBSIDIES.
THOSE THOSE PROJECTS, THOUGH,
THEY FEEL AND THEY SOUND LIKE
THEY MIGHT BE SUBSIDY FREE.
THEY'RE NOT.
MANY MARKET RATE DEALS,
ESPECIALLY THE LARGER DEALS,
ACTUALLY HAVE TO APPLY FOR
PROGRAMS
LIKE THE TAX CREDIT PROGRAMS,
LOCAL GRANT PROGRAMS OR THE MHP
PROGRAMS
IN ORDER TO MAKE THOSE PROJECTS
PENCIL AND ACTUALLY FUND THE
AFFORDABLE
UNITS IN THOSE PROJECTS.
OR THEY PARTNER WITH A NONPROFIT
WHO BUILDS
THEM IN A SEPARATE BUILDING OR
OFF SITE,
OR THEY PAY IN LIEU FEES TO TRY
TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY CAN ADHERE TO THOSE
STANDARDS.
AND AS YOU KNOW, MANY OF YOU
SAT ON THE SUBCOMMITTEES,
THOSE PROGRAMS,
MOST HAVE BEEN ELIMINATED THIS
YEAR IN YOUR BUDGET.
SO THAT'S NEW INFORMATION FROM
THE PREVIOUS
TIME THAT THIS COMMITTEE HAS
HEARD.
OTHER BILLS THAT ARE SIMILARLY
SITUATED.
$1.1 BILLION HAS BEEN ELIMINATED
IN THE STATE BUDGET
TO TO PAY FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNITS.
SO THESE PROGRAMS ALREADY
DISADVANTAGED
RURAL COMMUNITIES.
AND THOSE PROJECTS AND JUST
THOSE SUBSIDIES
REALLY JUST DON'T EXIST.
SO HOPEFULLY THAT, UM,
HOPEFULLY THE REDUCTION IN
IMPACT FEES,
THE DEFERRAL OF IMPACT FEES
WILL ACTUALLY SAVE MONEY.
COULD YOU IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE,
YOU DON'T HAVE A LOT OF CONTROL
OVER THOSE COSTS.
BUT WHAT YOU DO HAVE CONTROL
OVER IS TIME.
TIME IS MONEY.
IT SEEMS VERY SIMPLE.
THE SAVINGS HERE IS ACTUALLY
THE SAVINGS ON THE INTEREST
PAYMENTS THAT ARE MADE TO
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS,
ON THOSE FUNDS THAT ARE SITTING
AND ARE NOT USED,
UM, IN STATE IN THE, IN THE CITY
BUDGETS.
UM, SO WE HOPE NOW MORE THAN
EVER,
WE NEED YOUR SUPPORT TO DEFER
THESE IMPACT FEE PAYMENTS FOR
EVERY PROJECT IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT IS IN THE
PIPELINE
AND IS NOW IS ON HOLD,
BECAUSE THEY JUST CAN'T FUND
THE PROJECTS GOING FORWARD.
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL?
AB 2729.
YES, MADAM CHAIR MICHAEL
GUNNING,
LIGHTHOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS HERE
ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION,
CALIFORNIA YIMBY.
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY,
CALIFORNIA AND FIELDSTEAD ALL
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT?
SEEING NONE.
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION.
YOU'RE WELCOME TO COME UP TO
THE FRONT.
GO AHEAD.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR MEMBERS
ANTHONY TANNEHILL
WITH CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE IN OPPOSITION TO AB 2729.
WE FIND THAT THE MEASURE,
WHILE THE GOALS ARE AUDIBLE AS
WE TRY TO CONFRONT THESE VERY
REAL ISSUES OF HOUSING,
IS RATHER BROAD AND BLUNT IN
DOING SO.
THE.
HOUSING ISSUE.
UM.
IS WHAT CLEARLY GETS ALL THE
ATTENTION
THAT AND IT DESERVES SO.
BUT IT'S HARD TO CONTEMPLATE.
WITHOUT THE HOUSING
INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUE.
UM.
THESE THINGS NEED TO COME
TOGETHER.
AND THIS MEASURE, WE FIND, IS
JUST A BIT TOO
BROAD AND BLUNT TO ACHIEVE THAT
IN A WAY
THAT HELPS US DELIVER SERVICES
AND INFRASTRUCTURE
FAIRLY ACROSS ALL COMMUNITIES.
AND IT DOES SO IN A FEW
DIFFERENT WAYS.
UM.
THAT LOCAL AGENCIES FIND MAY
SHIFT
SOME OF THE RISK INHERENT
IN DEVELOPMENT FROM THE
MARKETPLACE
INTO THE LOCAL AGENCIES.
UM, SO WITH THAT.
PASS TO MY COLLEAGUE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, BRADY GUERIN,
ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES,
IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL,
ECHOING THE CONCERNS OF CSDA,
BUT ALSO THE CONCERNS OF ONE OF
THE FACTORS THAT WE NOTICED
WITH FEES
AND WITH THE LIMIT ON THE ON
THE PROPOSED
SHOT CLOCK ON LOCAL GOVERNMENTS,
IS IT TAKES MULTIPLE PROJECTS
TO ACHIEVE
THE INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED
TO PROVIDE QUALITY OF LIFE
BENEFITS
TO LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES,
AND WE THINK THAT THIS WOULD
HAVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES FOR
THESE
RURAL COMMUNITIES AND RURAL
CITIES,
AS WELL AS RURAL COUNTIES,
BECAUSE THEY WOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO HAVE
THOSE FEES AVAILABLE SHOULD THEY
NOT BREAK GROUND FROM THE LOCAL
LEVEL
WITHIN TWO YEARS OF DOING THAT,
UNDERSTANDING THAT HOUSING IS
INTENT,
WE ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT FEES ARE
A BIG FACTOR THAT INFLUENCES
THAT.
BUT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS NEED THESE
FEES TO PROVIDE
THE BEST SERVICES FOR THEIR
COMMUNITY.
AND AS A RESULT, WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT
THE SHOT CLOCK ON LOCAL
AGENCIES.
SO WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A NO
VOTE AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
UM, OTHERS, UM, IN OPPOSITION,
PLEASE COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE.
>> ETHAN NAGLER, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RECREATION AND
PARK
DISTRICTS AND THE CITIES OF
BELMONT
AND CARLSBAD AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR,
WITH FRANCO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA
FIRE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION AND
THE FIRE DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION.
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
>> ON IOANNIDIS ON BEHALF OF
LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
MARK NEUBERGER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
UM, HAVING HEARD FROM EVERYONE,
I JUST WANT TO SAY A FEW WORDS
AND.
I KNOW I WAS GOING TO DO IT.
CAN I DO IT FIRST?
OKAY.
UH, YEAH.
I'LL GO AND THEN ASK MY
COLLEAGUES
FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
UM.
UH, I THINK MOST OF US, IF NOT
ALL OF US,
HAVE A SHARED GOAL OF WANTING
TO INCREASE
HOUSING AND ADDRESS THE HOUSING
CRISIS.
UM, WHILE THIS MEASURE WOULD
HELP
DEVELOPERS BY DELAYING, UH,
WHEN THEY HAVE TO PAY IMPACT
FEES,
MANY LOCAL AGENCIES, AS WE'VE
HEARD TODAY,
HAVE RAISED CONCERNS THAT THEY
CANNOT TAKE ON THE ADDITIONAL
RISK OF RECEIVING IMPACT FEES
LATER IN THE IN THE PROCESS.
UH, DESPITE THESE CONCERNS, I
WANTED TO PROVIDE
A PATH FORWARD FOR THE
LEGISLATION.
FOR YOUR LEGISLATION?
UH, ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON,
AS YOU'RE AWARE,
THIS COMMITTEE ASKED FOR
AMENDMENTS ON A RELATED
BILL AUTHORED BY MY COLLEAGUE
FROM
SAN FRANCISCO THAT LIMITED
IMPACT
FEE DEFERRALS TO SMALL PROJECTS
AND PROJECTS WITH SOME
PERCENTAGE
OF DEDICATED, AFFORDABLE UNITS.
WE ASKED FOR THE SAME AMENDMENT
TO YOUR MEASURE TO ENSURE
WHEN WE OFFER BENEFITS TO A
PRIVATE DEVELOPER,
IT COMES WITH PUBLIC BENEFITS.
UM, WHILE I APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO ADDRESS
OTHER ISSUES THAT COMMITTEE
RAISED,
WE WERE NOT ABLE TO COME TO AN
AGREEMENT ON THE KEY
ISSUE AND THE KEY AMENDMENT THAT
FOR THAT REASON,
I AM UNABLE TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY.
UM, I'D OPEN IT UP TO MY OTHER
COLLEAGUES.
SENATOR.
OKAY, SO FORTUNATELY FOR YOU,
I AM VERY, UH,
I'VE HAD A LOT OF EXPERIENCE
WITH
DEVELOPMENT IMPACT FEES.
UH, FROM THE TIME THEY'RE
ACTUALLY DEVELOPED,
THE NEXUS THAT YOU HAVE TO GO
AND ESTABLISH BEFORE
YOU CAN ACTUALLY DECIDE WHAT AN
IMPACT FEE IS,
AND ALSO THE CATEGORIES FOR
THOSE IMPACT FEES.
ONE PROJECT DOES NOT PAY FOR
AN IMPACT.
UH, IT'S USUALLY MULTIPLE
PROJECTS THAT PUT INTO
THE IMPACT INTO THE FEE
AND THAT GOES INTO AN ACCOUNT.
SO WHEN THEY DO HAVE ENOUGH
MONEY,
THEN THEY BUILD WHATEVER IT IS
THAT'S
GOING TO OFFSET THE IMPACTS FOR
SEVERAL PROJECTS ALL TOGETHER.
SO THIS ISN'T, UH, THE CLAIM
THAT SOMEHOW
THIS ONE IMPACT FEE IS GOING
TO PREVENT
THEM FROM BUILDING SOMETHING
AND OFFSETTING
THOSE IMPACTS IS NOT CORRECT.
UM, IF THEY DON'T HAVE THE MONEY
FROM ONE PROJECT,
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE
THE MONEY FROM THE REST OF IT.
UH, THAT MEANS THEY HAVEN'T
COLLECTED ENOUGH
MONEY TO DO THE PROJECT, PERIOD.
SO, UM, FOR, FOR, YOU KNOW, IT'S
REALLY.
ANNOYING TO ME WHEN WE START
MIXING UP WHAT A WHAT A CFD.
AND CFD AND THEN IMPACT FEES
ARE IMPACT FEES ARE ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT THERE FOR BUILDING
FIRE STATIONS.
THEY'RE BUILT FOR BUILDING
ARTERIAL
ROADWAYS THROUGH CITIES.
UM, SO THERE'S A LOT OF
DIFFERENT IMPACT
FEES THAT ARE, THAT ARE
DEVELOPED.
THEY COLLECT THEM.
UM, AND WHEN IT'S TIME TO BUILD,
THEY BUILD THEM.
UM, ALL THIS DOES IS MOVE THE
COLLECTION OF THAT TO
WHEN THEY GET A CERTIFICATE OF
OCCUPANCY, WHICH,
WHICH IS ACTUALLY WHEN THE
IMPACT
STARTS FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
IS THE IMPACT IS FROM THE PEOPLE
MOVING IN AND STARTING
TO FLUSH TOILETS AND STARTING
TO USE WATER AND STARTING
TO DRIVE DOWN THE STREETS
AND STARTING TO USE SCHOOLS.
THAT'S WHEN THE IMPACTS ARE
STARTING TO BE FELT.
AND AND THAT'S PART OF COMMUNITY
PLANNING.
UH, SO BASICALLY WHAT THIS
ARGUMENT IS,
IS WHO GETS TO COLLECT THE
INTEREST
BETWEEN WHEN THE DEVELOPER
STARTS
BUILDING AND WHEN THE DEVELOPER
FINISHES BUILDING
AND SOMEBODY ACTUALLY MOVES IN
TO BEGIN THE IMPACT.
AND THERE HAVE BEEN DEVELOPMENTS
THAT SOMEWHERE
IN BETWEEN THAT THEY GO BANKRUPT
AND THEY SIT THERE FOR YEARS AND
YEARS BECAUSE
THEY PAID ALL THESE IMPACT FEES.
THEY DON'T GET THEM BACK.
AND THEY THEIR, THEIR PROJECT
IS NOW DEAD.
UM, BECAUSE THE ECONOMY TURNED
OR WHATEVER IT IS.
BOTTOM LINE IS, IF IT'S SITTING
DEAD,
THERE AREN'T ANY IMPACTS TO
SCHOOLS
AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
SO WHETHER THEY COLLECT IT IN
THE BEGINNING OR THE END
IS ALL ABOUT WHO MAKES THE
INTEREST IN BETWEEN.
AND THERE'S $20 MILLION OF
IMPACT FEES.
THAT'S A LOT OF INTEREST.
BUT THAT'S FOR ME.
IT'S NOT FAIR FOR A CITY TO
SAY, HEY,
WHILE YOU GUYS HAVE THE PLEASURE
OF BUILDING,
WE'RE GOING TO COLLECT INTEREST
ON YOUR MONEY.
AND THAT'S WHERE THIS LANDS
FOR ME,
IS WE'RE NOT COLLECTING THEY
THEY NEED
THEIR MONEY TO FINISH THIS
PROJECT.
WHETHER IT'S AN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING
PROJECT OR A MARKET RATE
PROJECT,
WHATEVER THE HECK IT IS,
THEY NEED THEIR MONEY UNTIL
THEY'RE DONE.
AND ONCE THEY'RE DONE, THEY TURN
THAT PROPERTY OVER.
THEY GET THEIR CERTIFICATE OF
OCCUPANCY,
AND THEN THEY PAY THEIR FEE
AND THE CITY CAN GO ABOUT.
PUTTING THAT MONEY INTO THE POT
AND BUILDING WHATEVER IT IS
THEY NEED BUILDING WHEN THEY
GET THE REST OF THEIR FEES.
SO.
SO FOR ME, THIS IS JUST A
INSTEAD
OF PAYING IN THE BEGINNING,
THEY PAY AT THE END AND THEY
DON'T WIND
UP HAVING THIS ENORMOUS HOLDING
COSTS,
WHICH CAN INCLUDE A BUNCH OF
DELAYS
CAUSED SOMETIMES BY COMMUNITIES
THEMSELVES OR BY OTHER STUFF
THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE CONTROL OVER.
AND IN THE MEANWHILE,
THEY'RE PAYING THE CARRYING
COSTS.
INTEREST GOES OUT AND OUT AND
OUT ON THESE,
ON THIS, ON THIS MONEY.
SO SO FOR THOSE REASONS, I WAS
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL.
I THINK IT IS A GOOD BILL TO
TRY TO HELP,
ESPECIALLY IN ALL THOSE NARROWED
DOWN
CATEGORIES THAT YOU HAVE NOW.
UH, SO THAT SO THAT THE,
THE PROJECTS HAVE A BETTER
CHANCE
OF GETTING DONE AND,
AND THE CITIES AND THE AGENCIES
WILL STILL GET THEIR DIF MONEY,
THEY WILL STILL GET THEIR DIF
MONEY.
AND, AND THEN THEY CAN BUILD
WHATEVER PROJECTS
IT IS WHEN THEY GET ALL OF THE
MONEY TOGETHER,
WHICH A LOT OF TIMES ISN'T WHEN
THAT PROJECT'S DONE,
IT'S WHEN TEN MORE OTHER
PROJECTS GET DONE.
SO WITH THAT, I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL.
APPRECIATE THAT YOU HAVE BROUGHT
IT
AND YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT
HELPING MOVE SOME OF THESE
PROJECTS
FORWARD BEFORE THEY GO BANKRUPT.
THANKS.
SENATOR SKINNER.
>> SO THANK YOU.
CHAIR.
UH, I DON'T THINK I WOULD HAVE,
UH.
MY COLLEAGUE SENATOR SATO'S
DESCRIPTION OF.
I HEARD A LITTLE TINGE OF, UH,
OF, UH, ANTI-GOVERNMENT,
UH, THERE IN THAT DESCRIPTION.
AND I WAS WITH YOU ANYWAY, I
THINK,
I THINK THE LEGITIMATE ISSUE
THAT YOU CLARIFIED AND WHICH
IS IN THE ANALYSIS ALSO,
IS THAT IN THE SITUATION, WHAT
THE BILL IS DOING
IS IT IS NOT RELIEVING ANYONE
OF FEES.
AND THE IT IS NOT DENYING EITHER
THE SPECIAL DISTRICTS
OR THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS OF
THE FEES.
IT IS A TIMING OF WHEN THE FEES
WILL BE RECEIVED.
AND, UH.
AND THAT.
>> UM.
THERE'S SOME SIMILARITIES TO
THE BILL
THAT SENATOR WIENER DID THAT
WE IN THIS COMMITTEE PASSED
THROUGH
AND THEN SOME NOT BUT.
UM, AND I APPRECIATE, CHAIR,
THAT YOU,
UM, HAD ASKED THE AUTHOR TO, UM,
CONFORM TO HAVE AMENDMENTS
CONFORM TO THE BILL,
AS SENATOR WIENER DID.
BUT AGAIN, THE BILLS ARE NOT,
UM.
THEY'RE NOT THE SAME.
THEY'RE SIMILAR.
AND I WONDERED IF I UNDERSTAND
WHEN THE,
UM, AUTHOR OPENED THAT.
AND I DON'T MEAN TO IN ANY WAY
QUESTION THAT THE,
THE AMENDMENTS YOU ASKED THAT
THE YOU KNOW,
WE DIDN'T REACH A CONCLUSION,
BUT I WONDERED IF THE AUTHOR
COULD
SPEAK TO THE AMENDMENTS,
AMENDMENTS THAT THEY ARE WILLING
TO TAKE.
AND I ASK BECAUSE IF THE BILL
WERE TO MOVE,
IT WOULD GO TO MY COMMITTEE
NEXT.
UM.
SO THERE IS OPPORTUNITY, AT
LEAST TO ENSURE THAT
CONCERNS THAT THIS COMMITTEE HAS
ARE ADDRESSED.
BUT I JUST WANTED TO TO SEE
WHETHER THERE WAS SOME.
ANY ANY OPENNESS THERE FOR.
REACHING SOME CONCLUSIONS.
WELL, THANK YOU, SENATOR
SKINNER.
UM, FIRST OF ALL, UM, THERE ARE
A LOT OF
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE PART OF
SENATOR
WIENER'S BILL IN TERMS OF
CERTAIN FEES
THAT HAVE TO BE PAID UP FRONT,
IN WHICH ONES THAT WOULD PUT THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AT SOME KIND OF OBLIGATION OR,
YOU KNOW, WORK HAS ALREADY
STARTED OR IT'S
GOING TO START OR THEY'RE IN
CONTRACT,
ALL 100% OF THOSE AMENDMENTS,
I'M WILLING TO TAKE ALL OF THEM.
UM, AND THEN THERE WERE SOME
OTHER
ONES THAT I THOUGHT WERE
PRETTY IMPORTANT IN THAT I WOULD
BE WILLING TO ACCEPT.
UH, BUT ALTHOUGH WE DIDN'T, UH,
OBVIOUSLY COME TO CONCLUSION
ON THIS,
BUT WERE TO LIMIT IT TO CITIES
THAT ARE NOT MEETING THEIR,
UM, ANNUAL PERFORMANCE REVIEW
THROUGH HCD.
SO IN OTHER WORDS, THEY'RE NOT
MEETING THE OBLIGATIONS TO,
TO MEET THEIR HOUSING GOALS
THAT THEY
SET AND ACCEPTED AND REZONED
FOR.
UM, AND THEN THIRDLY, ONE THAT
I WAS
INTERESTED IN WAS FOR SCHOOLS.
IF THERE EVER WAS A SCHOOL BOND
TO PASS OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT,
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT SCHOOLS
CAN GET THE MATCHING FUNDS,
BUT WE ARE WILLING AND TO TAKE
ANY AND ALL AMENDMENTS.
THE ONLY THING I THINK WHERE WE
HAD A POLICY
DISAGREEMENT ON WAS THE MARKET
RATE VERSUS,
UM, UH, AFFORDABLE SLASH SB 35
AB 2011 PROJECTS.
PAGE SIX.
SENATOR WIENER.
>> THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
UM, SO THIS IS, UH, THIS BILL
IS A IT'S
AN ODD POSITION FOR ME BECAUSE
I'VE, UM.
ONE OF THE ONE OF THE.
THE MAIN PART OF MY BILL IS
COVERING
SIMILAR GROUND TO THIS.
AND OF COURSE, THE ORIGINAL
VERSION OF
THE BILL THAT I INTRODUCED IS
QUITE SIMILAR
TO WHAT YOU'RE BRINGING TO THE
COMMITTEE
TODAY AND WHAT THE ASSEMBLY
PASSED.
SO OBVIOUSLY THAT'S, UM,
A BILL THAT I PUT MY NAME ON,
AND WE DID WORK OUT AMENDMENTS
WITH THE CHAIR.
AND I APPRECIATE THE CHAIR, UH,
WORKING WITH US, UM, ON THAT.
UM, I WILL SAY THAT THE THAT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT
DID COME OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE,
THERE ARE, UH,
THERE WAS ONE PARTICULAR LATE
SORT OF IT WAS
DEALT WITH IN THE LATER SIDE
THAT REALLY,
UM, HAVE HARMED THE BILL.
UM, AND THAT NEED TO BE FIXED.
AND I'M HOPING THAT WE WILL BE
ABLE TO FIX IT,
BECAUSE MY GOAL HERE IS MY GOAL
HERE IS
TO MAKE SURE THAT HOUSING GETS
BUILT.
WE ARE SHORT MILLIONS OF HOMES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA,
AND RIGHT NOW WE ARE BECAUSE
WE IMPACT FEES ARE THE WILD
WEST IN CALIFORNIA AND THEY ARE
ALL OVER THE MAP.
SOME ARE VERY LOW IN SOME
CITIES,
SOME ARE EXTREMELY HIGH,
AND INTEREST RATES ARE HIGH NOW.
AND WE'RE AND THE HOUSING IS NOT
GETTING BUILT.
AND SO I THINK, YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY
I INTRODUCED A BILL SIMILAR
TO THIS.
SO I BELIEVE THAT IT WILL HELP
IF WE CAN DELAY THE IMPACT FEES.
THEY'LL STILL BE PAID.
UH, AND EVEN THOUGH I REPRESENT
SAN FRANCISCO
AND I'M A BIG BELIEVER IN DENSE
MULTIUNIT HOMES,
AND THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE
TOOK OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
COVER SO MUCH OF WHAT WOULD BE
BUILT IN
AN URBAN SETTING IN TERMS OF
MULTI
UNIT USING A DENSITY BONUS,
USING SB FOUR, TWO, THREE, ETC..
THERE ARE SWATHS OF THE STATE
THAT
RELY ON OTHER FORMS OF OF
HOUSING,
AND I DO THINK THAT THERE IS AN
ARGUMENT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE BEING INCLUSIVE
IN THAT RESPECT.
UM, AND SO I, YOU KNOW, I KNOW
YOU'VE SAID
YOU'RE WILLING TO TAKE
AMENDMENTS
TO THE BILL AS LONG AS IT'S NOT
LIMITING THE KINDS OF HOUSING.
AND I DO THINK SOME OF THOSE
AMENDMENTS
THAT THE THAT WE WORKED
OUT WITH THE CHAIR AND ALSO WITH
OPPOSITION AROUND,
YOU KNOW, IF THERE'S A CASH
FLOW ISSUE FOR THE CITIES,
THOSE FEES SHOULD NOT BE
DELAYED, ETC..
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS
TO CONFORM IN THOSE RESPECTS.
UM, I, UM, I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THIS
BILL MOVE OUT OF COMMITTEE
TODAY.
UM, AND I WOULD LIKE TO SEE US
THEN BE ABLE TO,
TO SPEND THE SUMMER.
UM, WE NOW HAVE BOTH BILLS SORT
OF MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE,
UM, COMPLEMENTING AND,
AND AND MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
DOING
ALL THE THINGS THAT WE NEED
TO DO.
UM, AND TO ME, IT'S NOT ABOUT
WHOSE NAME IS ON WHAT.
I REALLY COULD CARE LESS.
UM, BUT I DO THINK IT WOULD
BE GOOD
FOR THIS BILL TO MOVE FORWARD,
AND THEN WE CAN WORK OUT ISSUES
IN TERMS OF ANY INCONSISTENCIES
BETWEEN THE BILLS OVER THE
SUMMER.
BUT I DO APPRECIATE YOUR DESIRE
NOT TO LIMIT
THE TYPE OF HOUSING THAT'S
COVERED.
AND OBVIOUSLY, I AGREE WITH THAT
BECAUSE
THAT'S THE BILL I ORIGINALLY
INTRODUCED.
UM, SO THAT THAT'S MY, UM, UH,
PERSPECTIVE.
AND I DO APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO TAKE SOME
OF THOSE AMENDMENTS THAT YOU'VE
ENUMERATED.
SENATOR DALY.
I'D JUST LIKE TO JUST WEIGH IN
FOR REAL QUICK.
I SUPPORTED THE SENATOR WEINER'S
BILL,
AND WHEN HE CAME TO ME,
I CAME OUT OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
WHERE WE DID DEVELOPMENTS ALL
THE TIME AND AND REPRESENTED
SPECIAL
DISTRICTS AND ALL THAT.
SO I GET THAT PART OF IT.
AND IT IS, I THINK, A LOT ABOUT
INTEREST
AND TIMING AND ALL THOSE THINGS.
AND I THINK WITH THE MARKETS THE
WAY THEY ARE
AND WITH THE INTEREST, THE WAY
THEY ARE,
AND WITH THE REGULATIONS WE HAVE
IN CALIFORNIA
AND HOW DIFFICULT IT IS TO BUILD
HOMES.
I MEAN, I THINK IT WAS JUST
LAST WEEK
AT THE MEDIAN HOME PRICE IS
900,000,
AND YOU'RE TALKING REAL MONEY
TO PUT HOUSES UP.
AND WE HAVE A HUGE HOUSING
SHORTAGE.
SO TO ME HOUSING IS HOUSING.
MORE HOUSING MEANS MORE MORE ON
THE MARKET SUPPLY AND DEMAND.
UM, SO I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THIS
BILL MOVE FORWARD.
I DON'T KNOW THE INTRICACIES
OF THE BILL,
BUT I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE IT MOVE
FORWARD.
AND AND WE HAVE A MONTH HERE
TO WORK
IT OUT BEFORE WE COME BACK.
AND MAYBE THAT CAN BE THAT COULD
BE A POSSIBILITY TO SEE.
BUT I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TO GET IT MOVING.
AND I THINK IT'S THE CONCEPT'S
RIGHT.
AND WE CAN GET THE DETAILS
WORKED
OUT ON THE TWO BILLS.
AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN BUILD
SOME HOUSES IN CALIFORNIA.
YEAH.
I JUST WANT TO RESPOND A LITTLE
BIT TO SOME OF THE COMMENTS.
I MEAN, THE I AS I REMEMBER THE
PRIMARY
REASON WE WENT TO THE TEN
UNITS OR LESS WAS TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE OF THE RURAL AREAS.
SO THAT WAS A THAT WAS A VERY
SPECIFIC THING.
I YOU KNOW, I APPRECIATE THAT
YOUR WILLINGNESS,
UH, TO LOOK AT AMENDMENTS.
BUT THE KEY ISSUE HERE IS WHAT
YOU'RE UNWILLING TO DO,
WHICH IS WHY I ALLOWED YOU AND
SAID,
OKAY, LET'S HAVE THE HEARING.
BUT YOU WERE UNWILLING TO MOVE
ON THE KEY ISSUE.
SO AMENDMENTS THAT THAT WE COULD
PLAY
AROUND WITH STILL DON'T GO TO
THE COURT BECAUSE YOU WERE
UNWILLING
TO LOOK AT THAT KEY ISSUE.
SO I DON'T SEE WHERE WE GO WITH
THIS WITHOUT
YOUR AGREEMENT ON THE KEY ISSUE.
THEN WE CAN GO TO THE TO THE
OTHER AMENDMENTS
THAT YOU'RE WILLING TO, TO,
TO TAKE.
UM, I DON'T KNOW IF ANY OF THE
OPPOSITION
WANT TO ADDRESS ANY OF THESE
ISSUES.
YEAH, I'LL JUST SAY THAT I
THINK, YOU KNOW,
APPRECIATE THE DEBATE ABOUT
THIS.
I THINK THE REALITY IS, IS FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS,
WE'RE IN A TIGHT SPOT.
AND EVEN THE HOUSING ELEMENT,
YOU KNOW,
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THE MEMBER
PUT FORWARD
WOULD BE VERY CONCERNING FOR
THE LEAGUE,
MOSTLY BECAUSE A LOT OF OUR
CITIES
ARE STRUGGLING AND THAT'S
KIND OF OUT OF OUR CONTROL
WITH A LOT OF THAT ASPECT.
BUT I THINK THE REALITY IS,
IS WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT.
MITIGATION FEES.
CURRENT LAW ALREADY HAS SOME
LANGUAGE
THAT HAS A SHOT CLOCK FOR FIVE
YEARS.
WE ALSO HAVE THE ABILITY UNDER
CURRENT LAW THAT ALLOWS US,
IF WE HAVE A CONSTRUCTION PLAN
OR SCHEDULE,
TO COLLECT THE FEES EARLIER,
AND THIS BILL WOULD REMOVE THAT.
AND THAT'S VERY CONCERNING,
BECAUSE A LOT OF OUR CITIES ARE
DOING THEIR
BEST TO PROVIDE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDED TO THEIR COMMUNITIES,
AND WE'RE CONCERNED THAT
DELAYING THAT WOULD
DELAY THE INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS
THAT ARE NEEDED TO GET PEOPLE
TO MOVE
INTO THESE COMMUNITIES TO MAKE
IT,
YOU KNOW, AFFORDABLE AND SAFE
FOR PEOPLE TO MOVE INTO.
SO THAT'S WHERE THAT'S WHERE
CAL CITIES IS COMING FROM.
BUT I THINK IN GENERAL, YOU
KNOW,
THAT'S WHERE OUR MAIN CONCERNS
LIE ON.
YEAH.
UM, THAT'S THE KEY ISSUE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
A LITTLE CONFUSED BECAUSE.
I'M SORT OF TRYING TO READ
BETWEEN THE LINES,
BUT I'M IF I LOOK AT THE
ANALYSIS,
IT SEEMS THAT IT'S.
YOU SPEAK UP.
YES.
LOOKING AT THE ANALYSIS NUMBER
FOUR ON PAGE SIX,
THAT THE AMENDMENTS THERE IS
WHAT IT SEEMS
THOSE IF I UNDERSTAND YOU
CORRECT,
CHAIR, THAT'S WHAT YOU YOU WERE
FEELING WAS
THE KEY ISSUE THAT THAT THE
AUTHOR HADN'T TAKEN.
RIGHT.
OKAY.
BUT I'M SORRY, SPECIAL
DISTRICTS,
BUT, UH, I DID NOT.
IT'S YOUR ISSUE.
SEEM TO BE IN GENERAL ON THE
INABILITY
THAT YOU WANTED THE FEES IN
ADVANCE.
AND OF COURSE, WHILE THIS WOULD
BE FEWER HOUSING
UNITS THAT YOU DIDN'T GET THE
FEES IN ADVANCE,
YOU WOULD STILL NOT BE GETTING
THE FEES IN ADVANCE.
THE SO I, I DON'T I MEAN SPECIAL
DISTRICTS
YOU'RE AGNOSTIC ABOUT WHETHER
HOUSING AND I'M NOT SAYING I'M
NOT
TRYING TO YOU JUST WANT THE
FEES.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT KIND OF
WHAT THE CONSTRUCTION IS.
SO I THINK WEIGHING IN ON
WHETHER THIS APPLIES
TO THE TYPE OF HOUSING IT
APPLIES TO.
UM, CERTAINLY YOU CAN HAVE AN
OPINION,
BUT I DON'T THINK IT'S GERMANE
PER
SE FOR THE SPECIAL DISTRICTS.
MADAM CHAIR.
MR.
MAYOR.
YES.
GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR.
UM.
THE COMMUNITIES CREATE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS TO PROVIDE SERVICES,
AND THE VOTER CREATES THEM AND
AND TAXES THEMSELVES.
AND THE THE TYPES OF
DEVELOPMENTS,
I THINK ARE OF INTEREST TO THE
SERVICE PROVIDER.
UM, WHEN YOU'RE DEALING WITH
CAPACITY CALLS FOR SERVICE,
WHAT KIND OF APPARATUS?
YOU MIGHT NEED TO SAY,
FIGHT A FIRE OR OR PUMP OUT A
SEWER?
UM, I DO THINK THAT IT IS OF
INTEREST.
AND WITH INFLATION.
FIRE OR PUMPING A SEWER IS GOING
TO BE REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
IT'S A LOW INCOME UNIT OR A
MARKET UNIT, BUT.
AND AND WITHIN.
AND WITH INFLATION.
SENATOR, I THINK THE THE TIMING
CAN MATTER, RIGHT?
FIRE TRUCKS AND APPARATUS DON'T
GET TWO CHEAPER OVER TIME.
AND SO IF.
THESE THINGS GO IN THESE FUNDS
GO INTO A SEPARATE ACCOUNT
WITH THE COUNTY WHERE THEY'RE
AUDITED AND REVIEWED,
AND YOU REPORT OUT ON WHAT
PROJECTS
HAVE BEEN COMPLETED
AND WHEN AND IF THERE'S ANY
EXCESS FUNDS,
AND THERE'S ACTUALLY A MECHANISM
TO REFUND THAT.
AND THAT'S ALL IN THE MITIGATION
FEE ACT ALREADY.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT ADDRESSES.
THE MAY I RESPOND.
TO THAT?
WHAT DOES THAT HAVE TO REALLY
MATTER?
>> MATTER AND THIS MATTERS.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
FOR A TWO MINUTE RECESS,
AND THEN WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND.
UH, THANK YOU, EVERYBODY, FOR
YOUR REALLY,
REALLY EXTRAORDINARY PATIENCE
HERE.
UM, WE'VE COME, I THINK, UH,
TO AN AGREEMENT ON SOME
AMENDMENTS.
SO LET ME JUST READ THEM OUT.
THE AUTHOR ACCEPTS ALL COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS NUMBER FOUR ON PAGES
FOUR AND FIVE ON COMMENTS NUMBER
FOUR AND FIVE OF THE ANALYSIS.
THAT'S THE ONE.
AND THE SECOND IS ONE ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENT TO EXTEND DEVELOPMENT
ENTITLEMENTS BY 18 MONTHS ON
ALL PROJECTS.
UM.
I'M SORRY TO BE TAKEN UP.
>> SO IN ORDER TO GET IT, TO
SEND IT OUT.
HERE THAT WE SHOULD ALSO PUT ON
THE RECORD.
THIS WILL BE A DUE PASS TO
HOUSING.
UM.
MR..
ASSEMBLYMAN.
YES, I ACCEPT THOSE AMENDMENTS.
AND, UM, DO YOU WANT ME TO JUST
GIVE
A CLOSING STATEMENT NOW OR.
HOWEVER.
BUT I DO ACCEPT THEM.
OKAY.
AND, UM, I APPRECIATE THE WORK
AND THE DELIBERATION ON THIS.
AND I THINK IT JUST GOES TO SHOW
THAT, YOU KNOW,
WE'RE SERIOUS POLICY MAKERS
AND WE'RE
TRYING TO WORK THINGS OUT.
AND, UM, YOU KNOW, JUST REALLY
THANK
EVERYBODY AND ESPECIALLY YOU
FOR,
FOR WORKING WITH ME ON IT.
OKAY.
WE HAVE A NEED, A MOTION.
SENATOR DASCHLE, WITH ALL THE
AMENDMENTS.
UM.
IT'S THE IT'S THE MOTION IS
REFERRED TO HOUSING
WITH THE AMENDMENTS TO BE TAKEN
IN HOUSING.
OKAY.
THE MOTION IS TO DO BEST.
DO.
CAN I JUST CLARIFY?
YES.
SO YES, SENATOR.
SO WE'RE NOT CREATING A
DIFFERENTIAL
BASED ON THE TYPE OF HOUSING.
THE TRADE OFF IS THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO REQUIRE THAT THEY
EXTEND THE ENTITLEMENTS FOR
18 MONTHS FOR ALL HOUSING.
YES.
AND, UH, REQUIRE THE DEFERRAL
OF FEES FOR ALL HOUSING.
YES.
NO.
SO I'M UNCLEAR.
FOR CONFORMED TO.
A NUMBERS DON'T HELP ME THERE.
CONFORM TO WHAT CAME OUT OF.
SORRY.
I DON'T WANT TO TALK OVER.
YEAH.
ARE YOURS.
SO IF I MAY, UM.
SO THE THE THERE WILL BE A CLEAN
18 MONTH EXTENSION
FOR PERMITS FOR ALL FORMS OF
HOUSING.
AND THE AUTHOR IS ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS ON THE FEE DEFERRAL,
UH, INCLUDING, AMONG OTHER
THINGS,
TO LIMIT THE TYPES OF HOUSING
SO IT WOULD
BE CONFORMED TO THE BILL THAT
THAT
I'M AUTHORING THAT PASSED OUT
OF THIS
COMMITTEE ON THE FEE DEFERRALS.
UM, AND THEN GOING FORWARD IN
THE FUTURE, WE WILL, UH,
IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE
COMMITTEE,
WORK EVERYTHING OUT BETWEEN
THE TWO.
>> BILLS.
OKAY.
SO I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY.
BUT I'M GOING TO WITHHOLD THE
OPPORTUNITY
TO TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT COMES
OUT.
IF IT WAS TO COME OUT OF
HOUSING,
EXACTLY WHAT ALL THAT MEANS.
AND I APPRECIATE THE EARNEST
WORK
BY THE AUTHOR AND THE CHAIR.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
SENATOR GLAZER,
ALSO FOR YOUR HELP.
SENATOR WAHEEB.
>> I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO RECESS
FOR YOUR TWO MINUTES.
YOU WANT TO RECESS AGAIN, BUT.
YOU'RE I'M JUST JOKING WITH YOU.
OKAY?
OKAY.
YOUR TWO MINUTES LASTED FOREVER.
OKAY?
I JUST OKAY, YOU KNOW?
SO, UM, I WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR WORKING WITH OUR
CHAIR.
I WANT TO THANK STAFF AND
OBVIOUSLY
ALL THE SENATORS.
OUR TWO MINUTES LASTED A VERY
LONG TIME,
BUT I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS.
ORIGINALLY, I WAS VERY
CONCERNED.
I THINK I WAS MORE CONCERNED
WITH
THE HOUSING PIECE OF IT, UM,
WHICH WE'RE GOING TO AGAIN
ESTABLISH
IN HOUSING COMMITTEE,
WHICH I ALSO SIT ON.
SO I DO JUST WANT TO LET YOU
KNOW THAT,
BUT I'M HAPPY TO ALSO VOTE TO
GET IT OUT
OF COMMITTEE WITH THE AMENDMENTS
THAT YOU'VE
ACCEPTED AND THE CHAIR PUT
FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU URGE.
AND I VOTE.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
HOUSING COMMITTEE.
SENATORS DURAZZO I DURAZZO I.
SATO.
SATO, I.
DOLLY.
DOLLY I.
GLASER.
GLASER, I.
SKINNER.
SKINNER I.
WAHAB.
WAHAB I WIENER.
I WIENER I.
7 TO 0.
RULE IS CLOSED.
IS THAT THE LAST BILL TO CLOSE?
UM.
IS THAT IT?
NO, WAIT.
STEVE.
NO!
STEVE!
OH.
DID HE LEAVE?
OH, SHIT.
SORRY.
WAIT.
>> WE NEED TO GET HIM BACK.
YEAH.
THE VOTE IS CLOSED ON THIS.
WE NEED TO DO IT THROUGH.
OH, OH.
SORRY.
OKAY.
WHICH ONES DO WE GO BACK TO?
ALL OF THEM?
YES.
EXCEPT FOR.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT, WE'RE LIFTING, UM,
THE VOTES ON ITEM NUMBER FOUR.
START WITH NUMBER FOUR.
RIGHT.
UM, STARTING WITH NUMBER FOUR,
AB 1807.
BY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 2 WITH NO
CURRENT VOTE FOR THE CHAIR.
SENATORS.
DURAZZO.
DURAZZO I WAHAB.
WAHAB I FIGURE TWO.
CLOSE THE ROLLS.
ITEM FIVE A AB 1801.
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACKSON.
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 5 TO 0.
NO CURRENT VOTE FOR THE CHAIR.
SENATORS DURAZZO I, DURAZZO I,
WAHAB I, WAHAB I 7 TO 0.
OKAY.
BILL IS OUT.
ITEM SEVEN AB 1827 SIX.
OH SIX.
OH, SORRY.
I'M SORRY.
ITEM SIX AB 1819.
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WALDRON.
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
CURRENT VOTE IS 5 TO 0.
NO CURRENT VOTE FOR THE CHAIR.
SENATORS DURAZZO I, DURAZZO I,
WAHAB I WAHAB I 7 TO 0.
THOSE ARE OLD.
DOLLARS, AND I.
UM.
ITEM 7AB 1827.
CALL THE ROLL.
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER PEPIN.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR.
CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 2.
NO CURRENT VOTE FOR THE CHAIR.
SENATORS.
DURAZZO.
DURAZZO I SKINNER.
SKINNER I WAHAB I.
WAHAB I FEIJOO.
TO.
CLOSE THE ROLL.
UH, NEXT IS ITEM TEN A B 2522.
OH, WHY DO I KEEP SKIPPING?
DID I SKIP?
YES, I SKIPPED NINE.
OKAY.
ITEM 9AB 1950 BY ASSEMBLY.
MEMBER WENDY CARRILLO.
MOTION IS TO PASS THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 0.
THE CURRENT VOTE FOR THE CHAIR.
SENATORS.
DURAZZO.
DURAZZO I SARTO.
SKINNER.
SKINNER I WAHAB I WAHAB I
WIENER.
WIENER I 6 TO 0.
CLOSE THE ROLL.
ITEM TEN.
AB 2522.
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
CURRENT VOTE IS 123.
NO CURRENT VOTE FOR THE CHAIR.
SENATORS DURAZZO.
DURAZZO I SKINNER.
SKINNER I WAHAB.
1010 2522.
AND YOU'RE A NO.
OH, AND I.
ALDI AND I.
THIS IS A COURTESY.
I JUST WANT THE AUTHOR TO KNOW.
THANK YOU.
WAHAB, I 43.
ITEM 11 AB 2387.
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLERIN.
MOTION IS TO PASS THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0, WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I.
SENATOR SKINNER.
SKINNER I WAHAB.
WAHAB I.
WIENER.
WIENER I 7 TO 0.
ITEM 12 AB 335.
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLERIN.
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0, WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATOR SKINNER.
SKINNER I WAHAB.
WAHAB I WIENER.
WIENER I 7 TO 0.
CLOSE THE ROLL.
ITEM 15.
ITEM 15 AB 2457.
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 0 WITH NO
CURRENT VOTE FOR THE CHAIR.
SENATORS DURAZZO I DURAZZO I
SKINNER.
SKINNER I WAHAB.
WAHAB I WIENER.
WIENER I 7 TO 0.
QUANTUM.
ITEM SIX, ITEM 16, AB 2488.
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING.
CURRENT VOTE IS 1 TO 1.
THE CURRENT VOTE FOR THE CHAIR.
SENATORS DURAZZO I.
DURAZZO I DOLLY.
SKINNER.
SKINNER I WAHAB.
WAHAB I WIENER.
WIENER I 5 TO 1.
ITEM 17 AB 2632.
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON.
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 0.
NO CURRENT VOTE FOR THE CHAIR.
SENATORS DURAZZO I DURAZZO I.
SKINNER.
SKINNER I WAHAB.
WAHAB NO.
WIENER.
WIENER I 6 TO 1.
ITEM 19 A B 2682.
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 2.
NO CURRENT VOTE FOR THE CHAIR.
SENATORS DURAZZO I DURAZZO I
WAHAB.
WAHAB I SIX.
NO.
5 TO 2.
ITEM 20 AB 3122.
VISALIA, COLORADO, PASSES.
A MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 5 TO 0.
NO CURRENT VOTE FOR THE CHAIR.
SENATORS DURAZZO I, DURAZZO I,
WAHAB I, WAHAB I 7 TO 0.
CLOSE THE ROLL.
ITEM 20 2AB 2946.
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER VALENCIA.
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 1 WITH NO
CURRENT VOTE FOR THE CHAIR.
SENATOR DURAZZO I DURAZZO I.
SKINNER.
SKINNER I WAHAB WAHHAB I WIENER.
WIENER I 6 TO 1.
CLOSE THE ROLL.
ITEM 24 AB 3130.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR.
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0.
BUT THE CHAIR VOTING I, SENATOR
SKINNER.
SKINNER I WAHAB WAHHAB I WIENER.
WIENER I 7 TO 0.
UH, WE HAVE A MOTION FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
OKAY.
WE NEED TO VOTE.
MOTION IS ADOPTED.
CONSENT CALENDAR.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 0.
SENATORS DURAZZO I, DURAZZO I
SKINNER.
SKINNER I WAHAB.
WAHHAB I WIENER.
WIENER I 7 TO 0.
ALL RIGHT, WE'RE DONE WITH THE
AGENDA.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH.
I'M SORRY.
YES.
WE GOT EVERYTHING.
THANK YOU TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WERE PATIENT,
WHO PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY.
IF YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY,
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
WRITING IN WRITING TO THE SENATE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU EVERYONE.
WE HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA.